[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous ravis de vous
retrouver sur public sénat pour vous
faire vivre l'un des événements phares
de la semaine au sénat votre rendez vous
du mercredi les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
on est ensemble tout l'après midi avec
nos journalistes quand un calme est
alexandre poussard mais aussi jean mas
saint quentin vous êtes dans l'hémicycle
doute vous allez nous analyser les
questions alors qu'ils y at-il au menu
et bien tam je ne vais pas vous
surprendre une large partie de ces
questions d'actualité vont être
consacrés à la crise sanitaire actuelle
à quelques heures de la prise de parole
du chef de l'état pour résumer si
questions seront directement consacrée à
la gestion de la crise mais plusieurs
autres thèmes annexes vont s'ajouter je
vous le donne en vrac deux questions
consacré aux vaccins deux autres à la
tension avec la turquie une sur le
terrorisme ou encore sur l'assurance
chômage
il ya donc aussi quelques surprises
merci beaucoup quentin à tout à l'heure
alexandre vous êtes vous à salle des
conférences souvent passé les ministres
et les sénateurs pour toutes les
réactions alors un aperçu de vous
inviter cet après midi mais bien comme
je serai d'abord avec la co rapporteur
de la commission d'enquêté du sénat sur
la gestion de la crise du cornet à virus
on parlera bien sûr du prochain
confinement que pourrait annoncer le
président la république
ce soir je serai également avec le
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères du sénat christian cambon
pour parler de la montée des tensions
entre la turquie et la france après les
nouvelles caricatures de charlie hebdo
sur le président turc erdogan
merci alexandre et à tout à l'heure et
enfin le streamer politique jean mas qui
est déjà en train de parler de cette
séance à venir avec sa communauté sur la
plateforme twitch et il va nous dire ce
qui interpelle les internautes les
streamer cet après-midi dans une
demi-heure notre face à face david
assouline sénateur socialiste face aux
sénateurs les républicains alain opère
on va parler avec eux de l'aco vide
on va insister sur l'impact que cela va
avoir sur l'activité du parlement
[Musique]
mais d'abord on va parler des très
nombreuses pistes évoquées aujourd'hui
alors qu emmanuel macron annonce ce soir
de nouvelles restrictions
face à la hausse exponentielle de
l'épidémie nous nous apprêtons une
nouvelle fois à restreindre nos libertés
face aux impératifs de sécurité
sanitaire on va parler de tout cela avec
rachid tu es mal bonjour sénateur
socialiste du val d'oise également avec
nos olivier paccaud bonjour vous êtes
sénateur l air de l'oise je précise que
vous êtes membre de la commission
denquête qu'ovide et en visio et
qu'ovide oblige nous sommes également
avec le constitutionnaliste didier moss
bonjour là bonjour nous sommes également
avec benjamin morel benjamin morel qui
est maître de conférences en droit
public à l'université paris ii panthéon
assas
le voilà bonjour benjamin et a tout de
suite puisqu'on va commencer par revenir
sur la fin du consensus politique qui
marque cette séquence
hier les responsables politiques ont été
consultés par le gouvernement et ils
n'ont pas ménagé leurs critiques gérer
mais iceman comme l'impression d'être
venu pour rien à la sortie de la réunion
avec jean castex les présidents de
groupes parlementaires ne cachaient pas
leur colère
on nous dit on vous réunis pour donner
un avis un avis sur quoi on le sait pas
et on vous dit bon ben el presidente
façon il ya un conseil de défense encore
demain matin il vous le saurez demain
soir le président va vous le dire bon
nous sommes venus en responsabilité pour
accompagner les informations qui nous
ont été données malheureusement elles
sont très largement suffisante pour que
la représentation nationale puisse faire
correctement son travail
une nouvelle fois l'exécutif échouent à
trouver un consensus politique
mais il estime ne pas avoir manqué de
transparence envers les parlementaires
le pr ministre a été très clair dans
l'état des lieux qu'il a fait sur la
situation de l'épidémie en europe comme
en france il a été très clair aussi sur
les mesures qu'il est possible de
prendre pour freiner davantage la
progression de l'épidémie
moi je m'étonne que ceux là même qui
appelle à la concertation et c'est
normal vous
non à la concertation semble regretter
que les décisions n'ait pas été prise
avant même que les réunions se tiennent
en leur présence après deux conseil de
défense en deux jours emmanuel macron
annoncera ce soir de nouvelles mesures
fortes
face à la flambée de l'épidémie la piste
d'un confinement nationale de quatre
semaines avec le maintien des écoles
ouvertes semble privilégiée pour les
chefs de partis d'opposition
c'est le résultat d'un manque
d'anticipation du gouvernement
s'il prend des décisions difficiles
c'est d'abord le fruit de ses errements
et de sa propre responsabilité et nous
ne voulons pas qu'il demande à toute la
représentation nationale ou aux autres
formations politiques d'endosser une
responsabilité qui est d'abord la sienne
on aurait pu penser que on tirerait les
leçons de la première vague l'arrêter
c'est que on se retrouve dans une
situation pire
à l'aube de cette deuxième vague la
france a enregistré 523 décès liés aux
kovy 19 ans 24 heures du jamais vu
depuis le mois d'avril
rachid tu es mal on entend donc
l'opposition ont unanimement critique
voulait rejoignez-vous dans ses
critiques que l'on a pu entendre hier
soir d'abord il faut dire un mot je
rappelle qu'en début juillet le premier
choisi comme le président pardon choisi
comme premier ministre monsieur
déconfinement oui jean castex ce castex
le 14 juillet le prénom publique rai me
répond jeunesse en disant que la france
est prête
quelques mois plus tard nous y sommes
chacun peut constater que nous on n'est
pas prêt que le déconfinement c'est donc
mal passé je reprends un exemple le val
d'oise mon département 58 lits en
réanimation au mois de mars 58
aujourd'hui donc à partir de là mon idée
c'est pas de taper son gouvernement
je crois qu'à une crise très dure je
crois que ondes aux responsabilités aux
français une responsabilité et donc on
prend les mesures efforts allaient
prendre ce qu'on dit c'est quoi une
réunion comme celle là évidemment il n'y
a pas de concertation d'ailleurs la
vérité c'est que on va tous attendre la
parole et que le débat aura lieu peu
après à l'assemblée
vous parlez au sénat et à l'assemblée je
me fais pas ça servait d'y aller y âge
d'aller au delà de sa circulaire
abandonnés soit le gouvernement fait le
choix de la totale transparence et
associer les forces politiques les
forces vives du pays à alger son crise
qui va et dans la durée il faut que nous
apprenions à vivre collectivement avec
ce virus là ça veut dire des mesures
structurelles au moins pour un temps
moyen terme sur les questions sociales
sur les questions économiques
secteur et ses terres au joli n'ya pas
cela on va nous faire voter sur un plan
encore une fois d'urgence l'état
d'urgence juste un mot
mais aujourd'hui 60 ordonnances prises
dans les premiers textes qui sont ou pas
appliquées donc et pas d'urgence
oui tout ça n'est pas très sérieux donc
je pense que l'art est un mythe
aujourd'hui également c'est maintenant
dire très sérieusement arrêté c'est tout
neuf ans après l'échec des tests l'échec
des masques il faudrait pas qu'un nouvel
échec devant nous je vous fait réagir
olivier paccaud aussi à cette une de
libération
aujourd'hui à libération qui dit et bien
jean castex et c'était monsieur
déconfinement maintenant c'est monsieur
reconfirme ans est-ce que c'est cela
aussi c'est l'échec du déconfinement ce
à quoi nous assistons aujourd'hui
faudrait pas que ça devienne monsieur
des confiné maintenant très sincèrement
je suis sur la même longueur d'onde que
que rachid tu es mal et moi aussi ce qui
m'avait frappé c'était la déclaration
présidentielle martial le 14 juillet
nous serons prêts ouais et
malheureusement c'est un constat c'est
même pas une critique c'est un constat
nous ne sommes pas prêts alors que nous
avons vécu mars avril mai que nous avons
accumulé des stocks que nous n'avions
pas de masque que nous avons des tests
mais finalement tout s'est répandue est
aujourd'hui la situation est plus grave
en fait parce qu' elle n'est plus
localisées sur quelques grands foyers
comme c'était le cas au printemps sur
allant de l'oise j'étais concerné mais
donc les autres ans l'ile-de-france et
levante est aujourd'hui on en a un petit
peu partout et c'est vrai que on sent
une forme de ventes panique aujourd'hui
qui souffle au sein du gouvernement en
ce qui concerne la réunion d'hier je
comprends le mécontentement des chefs de
parti des chefs de groupes qui ont été
consultés entre guillemets au plus tôt
informé ce que on a vu gabriella talent
s'exprimer il n'a pas forcément la même
définition du mot concertation à la
concertation c'est dialoguer discuter
décider ensemble mais là si il s'agit
d'être en quelque sorte une chambre
d'enregistrement
ce n'a jamais été là je sais pas si
c'est la chambre d'enregistrement hier
c'est plutôt qu' il ya un manque même
d'information finalement votre
profession des options n'est pas
ne sort pas de la appris beaucoup de
choses et c'est effectivement assez
inquiétant alors nous aurons à nous
exprimer et à voter on va voir demain
nous sommes très impatients d'entendre
ce que va dire le président de la
république
alors on va également les bars benjamin
morel benjamin comment analysez-vous ce
flot de critiques on vient de les
entendre de la part de l'opposition en
effectivement plus loin très loin de
cette atmosphère plutôt d'unité
nationale qui avait prévalu au printemps
dernier alors elle avait prévalu elle
avait fait rapidement on peut hein je
vous rappelle que les débats publics les
débats politiques ont été assez vives
fin du grand le confinement avec
notamment dans le cas français et
particularités assénait c'est à dire que
les élus locaux aujourd'hui
appartiennent à des formations qui ont
peu de rapport avec la formation pour un
niveau national et une formation au
niveau national qui a peu de relais
locaux et donc on a eu vraiment un
affront en politique très entre deux
strates entre deux strates qu'on ne
connaît pas dans les autres pays
c'était une c'est vraiment quelque chose
que qui est assez inédit en france en
dans l'ensemble des pays européens et
dans l'ensemble des pays occidentaux
aujourd'hui vous avez un sujet qu vide
qui est un sujet réellement de position
politique un sujet aujourd'hui fait la
campagne en roumanie
il fait également on en parle beaucoup
la campagne aux états unis on voit
qu'elle est ensuite très politique très
très forte en italie également en
allemagne 1 même si on a une vision un
peu ironique de la vie politique
allemande
donc il ya des tensions ces tensions
elles sont présentes elles sont au fond
elles sont inhérentes elles ne sont pas
propre à la france
ce qui est vrai en revanche c'est que on
a en france une méthode de consultation
on va dire très bonne à partie avec un
chef de l'état qui non seulement annonce
l'ensemble des mesures avec une sorte de
création d'innovation qui n'était
présent du parquet non mais le conseil
de défense qui semble s'être substitué
en tout cas s'être additionné aux autres
pouvoirs constitués et de l'autre une
volonté bien de ne pas aller
dans des annonces qui précéderait la
parole présidentielle de donner toujours
au président la primeur des annonces et
donc à partir de là des consultations
qui ne peuvent pas être dorée elle
consultation étant donné qu'il ne
faudrait pas surtout informer les
formations politiques des décisions en
cours leur permettent d'être informé
également pour les élever au cou et de
rentrer dans un processus de
concertation ce qu'ils fréquentent suite
est bien quand le président parlera et
tout pourrait déjà été décidé sur tout
aurait déjà chuté
donc cette méthode très verticale très
bonne ap artistes de gouvernance dans la
crise elle peut avoir des intérêts
lorsqu'il s'agit de réagir vite
mais lorsque vous devez construire du
consensus elles s'avèrent
fondamentalement délétère et on peut en
effet comprendre et bien le profond
mécontentement des chefs de partis
didier mau c'est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec l'analyse de benjamin
morel voir en tout cas que à la crise
sanitaire et bien s'ajoute en plus c'est
bien ces difficultés cette crise
politique est là dessus aussi bien cette
deuxième vague paraît plus compliquée
encore que la première
c'est normal qu'il y ait un débat
politique je veux dire le sujet
politique c'est comment faire pour
sauver la vie des français donc là on
est au coeur de la mission de l'état la
mission des hommes et des femmes
politiques c'est faire en sorte
d'assurer la sécurité des uns et des
autres et quand on voit les chiffres
d'hier où on est inquiet alors on est
aussi sous la 5ème république on n'est
pas dans un régime parlementaire de type
italien espagnol ou allemand
on a un président de la république il a
été élu et on a une constitution qui dit
à l'article 20 le gouvernement détermine
et conduit la politique de la nation
je crois qu'il faut toujours s'en
souvenir alors c'est vrai que le système
est très verticale mais est ce qu'il
peut en être autrement
en réalité dans la mesure où nous avons
élu un président de la république pour
qu'ils prennent les grandes décisions et
si on les annonce avant qu'il parle à
quoi cela sert-il qu'il prenne la parole
donc on est dans une contradiction ne
peut pas en même temps essayé de
diffuser la concertation et de dire il
appartient au président de la république
de tout dire voilà je crois que c'est
typiquement la vème république il faut
en prendre son parti
en plus on est dans un sujet qui
fondamentalement régalien
fondamentalement de la survie
des uns et des autres et là il faut être
tous étonnés de ce qui se passe oui
puisque la tension il n'y a pas d'un
côté une crise sanitaire et puis des
gens qui seraient dans le débat
politique
on va dire politiciens des choses
simples il ya une crise qui est devant
nous je prends un exemple concret sur la
question sociale
il ya aujourd'hui c'est pas moi qui le
dis il ya plein d'études il ya un
million de français qui basculent dans
la pauvreté liées à ce corps moi je veux
dans mon département je veux dire les
endroits où les restos du coeur haute
c'est quand même une a de plus en plus
les gens viennent et c'est là il ya un
débat de savoir quelles sont les mesures
comprend vous par exemple les gens du
pouvoir de vivre la cdt d'autres
variations etc font des propositions
comme moi je soutiens sur l'augmentation
du rsa sur les rsa jeunes etc pour pour
passer cette crise c'est un vrai débat
de fond
on a droit de la voir il faudrait pas
qu'ils aient une crise et tout le monde
sache les débats mais sinon c'est sûr il
faut que ça prenne des décisions comme
gîte à l'heure aujourd'hui on va être
dans une forme de normalité du vrai que
kovy dournes a droit d'avoir un débat
est portée petit public
rachid les mâles parle de crise
économique crise sociale
j'ai entendu parler de crise politique
il ya une crise sanitaire
il ya une crise morale il ya une crise
identitaire on est dans un pays qui
malheureusement fait face à une hydre de
crise et les français face à sas ont
totalement inquiète perdu déboussolés
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont l'impression
que ya pas de cap
ils ne savent pas où va le pays est en
fait une crise de gouvernance d'une
certaine façon
alors je ne dis pas que la situation est
aisé pour le président de la république
met à avoir trop usé du verbe et avoir
pris des mesures contradictoires
on va fermer les bars mais pas les
restaurants il ya plein de choses que
les français ne comprennent pas ça va
dans tous les sens et ça ne peut à mon
avis qu avoir un effet très délétère sur
le moral de la population et peut-être
que certaines mesures vont être très mal
acceptée oui parler france fin le niveau
d'acceptabilité défi car c'est en tout
cas à quoi qu'il arrive on a de très
fortes chances d'aller vers un nouveau
confinement le
vernement en tout cas le juge justifiée
compte tenu de la hausse exponentielle
du nombre de cas écoutez hier et bien
stanislas guérini le délégué général de
la république en marche qui était
également à cette consultation
et moi je crois que cette réunion avait
une vertu qui vous permettent de
qualifier la situation il voir que la
situation sanitaire du pays est grave il
faut regarder la situation en face et
d'accélération extrêmement forte du
virus qui nécessite à mon sens que nous
accélérions les mesures à prendre je
crois que nous sommes dans un moment il
faut prendre nos responsabilités face à
cette situation gpd pour ma part je
puisse avoir des mesures fortes et le
jeu qui soit lisible compréhensible par
l'ensemble le constat est là et on va
regarder un certain nombre de chiffres
sur la pandémie les derniers chiffres de
santé publique france +33 1417 cas
repérés en 24 heures plus de 14000
hospitalisation sur les sept derniers
jours dont bien 2057 en réanimation et
96 départements en situation de
vulnérabilité élevé alexandre plus tard
se trouve salle des conférences salle
des conférences vous êtes avec sylvie
vermeillet alex temps qui est l'une des
co rapporteur de la commission denquête
qu'ovide et bien on va écouter tout de
suite sa réaction à cette situation
oui sylvie vermeillet le président de la
république pourrait annoncer ce soir un
nouveau reconfirmant généralisée ça veut
dire que le gouvernement a échoué dans
sa stratégie sanitaire
c'est assez compliqué de d'être
victorieux face à une épidémie
d'ailleurs on voit qu'à l'échelle de
l'europe
finalement personne n'a réussi malgré
les succès avéré de l'allemagne sur la
première vague
il ya quelque chose qui se produit
actuellement qu'on n'est pas capable de
maîtriser
donc pour vous le gouvernement n'est pas
responsable de cette deuxième vague un
nouveau gouvernement n'est pas
responsable de cette deuxième vague
personne n'est responsable je crois pas
que c'est l'heure de fustiger untel ou
untel
y compris dans la population parce qu'on
essaye aussi de poser les jeunes aux
personnes âgées
la question c'est de faire face de ne
pas attendre le débordement des hôpitaux
et puis en même temps de laisser un peu
de l'oxygène à l'économie parce qu'elle
aussi elle a besoin d'oxygène
les patients ont besoin d'oxygène mais
l'économie aussi et pourtant ces
derniers mois est ce qu'on n'a pas été
trop souple dans le déconfinement en
laissant peut-être trop d'oxygène aux
français ce qui aurait provoqué la
deuxième vague est ce que les français
n'avaient pas besoin d'oxygène bien sûr
que si je crois que si on avait continué
le confinement d'ailleurs souvenez-vous
11 mai il y avait quand même des
contestations des protestations qui
étaient légitimes et les français ont
fait beaucoup d'efforts pendant la
première vague maintenant à l'été il
était normal que il respire eux aussi
donc pour vous jean castex a fait un
bond et confinement ces derniers mois je
trouve que le déconfinement a été
différent finalement mail à l'afflux de
touristes sur certaines zones qui
avaient été épargnés par la première
vague a sans doute relancer l'épidémie
tel qu'on s'y attendait pas voilà je
crois que maintenant il ya des mesures
prudentes à prendre parce que de
nouveaux on craint la saturation des
hôpitaux
et puis en tant que rapporteur de la
commission denquête qu'ovide moi je
voudrais attirer l'attention des gens
sur le fait qu' on a des internes dans
les hôpitaux qui n'ont pas pris de
vacances depuis plus d'un an qu'ils sont
épuisés et c'est une réalité et on se
doit de les protéger
on se doit aussi de penser à tous les
malades qui n'ont pas le coc vide mais
qui sont atteints d'autres pathologies
les malades atteints de cancers de
maladies chroniques qui eux n'ont rien
demandé mais à qui on va demander aussi
de faire des efforts parce qu'on va
prioriser les malades qu vide et c'est
bien légitime on peut pas faire
autrement
les manger vraiment de l'inquiétude pour
la prise en charge des malades qui ont
des pathologies différentes du coc vide
et qu'on se doit de protéger aussi mais
c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression que
cette deuxième vague va être plus forte
que la première avec beaucoup de
départements qui sont touchés par le
virus
et puis des personnels de santé qui sont
lassés
de cette crise tout à fait moi je
réponds je suis très inquiète pour les
personnels de santé
c'est mon discours chaque jour en ce
moment parce que il faut les soutenir de
nouveau c'est très bien on les applaudit
à 20 heures tous les soirs pendant la
première vague mais maintenant faut
essayer de faire en sorte qu'ils ne
soient pas submergés donc je pense à eux
et puis il faut de nouveau que chacun
fasse des efforts pour une durée limitée
elle sera limitée on va la vaincre cette
vague mais il faut que ce soit un effort
collectif
un effort collectif et un soutien très
fort aux personnels de santé qui sera
très important durant cette deuxième
vague merci beaucoup sylvie vermeillet
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
réaction benjamin morel votre réaction à
ce que vient dire sylvie vermeillet elle
dit aussi attention à ne pas opposer les
uns et les autres dans cette séquence et
on en parlait à l'instant
l'acceptabilité des français elle dépend
aussi de cela
oui c'est un grande partie vrai et si
vous regardez aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe en italie par exemple avec les
manifestations à rome et à naples
si vous regardez les manifestations qui
ont vu quelques il ya quelques semaines
quelques mois en allemagne
vous voyez que des vies politiques dont
on a pu avoir une vision un peu ironique
et dont on a pu assister également de ce
qu'on appelle en termes sondages y un
ralliement sous drapeau c'est à dire des
chefs de gouvernement qui ont connu une
vraie embellie sondagière avec la crise
qui n'a pas été le cas d'emmanuel macron
et bien malgré ces chefs de d'état
populaire malgré une gestion de crise
qui a peut-être été moins contesté
comprend justement parce que paroisse
crise et tout à l'heure vous avez eu des
élus locaux qui ont pu soutenir le
gouvernement notamment avec des partis
politiques qui ont fait bloc derrière
derrière et chef de l'exécutif est bien
malgré ça vous avez eu la désobéissance
civile et vous avez eu notamment la
désobéissance civile parce que vous avez
eu des formations politiques qui se sont
opposés à la gestion dako vide sur le
principe est à dire pas sur les
modalités comme on a pu connaître en
france et vous avez par exemple la r d
en allemagne
vous avez eu des partis en italie la
ligue a accepté un qui se sont opposés
frontalement disant désobéissez et là en
effet vous
avait à ce moment là et bien un clivage
politique qui se transforme à ce moment
là en injonction à la désobéissance
civile et qui crée cette daube et 100
civils
même si à côté de ça vous avez un
gouvernement fort légitime populaire
donc il faut faire extrêmement attention
à ne pas apparaître trop divisée dans ce
début de gestion de crise au risque
justement de créer ce type de phénomène
que jusqu'à présent on n'a pas connu en
france qu'on a connue aux etats-unis en
allemagne on était ce qui évidemment
n'implique pas une offre de cesser toute
réflexion sur ce qui peut aller mal dans
la gestion de la crise
on voit aujourd'hui que dans les faits
il ya eu des dysfonctionnements au
niveau gouvernemental
il ya également eu des
dysfonctionnements dans les autres pays
là on a tout de même deux phénomènes qui
on va dire son très particulier cette
seconde vague dans sa violence n'a été
vu par personne en italie était comme un
modèle il ya encore deux semaines
aujourd'hui on voit très clairement que
le modèle s'effondre la la reprise
épidémique n'était pas prévu par les
spécialistes elle n'était pas non plus
prévu par l'ensemble des gouvernements
occidentaux
donc là vous avez un phénomène qui est
un phénomène assez contingent que gère
comme ils le peuvent
l'ensemble des gouvernements occidentaux
avec plus ou moins de bonheur didier mau
ça on a vu qu'il ya eu aussi un certain
nombre de tribunes qui partageaient des
inquiétudes par rapport est bien aux
restrictions aux libertés qui s'annonce
et qui vont donc fortement réduit notre
liberté mais en vertu et bien de la
sécurité sanitaire vous quel est votre
regard là-dessus jurés l'équation est
parfaitement connu et que ce soit vous
dire où d'autres domaines des objectifs
fonctionnels
il faut trouver le bon emplacement du
curseur entre les inimitables
restrictions à un certain nombre de
droits et la nécessité de surmonter une
crise sanitaire aussi con surmonter la
crise sanitaire
il faut effectivement limiter la liberté
de circulation
ça va ou en mai est ce que c'est un
kilomètre retourner chez soi est que ces
5 km 10 km voilà j'ai rêvé toute une
série de questions qui vont se poser
mais il ya des points ou des domaines en
tout cas des libertés auxquelles il faut
pas toucher ne serait-ce que tout ce qui
concerne la liberté d'expression la
liberté de la presse la liberté du débat
et la liberté du parlement
notre crise sanitaire elle doit se
dérouler dans un état de droit dans une
démocratie ce n'est pas facile c'est
beaucoup plus facile de gérer une crise
dans une dictature mais c'est aussi
l'honneur des démocraties d'arriver à le
faire de manière pas obligatoirement
consensuel mais de manière débattu et
avec les fonctionnements presque normal
de tout le système
bon on faisait allusion aux
collectivités locales elles ont un rôle
énorme à jouer dans tout cela et il faut
arriver à trouver la bonne ligne de
passage c'est pas facile on est obligé
de constater que tout ce qui a été
annoncé depuis un mois a échoué
je crois que le constat est unanime
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire maintenant
c'est à dire c'est au gouvernement et au
président de la république de le dire
mais avec la dose d'incertitude qui est
la leur et qui l'est c'est le de tout ce
qu'on entend sur les écrans ou à la
radio notamment de la part des
scientifiques
d'ailleurs olivier pas quoi acheter
malin sont en train d'accueil et c est
ce que vous dites un didier moss sur ce
plateau on va parler bien justement de
la traduction au parlement de la
pandémie qu'est ce que ça va donner la
suite des événements c'est on en a
beaucoup parlé l'allocution d'emmanuel
macro à 20h aujourd'hui ça va être aussi
traduit par la déclaration demain de
jean castex au parlement assemblée et
sénat ça sera suivie d'un débat et d'un
vote dans les deux chambres
et puis au sénat il y aura également
l'examen du projet de loi de prorogation
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire ça sera
dans la foulée et ça sera à partir de
demain après midi
demain soir qu'est ce que vous attendez
de cette séquence rachid tu es mal on
l'a dit c'est une séquence riche pour le
parlement et notamment de cette
déclaration du gouvernement c'était
aussi une demande de la gauche en
socialistes et communistes qu'il y ait
ce moment de déclarations en vertu de
l'article 50-1 enfin je crois que je
crois que tous les rangs ce raisonnement
tous les tous les bancs que le parlement
puisse être associé qui puisse avoir un
avis qui puisse voter ces crimes et ça
me semble le minimum ce comme l'a dit
votre invité je crois que là il faut
aussi que la démocratie continue à vivre
moi je reviens d'un point sur ce que va
dire présent ce soir ce qui serait bien
je pars conseils donnés mais qui donne
aussi de l'espoir et l'espoir
aujourd'hui pour les français c'est la
question d'un
de soi de médicaments soit de vaccins et
je crois que ces dernières semaines plus
personne n'en parle
et mettez vous à la place de français
comme nous on vit ça difficilement avec
des conséquences sociales économie
dramatique mais en terme de ce rappel
les éléments psychologiques ces actions
qui sont conséquents si l'amendé le
président n'arrive plus à remettre de la
perspective voilà on travaille sur la
question des médicaments
on travaille 60 du vaccin il ya espoir
et c'est je crois qu'il faut qu'ils
redonnent de la rrq de l'espoir aux
français je crois que ça c'est aussi son
rôle d'un président et d'un grand manque
aussi dire à la fin la pesée au bout du
tunnel tout ce que vous allez signer je
pense est important de le rappeler
oui les soirs ou n'est pas de faux
espoirs et c'est vrai que
malheureusement depuis des mois voire
des années
le président de la république nous a
habitués à voir des discours qui pouvait
être enthousiasmant et à l'arrivée la
suite l'était beaucoup moins
exactement je simplement ajouter une
petite chose suite aux propos de madame
vermeille et je suis aussi membre de la
commission d'enquêté sénatoriale sur la
côte est qui et qui est très
intéressante
est ce que moi j'en ai a obtenu
notamment et j'avais été passionné par
les auditions des ambassadeurs de taiwan
et de corée du sud qui sont des pays qui
eux ont su endiguer là la première vague
et qui n'ont pas pour l'instant le 2ème
bataillon de la corée du sud ses 52
millions d'habitants moins de 350 morts
mais il avait tiré tous les
enseignements de précédentes épidémies
il était totalement prêt comme quoi on
peut s'organiser
ils avaient des masques qu'ils avaient
des tests il avait une traçabilité
électronique et avait été accepté par le
parlement qui avait été décidée par le
parlement et que qui avait été
complètement intégré par la population
résultat ils ont pu tracer tester isolé
et ils ont complètement éteint
l'incendié épidémiologique
comme quoi c'est possible alors ce sont
des asiatiques on va dire ils sont
beaucoup plus disciplinés que nous mais
je pense que en cas de salubrité
publique
nous devrions pouvoir réellement tirer
tous les enseignements et j'espère
surtout qu'il y aura pas de quatrième
vague ni de troisième vague
didier moss je voudrais aussi qu'on
parle un petit peu et bien de la
dimension parlementaire que j'évoquais à
l'instant à la nouveauté qu'il va y
avoir par rapport au mois de mars c'est
cette déclaration qui va y avoir
- de jean castex pour vous quelle est la
valeur de ce discours à quoi va-t-il
servir demain
d'abord il m'a dit il a permis deux
premiers mieux s'exprimer devant
l'assemblée nationale des skins à ce qui
est une bonne chose
en réalité ça va être le suivi de la
déclaration du président de la
république de ce soit ça avec le mode
d'emploi l'explication pour ça sera vont
bien en plus long et il y aura un débat
et il est bon que les groupes
parlementaires dont les deux assemblées
puisse dire ce qu'ils pensent à la fois
de la cité sanitaire
mais comme ça a été dit tout à l'heure d
autres aspects de la crise car la crise
sanitaire
elle a des conséquences économiques des
conséquences sociales des conséquences
psychologiques dramatique et elle se
situe à un moment où on est dans une
crise terroristes alors tout ça
effectivement être un petit peu
compliqué les lire on est dans un
univers à multi dimension mais il est
normal que le premier ministre utilise
les armes qu'il a à sa disposition
il ya rien de cet étonnant bon ça durera
ce que ça durera il y aura aveugle bon
il y aura une approbation c'est évident
mais je crois que là on est dans le
fonctionnement par fne et moi j'aimerais
ne pas revoir ce qu'on a vu au mois de
mars
c'est à dire un hémicycle aussi bien de
l'assemblée nationale que du sénat où il
y avait un représentant par groupe
politique il faut quand même que la
représentation la physionomie la photo
j'allais dire des groupes politiques
soient présents dans l'hémicycle
oui benjamin morel est ce que c'est
certain qu'il va y avoir un vote
favorable du sénat parce qu'on se
rappelle que par exemple lorsqu'il ya eu
le plan de déconfinement et bien le
sénat s'est opposé et ça serait un sacré
symbole quand même si le sénat bascule
elle sait pas s'opposent au pl et enfin
le plan n'était pas assez bien pour nous
que ça n'allait pas je crois que les
faits ont donné raison
benjamin morel est ce que vous
m'entendez benjamin je disais quel
symbole ça serait si le sénat s'opposent
cette fois ci avec cette nouvelle
déclaration parce que je le rappelais et
bien le sénat s'était opposée au plan 2d
confinant parce qu'ils n'allaient pas
assez loin pour lui à et bien on
entendra alors eh ben je vous interroge
vous quel sera votre vote rachid tes
malheurs ne le savez pas encore non
c'est preuve que preuve qu'on n'est pas
pavlovien non les actionnaires le prêt
applique dont il hier soir c'était un
échec à consultation je rappelle que les
élus locaux n'ont pas été aussi associée
à tout débat alors que sur le terrain
ceux qui sont en face aux français pour
le rappeler ils ont pas été associés
il ya une déclaration sur la duperie
république dans la démocratie et macro
nien c'est très important
et puis il y aura le débat pour moi je
vais attendre avec mon groupe on va
attendre ce qu'ils nous disent les uns
les autres
c'est patent sur prendre des mesures il
n'y a pas d'un côté des gens sérieux et
responsable c'est également et les
autres ils responsables
on peut aussi dire que il faut telle ou
telle mesure en plus au moins je
reprends les armes des entreprises
aujourd'hui sur les entreprises la
question des d'hp et rennes aujourd'hui
on a aidé beaucoup sur les cotisations
etc
mais ils pourront pas rembourser donc
qu'est ce que va dire le président
qu'est ce que dira le pr ministation sur
ces questions là par exemple olivier
paccaud écouter les dernières réactions
enfin on attend effectivement la
déclaration du président mais on a eu
les actes auparavant qu'ils ne nous ont
pas forcément convaincu que ce soit au
niveau économique il ya eu des aides
importantes qui ont permis un rebond au
troisième trimestre mais il y avait
plein de gens qui avaient été oubliés
par les haines et puis il ya une
catégorie de la population qui
malheureusement est actuellement dans
une situation dramatique ce sont les
jeunes doivent avoir un mot sur eux ceux
qui sortent donc de l'école ce qui
arrive en fin de période de formation
qui cherche des stages c'est dramatique
pour eux et malgré les discours
encourageant ou rassurant la réalité est
vraiment terrible pour eux terrible pour
et bien merci merci beaucoup à tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat on
va continuer à parler de la pandémie sur
ce plateau alors que nous sommes
maintenant à une demi heure des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
c'est là encore est bien l'un des sujets
principaux que l'on va avoir lors de
cette séance de questions d'actualité
nous sommes toujours avec alexandre
poussard salle à des conférences pour
l'instant normalement et bien j'imagine
que c'est encore assez calmes nous
sommes également avec jean m'assieds qui
est sur la plateforme twitch et fait
vivre à sa communauté la séance à venir
mais aussi quentin qu'elle met dans
l'hémicycle du sénat quentin des
précautions sont prises au sénat est ce
que on a fait évoluer les conditions de
travail des sénateurs avec le contexte
sanitaire et vient pas exactement tam le
protocole sanitaire il est en place au
sénat depuis le 8 octobre alors c'est
vrai que les sénateurs ont repris
récemment et eu les élections
sénatoriales
mais depuis
octobre il n'y a pas eu d'évolution du
protocole sanitaire je vous le rappelle
le nombre de sénateurs est limité à 1
sur 2 d'ailleurs peut-être voyez vous
sur les images de notre réalisateur
laurent duthil qu'effectivement un
fauteuil sur deux ne peut pas être
occupés dans l'hémicycle qui se trouve
derrière moi du gel hydroalcoolique et à
la disposition des sénateurs dans les
travées qui jouxte l'hémicycle et qui
permettent de le rejoindre et l'ensemble
des personnes présentes dans le sénat
porte un masque bien sûr et cela se fait
sans aucune exception et elle c'est très
clair d'ailleurs dans les consignes qui
ont été délivrés par le bureau du sénat
même l'orateur lorsqu'il pose une
question d'actualité comme ce sera le
cas dans une demi heure il doit enlever
son masque et a donc finalement il n'y a
pas dans d'évolution que cela depuis le
8 octobre quand un nom c'est vrai pas
encore et d'ailleurs certains sénateurs
s'interrogent sur ses conditions de
travail ils poussent pour des mesures
plus strictes
un sénateur note par exemple que seuls
les collaborateurs parlementaires ont
été invités à télétravailler pour
l'heure mais les questeurs qui organise
aussi le travail parlementaire pourrait
donner de nouvelles mesures demain mais
cela dit déjà la présidence du sénat
entend insister sur à la question de la
poursuite des activités législatives
c'est bien la priorité pour la
présidence du sénat où on nous a
expliqué qu'il faut attendre les
annonces bien sûr des manuels macron
mais qu' a priori de l'ordre du jour est
bien maintenue pour les prochaines
semaines et que la règle de un sénateur
sur deux sera maintenue masqué
quant aux auditions elle pourrait elle
bien avoir lieu en visioconférence mais
donc on verra tout ça dans les
prochaines heures tam
merci quand on se retrouve tout à
l'heure on va continuer à parler de
l'aco vide un sujet qui va largement
occupé le parlement ces prochains jours
les sénateurs en effet sont appelés à
voter demain par deux fois sur la
déclaration que va faire le premier
ministre jean castex et qui va traduire
les annonces ce soir d'emmanuel macro
mais aussi sur le projet de loi de
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
aurélien romano vous explique tout ça
suite aux annonces du président ce soir
le gouvernement veut passer par un vote
au parlement afin d'asseoir la
légitimité d'un éventuel reconfirme ans
pour le chef des sénateurs ma chronique
c'est une manière de mettre les parties
devant leurs responsabilités suite aux
nombreuses critiques je pense est une
démarche démocratique élire d'associer
le parlement aux décisions sanitaire
lourde qui doivent être prises
ça me paraît de bonne pratique
ce n'est pas lui mettre devant le fait
accompli ça leur dire est ce que vous y
souscrivait ou pas on verra bien demain
moi je souhaite qu'il y ait un vote
on verra si les forces politiques sens
capable d'accompagner de soutenir ou
bien de se mettre dans un état de
critique aujourd'hui 100 propositions
réelles ce vote qui n'engagent pas la
responsabilité du gouvernement aura lieu
jeudi et donc décale dans la foulée à
jeudi soir l'examen au sénat de la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence déjà
adopté à l'assemblée en commission des
modifications ont été apportées
notamment la date limite ramener au 31
janvier au lieu de mi février mais aussi
la possibilité pour le gouvernement de
légiférer par ordonnance la commission
des lois veux souligner que le sénat
existe et continue ses travaux
la crise sanitaire ne doit pas nous
condamner à sacrifier la démocratie nos
institutions sont composés d'un exécutif
mais il ya aussi un parlement et au
moment où il faut gagner la confiance de
nos concitoyens je pense que le
parlement en tout cas le sénat est tout
à fait dans son rôle quand il demande à
être davantage associés aux décisions et
que le parlement ne peut pas donner sur
une durée qui s'allonge un blanc-seing
en quelque sorte au gouvernement en de
question de signer un blanc seing au
gouvernement quitte à ce qu'il n'y ait
pas d'accord sur la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence tel que proposé par le
gouvernement
dans ce cas le dernier mot reviendra à
l'assemblée et sur ce plateau david
assouline bonjour jour vous êtes
sénateur socialiste de marie vice
président de la commission de la culture
et de l'éducation
et je précise que vous êtes également
membre de la commission d' enquête sur
la cause vide également avec nous à
l'imper vous êtes sénateur les
républicains de la côte d'or et vous
êtes membre de la commission des
affaires étrangères
un mot d'abord et bien sûr le programme
que vient de nous présenter aurélien
romano donc une allocution de manière
macron ce soir une déclaration demain le
jean castex le pro de légers de loi
urgente dans la foulée qu'est-ce que ça
traduit pour vous cette soudaine
accélération du tempo à tous les niveaux
et notamment parlementaire david
assouline
deux choses la première c'est que nous
vivons une situation à nouveau grave
dangereuse pour les français la pandémie
est hors contrôle
et donc voilà non ces moments-là faut
accélérer faut prendre des mesures et
une espèce de panique au niveau
gouvernemental
parce qu'ils n'avaient rien anticipé
qu'ils ont tergiversé et que maintenant
il semble s'agiter
ce qui n'est pas bon parce que dans ces
moments là et on le dit depuis de
nombreuses semaines dans ces moments là
un exécutif à un rôle de protection
d'autorité qui rassure de de deux
capitaines de navire qui sait où il va
parce que la situation est anxiogène par
elle même et c'est pas du tout
l'impression qu'ils ont donnée sur la
forme et sur le fond on voit bien que le
stop and go sans arrêt n'a pas été de
nature à être efficace face à cette
deuxième vague on l'entend vous êtes
assez critique
est ce que vous savez déjà si demain
vous allez voter après la déclaration de
politique générale pour ce le plan du
jour vous parler de notre état d'esprit
nous sommes
les les manches retroussées pour avec
tout le monde avec tous les responsables
politiques du rhdp locaux nationaux et
le gouvernement
ma faire front face à l'épidémie donc
c'est la démocratie - unis quand même à
ladite mais ce que je vous dis c'est à
dire que nous on aimerait n'avoir aucune
critique à formuler mais c'est notre
rôle de le faire c'est notre rôle de le
faire mais sur le terrain et face à la
pandémie
on peut compter sur nous en eux on a des
élus locaux qui vont devoir traduire
dans la pratique
à paris par exemple anne hidalgo et on
est là on est au front donc on ne vous
ne sera pas des empêcheurs sûr loin de
là on veut monter mobiliser le pays et
faire face à cette pandémie dans l'unité
la plus grande mais il ya des choses que
l'on doit dire y compris pour que le
gouvernement s'améliore progresse donc
une unité qui n'empêche pas la critique
alain houpert à ce que c'est aussi votre
état d'esprit avant et bien les votes
sur ces deux textes majeurs demain
concernant la pandémie
la critique doit toujours être
constructive et intelligente
je voudrais madys youn et à ce que dit
ce qu'elle a dit david assouline
nous sommes dans le résultat d'un échec
monsieur déconfinement qui a été nommé
premier ministre
g j'étais en campagne électorale pendant
tout l'été j'ai écouté nos électeurs et
notre travail c'est un travail de
transmission un relais de transmission
entre le terrain et et paris il ya un
profond découragement une profonde
crainte de tous les français
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure cher
david de panique
nous présidents parler de guerre 1 il
est vrai qu'on est dans la panique le
gouvernement en train de paniquer deux
pays et le gouvernement et dans la
panique ne savons pas quoi faire il ne
t'aura rues tirant surtout pas les
leçons de ce qui s'est passé en février
et en mars
on n'a pas tiré les leçons vous avez
aussi mentionné jean castex jean castex
monsieur déconfinement voilà une de
libération des petits
contre la tête du premier ministre avec
ce titre monsieur re confinement est ce
que c'est pour vous les chèques donc de
ces mois de déconfinement qui se
traduisent aujourd'hui il faut pas être
un procureur et et quelques mâles ayant
aujourd'hui pour constater que c'est un
échec mais c'est un échec
c'est un choix on a choisi quelqu'un qui
a fait ses preuves comme préfet commet
d'organisation en pensant qu'il suffit
d'être un bon organisateur pour être un
chef de gouvernement
mais la politique c'est quand même aussi
autre chose que de la technicité donc on
nous connaît les techno qui n'ont pas
l'accent on va dire là où on a fait
croire que c'était de nature
profondément différente proche du peuple
mais non
je je il fallait de la vision politique
et il fallait surtout savoir à ce moment
là qu'on doit rassurer c'est si vous ne
vous ne le trouvez pas rassurant dans
cette séquence par exemple par haider
philippe qui avait vu à gérer la
première phase du déconfinement sont eux
non c'est pas rassurant du tout le fait
qu on change le pied tout en nous je
regarde à peu près les dates de 10
octobre on a demandé un débat sur le 50
qui rien on nous a répondu le 19 noms et
puis il y avait ça nous tombe dessus le
bon voilà ça c'est sur la façon dont
aussi pour assurer il faut montrer aussi
qu'on veut rassembler et notamment la
façon de consulter non seulement les
élus locaux il ya déjà eu un problème
sur les mesures d'urgence d'avant les
mesures qui monte en grade sur sur les
restrictions
tous les élus locaux disent aimer
on vient on nous appelle dix minutes
avant la loi a été voulue a téléphoné
dix minutes a beau les mesures sur
couvre-feu et c est là là c'est encore
un peu pareil on réunit tous les partis
politiques mais on leur a rien dit c'est
à dire que ça consultations d'hier un
peut aussi se dire sort de la phase de
travaux pour un gouvernement pour qu on
croit qu'ils que c'est vraiment le côté
1 qui domine ils nous disent bon on ne
peut pas tout savoir c'est nouveau dans
le monde entier sont percutés par sa bon
d'accord mais dans ce cas là et ils
doivent aller au bout ils doivent
écouter ils doivent peut-être apprendre
d'autres c'est collectivement qu'on va
être intelligent là ils sont en train de
concocter des mesures on va les
apprendre ce soir on en a les grandes
lignes on s'est probablement maintenant
c'est ce qu'il faut faire
on verra les formes mais on peut pas
aller coûte parce qu'il faut il faut
réagir très vite mais en tous les cas
c'est un échec
oui alors c'est un échec
oui c'est un échec je pense qu'il y
avait une stratégie politique au départ
le remplacement d'edouard philippe le
qui prenait beaucoup d'importance qui
était très populaire on l'a remplacé par
jean castex qui est un provincial jeu je
m'en réjouis comme edward physique mais
avec la pression aussi que cette crise
sanitaire était à l'époque derrière nous
peut-être mais on l'a remplacé par
quelqu'un de très techno que vous l'avez
dit un ancien préfet qui va faire un
recond finement bâtard s'en tirer des
leçons de ce qui s'est passé pendant ces
deux mois de confinement sans tirer les
leçons parce que le virus je parle en
tant que médecin les virus on commence à
le connaître mieux à mieux comprendre
tirer les leçons les leçons des erreurs
qu'on a fait sur les traitements on
mettait pas au départ de de la cortisone
maintenant on en met on sait on sait
qu'il ya des traitements qui marche
et puis il ya cette ce qui me gêne
profondément et en tant que médecin ces
sept
ce foulage au pied du serment
d'hippocrate où on est en train de
diviser la france entre ceux qui sont
professeurs out et ceux qui sont contre
là on est toujours dans une division le
monde y ajoute rejoignez une clause il
vaut mieux diviser
j'aimerais oui j'aimerais rajouter sur
notre état d'esprit aussi pour demain on
va voir ce qui sera dit etc
mais nous conditionnons beaucoup notre
adhésion au fait qu'il ya un volet
social c'est à dire que tout le monde
sait qu elle est demandée pour bien sûr
parce que tout le monde sait que il ya
une catastrophe sociale qui elle
commence à avoir lieu qui va s'agrandir
s'approfondir avec les mois qui viennent
les fermetures d'entreprises le chômage
qui va grimper les pauvres des gens
inclus qui vont basculer dans l'extrême
précarité
bon donc ce n'est pas possible de dire
pendant des mois on prend des demi
mesures parce qu'il faut pas arrêter
l'économie et à côté ne pas se rendre
compte que la question sociale mairie
aussi beaucoup d'attention et
d'investissement donc on attend de
savoir ce qui va être dit pour protéger
les plus démunis qui sont souvent les
plus frappés des plus fragilisés par le
virus lui même on voit les études ont
été faites et c'est dans les endroits
les plus disons précaires les milieux
sociaux ou même les territoires que ça
fait le plus de dégâts
donc on attend des mesures sociales des
mesures de protection et
d'accompagnement un peu plus respectueux
pour les personnes âgées aussi allez on
va aussi rejoindre maintenant jean
mathieu jean masse y est c'est notre
streamer politique est en train est bien
de faire vivre cette séance de questions
d'actualité à sa communauté bonjour jean
alors toi qu'est ce qui fait réagir ta
communauté les streamer actuellement on
imagine que le coville est aussi au
coeur de leurs préoccupations
aujourd'hui il ya d'autres choses
ben oui non bien sûr évidemment ta main
tout le monde attend les annonces des
manuels macro ce soir c'est ça qui est
le plus attendu par les internautes
la tente d'un confinement clairement le
mot n'est plus tabou tout le monde
s'attend à ce que ce soit le président
de la république nous annonce
confinement dont les modalités sont
encore à expliquer une première question
qui émane et qui est attendue du coût de
la part des sénateurs cet après midi au
gouvernement c c'est assez simple en
fait en juillet dernier emmanuel macron
a promis plus de lui à l'hôpital a
promis plus de moyens et a dit que la
france était prête pour une seconde
vague
visiblement ce n'est pas le cas pourquoi
voilà ça c'est la question que les
internautes veulent que les sénateurs
pause cet après midi est on est on
attend surtout la réponse du
gouvernement à cette question ensuite
bon la perspective d'un long confinement
annoncé ce soir clairement une des
choses qui ressort le plus c'est la
déprime
ils sont très nombreux les internautes à
mme hamm expliqué que en fait ça leur
fait peur ils s'inquiètent pour leurs
études ils s'inquiètent pour leur
insertion professionnelle il ya des
jeunes diplômés qui sont vraiment dans
la galère et qui est qui et qui
s'inquiète vraiment le gouvernement
emmanuel macron leur a annoncé une prime
pour les jeunes qui touche les apl elle
n'arrivera qu'en novembre prochain donc
pour l'instant ils n'ont pas encore vu
la couleur d'une aide gouvernementale
donc voilà il ya une vraie inquiétude
qui s'exprime et puis troisième question
qui est attendu sur ce sujet là la
recherche vaccinale on en est où on en
ebook et c'est que c'est quoi l'issue de
tout ça est ce qu'on va avoir un vaccin
un jour est ce que le gouvernement peut
à skis et de gouvernement un espoir est
ce qu'il ya éventuellement un calendrier
déjà qui pourrait nous être proposées ce
serait ce sera vraiment quelque chose de
très chouettes donc voilà sur ce premier
sujet le deuxième sujet qui est vraiment
attendu tam
c'est aussi la question de la turquie
figure toi erdogan qui monte le ton
contre la turquie dans des attaques à
fuir il s'est au programme est varié
voilà on a hâte de voir des questions
gouvernement là dessus jean yves le
drian qui va pouvoir répondre à la
question simple est ce que la france et
la turquie sont toujours amis est ce que
la france à la turquie sont toujours
allié qu'est ce que la turquie fait dans
l'otan qu'est ce que nous faisons encore
dans l'otan est ce que cette crise qui
est en train de sourire à la question
qui n'est pas un peu le moment de se
reposer la question de nos alliances
dans cette région du monde
c'est aussi un sujet qui est qui est
attendue cet après midi bon eh ben tu
vois les ta communauté est complètement
en phase avec le sénat parce que c'est à
peu près le programme des questions
juste une petite réaction alain houpert
david assouline
on l'entend donc on nous dit et pourquoi
n'y a pas plus de lien à l'hôpital on
s'inquiète de la déprime psychique
on parle de la prime pour les jeunes et
puis aussi bien la lumière au bout du
tunnel et bien ça serait un vaccin on
voit finalement les interrogations des
internautes reflète aussi un peu les
questions qui va y avoir tout à l'heure
plus de lille à l'hôpital on a continué
à diminuer
après le déconfinement c'est qu'un
dramatique on n'a pas utilisé pendant le
premier confinement les lits de
réanimation privé je pense que j'espère
qu'on va utiliser le vaccin
levac sens je dirais c'est une utopie
qui se réalisera dans quelques mois ou
peut-être dans une année faux faut pas
rêver c'est un vaccin compliqué mais je
reviens sur la connaissance que l'on a
vis à vis du virus
on connaît mieux les choses et la
communication du gouvernement est
délétère la communication qu'ovide égale
réanimation positif égale maladie non
c'est pas parce qu'on est positif qu'on
est malade il faut confier
quand il faut dire je pense que la
communication du gouvernement doit
changer en disant vous avez des
symptômes
allez voir votre médecin traitant fait
vous bouscule t et lâché prise auprès de
votre médecin traitant la médecine c'est
une relation entre le patient et de
médecins la médecine ça ça vient du
lâcher prise
il faut faire confiance à son médecin je
voudrais aussi qu'on parle un peu de
l'autre thématique dont par les gens à
l'instant et qui a également bien sûr
dans l'actualité avec notamment et bien
cette caricature under doan dans charlie
hebdo qui provoque encore aujourd'hui la
colère d'ankara alors on va voir voilà
cette image de cette caricature ce
dessin qui montre le président turc vous
le voyez en tee shirt et en sous
vêtements en train de boire une bière et
de soulever la jupe d'une femme portant
un voile
la turquie annonce qu'elle va prendre
des mesures judiciaires et diplomatiques
un mot david assouline et bien sûr et
bien ce nouvel événement qui vient un
peu plus accroître les tensions avec la
turquie mais cette image c'est aussi la
réponse de charlie hebdo à erdogan alors
que le président turc avait appelé au
boycott des produits français parce que
emmanuel malmont a défendu la semaine
dernière la liberté revient sur ce tout
commence là quand même c'est à dire que
ce dictateur turc qui d'abord fait du
mal à son propre peuple
ces permis non pas de venir rendre
hommage à une victime d'un attentat
terroriste en france samuel pâtit
sauvagement assassiné mais est venu
insulter notre président de la
république parce que il a réaffirmé les
valeurs de la république et le droit
dans notre pays
d'abord la liberté d'expression et le
droit au blasphème qui existe et qui est
là donc avec une violence une vulgarité
incroyable j'ai vu aussi un tweet d'un
ministre du tourisme qui traite charlie
de chienne bon c'est vrai c'est vraiment
des moeurs qu'il faut combattre et ça
nous rappelle une chose c'est que depuis
salman rushdie il ya une offensive des
islamistes dans le monde entier pour
pour accuser ceux qui usent et de leur
liberté d'expression et ça a été des
journalistes ou des écrivains comme
salman rushdie qui étaient montrées du
doigt qui était attaquée il ya eu
beaucoup trop de passivité à réagir dans
le monde
encore aujourd'hui de ceux qui viennent
soutenir la france il ya de la timidité
il a fallu attendre même pour que
l'europe se met à réagir et à défendre
emmanuel macron et donc c'est que c'est
il ya vraiment une clarification à avoir
au niveau international parce que c'est
une bataille mondiale
on la gagnera en france tout seul et ça
se gagnera pas comme certains l'ont cru
en envahissant des pays où avec des
bombes
c'est une bagarre idéologique il la
gagne sur le plan idéologique il faut
opposer des valeurs et ne pas laisser
traîner ce qu'il
faux pour pour polluer des têtes merci
david à ce qu'une tout de suite on va
rejoindre alexandre poussin salle des
conférences pour une nouvelle réaction à
ce sujet un des caricatures avec
alexandre touzard qui est donc avec
christian cambon le président de la
commission de la défense et des affaires
étrangères
mais oui avec christian cambon et bien
ces nouvelles caricatures de charlie
hebdo sont un nouvel épisode dans la
montée des tensions entre la france et
la turquie
question comment est ce que le
gouvernement français emmanuel macron
doivent être plus ferme face à recep
tayyip erdogan
évidemment évidemment la turquie ne
cesse de multiplier les agressions
contre ses propres alliés de l'otan
notamment et la liste commence à être
longue
maintenant on en est venu à des attaques
personnelles contre le président de la
république c'est à dire contre
l'ensemble des français dans une période
particulièrement douloureuse puisque
nous venons de connaître ce dramatique
attentat et donc nous demandons et je
vais demander dans quelques instants
en interrogeant le gouvernement sur ce
sujet quelle mesure effective le
président de la république et surtout le
gouvernement compte prendre à l'endroit
de la turquie pour arrêter cette
escalade qui n'est pas simplement une
escalade verbale
car parmi les les nombreux faits que
l'on peut reprocher à la turquie il ya
bien sûr les incidents qui nous oppose
en mer orientale
il y a bien sûr le chantage aux flux des
immigrés que la turquie nous menace
régulièrement de libérer mais maintenant
il y à l'encouragement et la
participation de la turquie dans le
dramatique et terrible conflit du haut
karabagh au lieu de jouer le rôle d'une
puissance qui travaille pour la paix
elle apporte un soutien armé à
l'azerbaïdjan dans l'offensive qu'ils
mènent contre l'arménie est donc
véritablement ça ne peut plus continuer
comme ça vous pensez à quelles mesures
effectives contre nature qui écoute et
moi je vais en je vais en proposer une
tout à l'heure
au ministre je garde évidemment la
primeur de ce propos pour la séance
mais je pense qu'on peut faire quelque
chose et cesser de se réfugier dans des
déclarations alors qu'en fait monsieur
erdogan s'appuie sur la faiblesse de
l'europe pour avancer systématiquement
et je vais aussi demander au
gouvernement bien sûr de plus plus de
solidarité de la part de nos amis
européens que je trouve assez discret
sur ces sujets vous trouvez pas qu'il ya
une union européenne autour d'eux des
manuels macron dans ce conte je n'en
suis pas persuadé il ya des messages
très forts de la part de l'autriche et
de quelques autres mais j'en attends
plus de nos principaux partenaires et
voisins
merci beaucoup et christian cambon pour
votre réaction et on attend avec
impatience votre annonce de mesures
effectives contre la turquie
dans cette montée des tensions entre la
france et la turquie
merci beaucoup alexandre effectivement
il va y avoir plusieurs questions autour
de cette montée de tension entre la
france et la turquie après notamment et
bien cette nouvelle caricature qui a été
publiées dans charlie hebdo montrant
ainsi le président r douanes tandis que
mais vous le voyez il commence à arriver
un certain nombre de sénateurs salle des
conférences il ya du monde qui arrive
avant cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement nous sommes
maintenant à 5 1 minute 5 minutes du
début de cette séance de questions
d'actualité on va rejoindre alexandre
poussard alexandre qui est avec bernard
jomier bernard tomic et co rapporteur
socialiste de la commission denquête
qu'ovide il va d'ailleurs posé une
question tout à l'heure alexandre oui
bernard jomier vous allez interroger le
gouvernement sur la crise sanitaire
alors que ce soir le président de la
république pourrait annoncer un nouveau
confinement
ça veut dire que notre stratégie
sanitaire a échoué oui bien sûr enfin
comme tous les pays d'europe
on a actuellement une seconde vague qui
arrive et
ce qui se passe actuellement en france
dit simplement la nécessité de prendre
des mesures restrictives très forte que
la stratégie qui a été mise en place en
amont n'a pas bien fonctionné et donc
cette stratégie qui reposait sur deux
piliers le masque et les gestes barrière
la distanciation physique et la
stratégie tester tracé isolé ne freine
pas suffisamment la circulation du virus
qui s'est considérablement accéléré et
qui impose de prendre de nouvelles
mesures restrictives
alors vous êtes co rapporteur de la
commission d'enquêté du sénat sur la
gestion de cette crise de lakovic 19 est
ce que le gouvernement a vraiment tiré
les leçons de ce premier confinement du
printemps dernier c'est là dessus que
j'ai interrogées le gouvernement dans
quelques instants parce que on a on a vu
beaucoup de leçons de cette première
phase notamment en terme d'organisation
certains parlent d'ailleurs d'une crise
organisationnelles en matière de
processus de décision et sur ces deux
plans là il n'y a pas eu réellement de
mesures qui ont été prises des mesures
ont été prises sur des phénomènes
beaucoup plus conjoncturelle la question
des thèses des masses qui sont
importantes sont importantes mais qui ne
suffisent pas à avoir une approche de
santé publique assez efficace est ce que
selon vous un le nouveau confinement
doit être un peu similaire à celui qu'on
a connu au printemps dernier où il doit
être plus allégée je crois qu'au stade
où on en est les mesures restrictives
doivent être importantes si on veut
casser réellement rapidement la courbe
des contaminations - seront importantes
plus il faudra qu'elles durent longtemps
merci beaucoup bernard jomier pour votre
réaction et on va écouter votre question
d'actualité tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle du sénat
merci à alexandre et pied vous allez
enchaîner sur une nouvelle réaction
avant cette séance de questions
d'actualité puisque vous êtes avec loïc
hervé sénateur uc il vient d'adresser
une lettre ouverte à emmanuel macron où
il propose à 1 re confinement loïc hervé
qui concerne avant tout les plus
fragiles alexandre et oui avec loïc
harvey vous faites partie des sénateurs
centristes qui refusent l'idée d'un
nouveau confinement en tout cas sur le
modèle du printemps dernier absolument
je crois que on a vu au mois de mars
avril
les conséquences économiques et
conséquences sociales pour notre pays et
donc je fais partie de ceux qui essayent
de trouver une troisième voie entre la
situation actuelle
et 1re confinement total en proposant
l'auto confinement des personnes les
plus vulnérables
on sait très bien que la situation de
santé l'âge
un jeu à rentrer en jeu en termes
d'accès à la réanimation voir en terme
de mortalité est donc moi j'en appelle à
notre système de santé pour protéger ces
personnes là pour qu'elles ne viennent
pas saturer les l'hydre animation est
donc vraiment pour que l'économie tourne
églises écoles restent ouvertes etc
c'est ce que j'essayerai de plaider
aujourd'hui et demain ce que j'essayais
de prévenus présents la république pour
qu'on ait une
une attitude beaucoup plus
responsabilisant de vis-à-vis des
français que que celle que nous avons
jusqu'à maintenant où on attend la
parole présidentielle ce soit pour
savoir ce qu'on fait c'est pas ça ils
rôle du parlement c'est bien de proposer
des choses et c'est ce que moi j'essaye
de faire
mais justement la stratégie ces
dernières semaines et ce qu'elle n'était
pas basé sur la responsabilité des
français en faisant appel à leur bon
sens c'était un peu le discours
l'interview du président de la
république il y a dix jours maintenant
il faut peut-être un imposé en
confinement mais on va faire ça pendant
combien de temps ces terres que la
troisième vague on aura à nouveau 1,3 et
moi confinement d'une quatrième homme
d'état on sait très bien que le paradoxe
c'est qu'on nous explique qu'il faut
vivre avec le virus
quand même temps il faut soutenir
l'activité économique et qu'on a bien vu
que il ya comme un redémarrage de
l'épidémie donc l'idée pour ne pas ce
que l'on l'enjeu c'est non c'est pas que
le virus se diffuse le virus y se
diffusent leurs françois delfraissy
parle de 100000 infections jours donc le
virus se diffuse dans la population
il faut qu'ils ne touchent pas ceux qui
sont les plus vulnérables dont les
personnes les plus vulnérables sont les
personnes qui de par leur état de santé
ou leur âge statistiquement plus de
risques que les autres
c'est terrible de dire ça moi je
préférerais qu'on qu'on ait la même
liberté pour tout le monde
mais voilà on est dans la proposition
que vous déposez évoqué leur confinement
total ça coûte 2 milliards d'euros par
jour dont 7 à choix pour les finances
publiques pour le pib pour la société
qui est un choix considérable mais avec
votre solution de seulement confiné à
les personnes les plus vulnérables et ce
qu'on ne va pas stigmatiser une partie
de la population c'est pour ça que je
parle d'un auto confinement d'une
responsabilité je sais très bien pour
des raisons constitutionnelles de
libertés publiques c'est très compliqué
mais par contre on a un discours de
vérité peut-être ce soir dans la bouche
présent la république de dire qu' il ya
des personnes qui sont beaucoup plus et
ce qui est écrit ce devenir engorger les
hôpitaux simplement parce que
statistiquement je le redis elles ont de
par leur âge ou leur état de santé que
général beaucoup plus de chances de
développer une forme grave
et bien que ces personnes-là d'elle même
on apprend tout l'accompagnement social
qui a été nécessaire qu'on puisse les
accompagner leur permettre de rester de
rester à la maison si jamais emmanuel
macron ce soir annonce un confinement
nationale sur quatre semaines c'est
l'information qui est en train de
circuler vous craignez pour les libertés
des français
je crois toujours pas ce que c'est c'est
une nouvelle mesure extrêmement
privative de liberté pour nos
compatriotes et donc j'aurai l'occasion
demain j'imagine lors du débat avec les
collègues de de faire partie de ceux qui
vont l'exprimer pour dire que nous
sommes très inquiets et dans le débat
sur le projet de loi prorogeant l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
il sera important de défendre le rôle du
parlement dans cette période qui a remis
face qu'à nouveau à faire décaler on va
faire décaler tout un tas de de télé on
va avoir recours à nouveau aux
ordonnances
il ya beaucoup de choses qui vont être
proposées le parlement il fonctionne
la preuve aujourd'hui il doit
fonctionner avant tout l'art de la crise
merci beaucoup
loïc hervé vos réponses à mes questions
on va retrouver à la tribune de presse
de l'hémicycle du sénat pour le
programme de ces questions d'actualité
quand un calme et oui alexandre pousse à
vous venez de voir gérard larcher sortir
du bureau de départ il est en train de
s'installer derrière moi dans
l'hémicycle ça me donne quelques
secondes pour vous donner un peu le menu
de ces questions d'actualité vous allez
pouvoir suivre six questions directement
consacrée à la crise sanitaire
six autres questions sur les
conséquences de cette crise sanitaire et
vous l'avez bien compris aussi des
questions sur la turquie ou encore sur
la tension au moyen-orient
la sanef vient de sonner c'est parti
pour ces questions d'actualité
[Musique]
distribués nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation y'en a t'il en séance je
n'en vois point le procès verbal est
donc adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre et dams et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
nous sommes retransmis en direct sur
public sénat sur notre site internet
chacun sera attentif au respect du temps
un encore plus au respect des uns et des
autres et je donne immédiatement la
parole au président françois patriat
pour le groupe du rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendant
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
douze jours se sont écoulés depuis
l'effroyable attentat terroriste qui a
frappé à une star de la république
une fois encore c'est dans sa chair que
le peuple français a été touché
nous ne devons jamais oublier et nous
devrons réagir
cette attaque d'une violence inouïe
atteint notre nation en plein coeur dans
ce qu'elle a d'universel et c'est cet
universel que nombreux nous envient
l'esprit critique et la liberté
d'expression entre autres la laïcité à
la française fait partie de ces valeurs
républicaines qui ont forgé l'âme de
notre nation l'histoire de notre pays et
c'est précisément ce que ces esprits ses
ennemis de la liberté veulent abattre
c'est ainsi que nous serons collègues
élus de la république avant partager
avec émotion un moment d'intense
recueillement à la sorbonne
comme beaucoup l'ont fait sur notre
territoire la stupeur et la solidarité
ont dépassé les frontières nationales et
ont entraîné un soutien de nombre de nos
partenaires européens et internationaux
mes chers collègues le contexte
terroriste sanitaire économique et plus
récemment diplomatique exige de nous un
devoir d'unité ne pouvons affronter ces
quatre péril majeur sur les divisions
internes vin est dérisoire
dans ce contexte pesant le peuple
français doit adresser un message fort à
ses dirigeants
celui d'une nation unie une nation forte
et fière de ses valeurs face à l'as
descriptible l'indicible l'innommable
monsieur premier ministre nombreux sont
ceux qui souhaitent
installé le doute et la division dans
nos esprits cet ensemble nous
continuerons à faire face à la menace
terroriste
encore une fois l'histoire exige de nous
que nous soyons à la hauteur de nos
responsabilités
le chef de l'état l'a dit nous ne
reculerons pas la lutte contre le
terrorisme doit demeurer une priorité de
notre action politique et à ce titre
monsieur le premier ministre
pouvez vous nous préciser comment le
gouvernement entend amplifier les
efforts menés en faveur de la
préservation de notre modèle républicain
et lutter contre les séparatistes je
vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur castex vous avez la
parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président patriat vous avez parfaitement
raison
ce n'est pas seulement une personne
admirable
le professeur pâtit lâchement assassiné
qui a été visé ce la république
ce sont ces valeurs de liberté d'égalité
de fraternité de laïcité la main de cet
acte odieux
on la connaît c'est celle de l'islamisme
politique de l'islamisme radical qui
n'en est pas à son premier forfait
monsieur présent patriat vous avez
encore raison quand vous dites que la
première des réponses c'est l'unité de
la république et de la nation toute
entière car les ennemis de la république
en d'abord pour premier objectif de nous
diviser de faire prospérer tous les
amalgames de déchaîner la haine pour
embrigader à servir et finalement
assassiné
on connaît leurs méthodes faire le
procès de la france faire le procès de
son histoire comme si elle avait en
rougir de ses principes fondateurs qui
sont à l'opposé des leurs voilà pourquoi
nous sommes leur cible et que ce soit
dit ici que se soit répétée ici comme
ailleurs partout dans le monde
en france on peut publier des
caricatures librement on connaît aussi
vous l'avez dit leur levier leur mode
opératoire des lieux de culte des
tournées des associations paravents des
réseaux sociaux proactif comme les
lâches ils agissent dans l'ombre et bien
qu'ils sachent qu'ils trouveront
toujours la république en travers de
leur chemin
le gouvernement sous l'autorité du
président république les ministres
principalement concernées sont à
l'action et à la manoeuvre ils n'ont
jamais cessé de l'être ils sont dans
l'action quotidienne encore ce jour le
conseil des ministres a procédé sur la
proposition du ministre de l'intérieur à
la dissolution de l'une de ces
associations
la semaine dernière une mosquée radicale
a été fermée depuis 2010 8 356 lieu de
radicalisation ont également été
interdits
j'ai décidé de renforcer les effectifs
de renseignement 100 postes vont être
créés dédié à la surveillance des
réseaux sociaux depuis le début du
quinquennat
neil 250 postes supplémentaires ont été
affectés à la dgsi vendredi dernier je
me suis rendu à bruxelles pour
rencontrer le président de la commission
européenne et le commissaire breton pour
pousser les deux règlements européens
qui lutteront contre l'apologie du
terrorisme en ligne et contre la projet
pour la prohibition des réseaux et ne
ses textes vont aboutir très
prochainement
enfin vous le savez monsieur le
président nous travaillons
d'arrache-pied au projet de loi de lutte
contre le séparatisme annoncé je le
rappelle à la haute assemblée par le
président de la république dès avant la
commission de l'acte de conflans sainte
honorine et je ne doute pas que le sénat
apportera à ce texte
des compléments très utile je vous
remercie monsieur le premier ministre
la parole est à notre collègue bernard
jomier pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicaine vous avez la
parole une seule créée dans le seul
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues nous
faisons face à la seconde vague
et comme au printemps avec beaucoup
d'autres pays de l'hémisphère nord
notamment
et comme au printemps la qualité de
notre réponse déterminera le nombre de
vies que nous sauverons vous deviez que
nous perdrons la première vague a révélé
des forces et des faiblesses de notre
pays les constats qui ont été effectués
montrent de sérieux problèmes
d'organisation celle de certains parlent
même d'une crise organisationnel et de
nombre non moins sérieuses failles dans
nos processus de décision jusqu'à
l'expert mentionné par le chef de l'état
qui fait ces constats alors monsieur le
ministre
quelles sont les décisions que vous avez
prises quels sont les actes que vous
avez posé
suite à ces concerta pour mieux nous
préparer à cette seconde vague
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et à monsieur olivier ferrand
mais liste des solidarités de la chanter
où la parole monsieur sénateurs jomier
vous avez raison la sangle la seconde
vague
l'europe elle frappe d'ailleurs
indistinctement l'ensemble des pays qui
nous entourent
y compris les pays qui ont eu 1 re
démarrage plus tardif que la france
l'italie a multiplié le nombre de
nouveaux diagnostics par dix en moins de
trois semaines
en moins de trois semaines l'allemagne
augmentent de 100 % le nombre de malades
chaque semaine la suisse dont on vantait
à juste titre l'investissement
incroyable des troupes dans un pays de
la taille de la suisse sur le contact
racing et la capacité de tests a vu
toutes ses capacités de contact racing
débordé et ses capacités de test saturé
avec des délais qui sont analogues à
ceux qu'on avait pu connaître il ya
quelques semaines dans notre pays
face à cela on pourrait penser mais ce
n'est pas votre cas est vous êtes non
seulement sénateurs mais médecin on
pourrait penser qu'il faudrait chercher
là un dysfonctionnement d'un appareil
d'état où on peut se demander utilement
comment freiner collectivement par
l'action de tous et en solidarité
la diffusion du virus avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard monsieur le sénateur il
ya trois paramètres dans un virus comme
le coronavirus deux qu'on ne maîtrise
pas la contagiosité
c'est à dire les risques de transmettre
le virus quand on l'a le nombre de jours
pendant lequel on est contagieux ces
deux paramètres là on ne maîtrise pas il
ya en somme un paramètre et c'est vieux
comme le monde
on peut maîtriser c'est le nombre de
personnes avec qui on est en contact et
qui pourraient être contaminés c'est
pour cela que nous prenons les gestes
barrières que nous prônons le lavage des
mains que nous prônons la distanciation
sociales et des mesures de restriction
sont prises partout où c'est nécessaire
sur l'ensemble du territoire et nous
continuerons
monsieur j'ai oublié
mais seul mini je suis tout de même un
peu inquiet de vous entendre dire qu'il
n'ya pas de dysfonctionnement de l'état
tous les rapports tous les travaux
effectués montrent qu'il ya un problème
d'organisation et qui est un problème
dans les processus de décision
cette myriade d'agents sanitaires mal
coordonnées entre elles la création par
le chef de l'état d'instance nouvelle
alors que la crise est en cours témoigne
témoigne de ces difficultés
tout le monde est responsable certes
mais certains ont plus de
responsabilités que d'autres
il n'est pas digne de renvoyer aux
français la responsabilité de cette
seconde vague
elle est en premier la responsabilité de
ceux qui n'ont pas su analyser et agir à
temps la stratégie tester tracé isolé
est en échec et les français n'y sont
pour rien alors monsieur le ministre
nous attendons ce soir l' annonce de
nouvelles mesures restrictives
elles seront le marqueur de l'échec de
notre politique de santé publique
ayons le courage de le reconnaître merci
la parole est à notre collègue jean yves
roux pour le gros du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur
leproux ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues le
confinement et la nécessité de vivre
avait là que 8,19 dans nos soucis des
gestes-barrières en accéléré des
pratiques dématérialisée dans tous les
aspects essentiels de la vie quotidienne
ça l'est encore plus dans l'attenté de
l'intervention ce soir du président de
la république
or dans les faits monsieur le ministre
les ruraux depuis des mois nous rapporte
en homme ne pas avoir accès aux plus
élémentaires et moyens de communication
le téléphone
combien de personnes se retrouvent ainsi
isolés hors d'atteinte
en cas d'urgence leur ligne téléphone
définitivement en panne ou sans aucune
ligne mobile je rappellerai mes chers
collègues qui a plus de
commercialisation des lignes
téléphoniques fixes depuis novembre 2019
et que l'entretien minima des lignes
pourtant promis a lui aussi été arrêté
nos champions technologiques
internationaux et leurs sous-traitants
rafistol ainsi des poteaux tomber en les
attachant aux arbres avec de la rubalise
cunti ne débranche pas le voisin pour
accorder un autre vous allez me répondre
monsieur le ministre que la fibre ou
toute autre possibilité de raccordement
numériques sont bien prévues dans nos
territoires d'ici 2025 ce qui devrait
tout résoudre cinq ans dans cette
situation sans téléphone fonctionnel et
sans débit suffisant chers collègues
dans le contexte de pandémie qui dure la
70e ou encadrements des personnes
positives à la coved voir confie de main
rapide
comment nos jeunes pourront ils
continuer à étudier nos concitoyens à
avoir recours au télétravail ou tout
simplement comment pourrons-nous
télécharger tout en tics hovig mes chers
collègues dans cette crise majeure que
nous traversons où la communication joue
un rôle si important
nous voulons tous être des artisans du
plan de relance et n'ont pu les
malgré-nous du plan du silence ainsi ma
question est la suivante quelle garantie
monsieur le ministre vous pouvez vous
donner aux français de la ruralité pour
disposer très vite de droit la
communication la plus élémentaire
la 4g pu ce n'était pas la solution
technologique la plus adaptée à déployer
maintenant nous ne pouvons plus attendre
et pas attendre 5
je vous remercie quand vous répondre la
parole et au secrétaire d'état chargé de
la transition numérique des
communications électroniques monsieur
c'est vrai qu il avait la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur je pense que votre question est
l'occasion de rappeler que au delà des
débats qui nous agitent actuellement sur
les nouvelles technologies
la question de la réduction de la
fracture numérique est la première
priorité en matière de numérique de ce
gouvernement
quelques chiffres monsieur les sénateurs
pour rappeler les efforts qui sont faits
vous citiez la question du mobile dans
le précédent plan qui avaient été
déployés par les majorités précédente
pour la réduction des zones blanches
juste pour bien rappeler les chiffres
c'est 600 pylônes qui ont été allumés
dans les zones blanches entre 2003 et
2010 8 600 pilotes en 2003 entre 2003 à
2018 grâce au new deal mobile signée par
ce gouvernement l'arcep et les
opérateurs ce sont 2000 pylône dans les
deux années qui viennent
dix à douze mille pylônes en huit ans
tous dans vos territoires vous avez des
équipes projets d un nombre de pylônes
qui sont assignés chaque mois et je
rappelle je rappelle mesdames et
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs que
la prochaine levée des copies pour
l'ensemble de l'année 2000 21 c'est à la
fin de l'année et donc je vous
invite à nous indiquer les endroits où
vous voulez qu'on mette des pylônes dans
les deux ans qui viennent premiers
éléments sur la fibre oui vous avez
raison monsieur le sénateur c'est
toujours trop lents mais si on regarde
ce qui se passe en europe
aujourd'hui la france est le pays qui
grâce à l'action des collectivités
territoriales conjointement avec l'état
et les opérateurs a le plus grand nombre
de kilomètres de fibres qui est déployée
et la moitié de la fibre qui se déploie
en europe se déploie en france cela ne
doit pas empêcher monsieur le sénateur
vous avez raison de continuer à
entretenir le réseau téléphonique et
nous faisons en sorte en mettant la
pression sur les opérateurs c'est ce qui
s'est passé dernièrement dans le gard de
faire en sorte que l'opérateur
historique notamment continué à
entretenir ce réseau téléphonique
nous voulons faire en sorte aussi que
cela se déploie encore plus rapidement
afin de faire de cette de ce droit à la
connexion un service universel c'est
pour ça que nous avons annoncées avec le
premier ministre et son gouvernement que
nous ferions de la fibre un suivre
service universel à l'horizon 2025
et s'agissant de la 5g que le france est
le seul pays à avoir réservé un quart
des pylônes 5 g pour les zones rurales
merci la parole est à notre collègue
raymonde poncet mange pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire de la
parole merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des solidarités de la santé
monsieur le ministre la crise sanitaire
qui vous occupe mais c'est au ministre
des solidarités auquel je m'adresse avec
la crise sanitaire et économique
un million de personnes sont en train de
basculer dans la pauvreté s'ajoute aux
plus de 9 millions de personnes vivent
déjà en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
ce sont plus de 800 mille personnes qui
risquent de perdre leur emploi d'ici la
fin de l'année
les lois anti travail successives au
flexibiliser précarisés des emplois
aujourd'hui sont touchés les moins
qualifiés ceux qui ont chaîne les cdd
les travailleurs intérimaires ou les
jeunes la protection sociale joue moi
qui hier son rôle d'amortisseur social
contre contre cyclique en cause les
réformes qui ont abaissé les droits je
pense à la réforme de l'assurance
chômage donc dont nous demandons
aujourd'hui solennellement l'abrogation
il est encore plus d'un des 100 kg avant
de
prétendre qu'il suffit de traverser la
rue pour trouver un emploi des milliards
sont distribués aux entreprises sans
conditionnalité sociale et écologique et
seulement quelques millions aux ménages
aux situations de pauvreté alors que des
mesures fiscales ont enrichi les héros à
pour 100 ménages les plus riches
la crise doivent remettre à l'agenda du
gouvernement
la résorption du mal logement et le plan
de prévention et de lutte contre la
pauvreté dont l'acte 2 récemment est
clair on n'est clairement pas à la
hauteur pour le groupe écologiste du
sénat les mesures sanitaires doivent
impérativement être accompagné de
mesures sociales à la hauteur de
l'urgence sociale
dans ce contexte monsieur le ministre
quelles mesures sociales d'urgence
proposez vous pour les ménages les plus
modestes
merci pour vous répondre la parole et
mobilise des solidarités et de la santé
madame la sénatrice pour ses manches je
vous remercie pour votre question et
vous avez raison la crise a aggravé les
inégalités sociales et la crise aggrave
la précarité pour bon nombre de français
dans notre pays c'est le cas d'ailleurs
dans le monde dans le monde entier la
seule chose que je ne partage pas dans
le constat que vous faites madame la
sénatrice si je puis me permettre c'est
quand vous dites que la protection
sociale ne joue plus son rôle
d'amortisseur
s'il ya bien un système dont nous
pouvons nous targuer dans notre pays
c'est d'avoir une sécurité sociale qui
joue justement cette ce rôle
d'amortisseur et de protecteur
souvenez-vous de la crise bancaire et
économique de 2008 il ya eu trois fois
moins de nouveaux pauvres en france
qu'en allemagne parce que la protection
sociale a joué son rôle
quitte à faire des dépenses publiques et
des dépenses publiques nous en avons
vous aurez à examiner le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
qui est le plus élevé de toute
l'histoire en matière de dépenses
publiques y compris dans l'art et aux
d'ailleurs de salaire de personnes qui
ne gagnaient pas très bien leur vie
la sénatrice le gouvernement a engagé
non pas quelques millions mais plus de 3
milliards d'euros d'ores et déjà en
soutien aux plus précaires dans notre
pays
le premier ministre a annoncé lui-même
une aide exceptionnelle de solidarité
qui sera à nouveau versé à plus de
quatre mois millions de foyers en
difficulté
il ya eu une augmentation de
l'allocation rentrée scolaire il y a eu
une autre aide exceptionnelle qui avait
été versée parfois de plusieurs
centaines d'euros par famille au cours
du mois de mai et juin dernier pour
faire face à la crise parce que c'est
vrai que les dépenses augmentent le
confinement augmenter les dépenses
le confinement
réduit les sources d'appoint financiers
qui étaient des petits boulots par
exemple parfois c'était les cantines qui
était fermée pendant de confinement tout
cela a eu un coût mais madame la
sénatrice lorsque le plan de relance
lorsque le plan européen et français de
relance investi massivement comme jamais
la france l'avait fait dans l'accès à
l'emploi et à la formation
professionnelle pour des jeunes
la france fait le choix de lutter contre
la première cause de précarité
la première cause de précarité vous le
savez c'est le chômage est le premier
moyen de sortir de la précarité la
misère c'est l'emploi donc aider
accompagner les jeunes à trouver de
l'emploi en entreprise c'est pas donner
de l'argent aux entreprises s'est donné
des chances et de l'espoir aux jeunes de
notre pays pour qu'ils puissent accéder
à l'emploi éviter la pauvreté la misère
voilà bon chez mange ministre je crois
que le compte n'y est pas donc permettez
moi de vous faire ou non du groupe
écologiste quelques suggestions
il nous faut une augmentation et le
versement automatique des minima sociaux
pour lutter contre le non recours
l'extension du rsa aux 18-25 ans la
paupérisation de la jeunesse oblitère
l'avenir la réquisition de logements
pour les sans abri un appui financier
humain aux associations luttant contre
la pauvreté
leur retour des contrats aidés et la
mise en place ils vont conclure je te je
conclue 6
l'assemblée veut bien faire silence la
mise en place immédiate d'un chèque
alimentaires tel que proposé par la
convention citoyenne pour le climat que
vous avez décidé d'appliquer
merci merci la parole et à notre
collègue joël guerriau pour le groupe
les indépendants république et
territoires
ta anti-grippe que nous avons et sur les
vaccins contre le coc vide ou là que
vides plutôt que nous espérons chaque
année la grippe saisonnière touche des
millions de français en traîne des
milliers d'admission en urgence le
vaccin contre la grippe sauvent des vies
et limite les complications les mesures
appliquées contre la queue vide 19
devrait ralentir la propagation de
l'épidémie grippale de façon plus
certaine il s'agit de limiter
l'engorgement des hôpitaux et les
erreurs de diagnostic liées à des
symptômes similaires entre les deux
virus
de plus les risques de double infection
semble réel
dans ce contexte les français sont
invités très largement à se vacciner
contre la grippe
d'où une demande globale en forte
augmentation cette année plus de 15
millions de personnes sont destinataires
de prescription de vaccins les commandes
de votre ministère aurait été passé en
mars dernier sur la base du chiffre de
l'année dernière avec une augmentation
de 30 %
malgré cet effort au-delà de la campagne
de vaccination ciblant les personnes les
plus vulnérables
allons-nous réellement pouvoir couvrir
l'ensemble des demandes de cette année
enfin la lumière de cette expérience
comment allez vous anticipez le bon
approvisionnement en france des vaccins
contre lacko vite 19 lorsqu'ils seront
disponibles sur le marché mondial pour
vous répondre
la parole les tabliers verront ministre
des solidarités de la santé monsieur le
sénateur joël guerriau alors c'est pas
le gouvernement qui fait des commandes
de vaccin antigrippal ce sont les
pharmacies d'officine qui s'équipent
il se trouve que cette année les
pharmaciens sont autorisés à vacciner
contre la grippe de manière plus
importante que les années précédentes et
les commandes ne les passe pas en mars
mais mois de décembre dernier avant même
l'épidémie une chance dans notre malheur
si je puis dire c'est que les
pharmaciens considérant qu'ils avaient
vacciner davantage on commande un peu
plus de vaccins que les années
précédentes et par ailleurs au printemps
lorsque l'épidémie a commencé
nous avons fait le choix pour la
première fois de nous doter d'un stock
d'état complémentaire de vaccins à
mettre à disposition des officiers et
des hôpitaux si jamais la situation
devait l'exiger
quelle est la situation précise nous
avons consommé en cinq jours
l'équivalent d'un mois de doses de
vaccin antigrippal une ruée véritable
ruée sur les pharmacies
82% des personnes qui ont acheté des
vaccins en pharmacie sont âgées de 65
ans et plus ils sont donc parfaitement
dans la cible et sur les 18 % qui
restent un certain nombre d'entre eux
correspondent à des sites à des
soignants des prestataires du domicile
ils sont donc dans la cible est à des
gens qui sont porteurs de comorbidité de
pathologies qui rend la vaccination
antigrippale nécessaire pour eux là
encore on est dans la cible un certain
nombre de formations pour face à des
ruptures de stock pour la plupart
temporaire je vous rassure cette semaine
un million trois cent mille doses
supplémentaires sont livrés pour ré
achalandé les pharmacies 3 millions de
doses vont suivre à destination des
pharmaciens seller commandes habituelles
et au cours du mois de novembre et même
jusqu'à début décembre l'état se
pourvoir en vaccins pour pouvoir
réaliser achalandé ces pharmacies
monsieur le sénateur il n'y a pas
d'urgence puisque la grippe ne démarre
pas avant noël dans l'hémisphère sud
elle a même été retardé et qu'une
vaccination doit être fait au bon moment
et mon appel monsieur le sénateur mon
appel ma crainte n'est pas que nous
manquions vaccin ma crainte est que nous
ne soyons pas assez nombreux parmi les
publics vulnérables à avoir une
vaccination antigrippale faute d'aller
décidé se faire vacciner l'année
dernière 48 % du public cible c'était
vacciner leurs maîtres commandes
atteindre 75%
je souhaite ardemment que les publics
vulnérables et fragiles les médecins et
les soignants les acteurs du domicile et
se fassent vacciner
il en va de la protection des français
c'est là notre objectif et les dom et
les et l'accès au vaccin
suivra vous pouvez compter sur le réseau
des pharmaciens pour cela je guerriau
monsieur le ministre j'ai bien entendu
votre réponse et je vous en remercie
la difficulté que nous ayons c'est de
pouvoir y voir clair dans les chiffres
j'étais allé chercher j'ai cherché les
chiffres à peu près partout et j'ai
trouvé des des commandes est un acronyme
aider vraiment des choses que je
n'arrivais pas à expliquer donc je
n'arrive pas à fixer le chiffre il
semblerait que c'est de l'ordre de 13
millions de vaccins qui auraient été
commandés peut-être avec + 30 % 17
millions maximum elle mais tant qu'il ya
eu 17 millions de commandes et on sait
qu'aujourd'hui la population française
des plus de 65 ans elle porte sur 13
millions d'individus entre 60 et 65 ans
vous rajouter 4 millions donc vous avez
vos 17 millions à plus de
sur la base des plus de 60 ans donc on
voit bien que on est sur un nombre de
vaccins disponibles qui risque d'être en
dessous d'une demande si effectivement
comme on le voit aujourd'hui il ya une
vraie tension qui fait que les
pharmacies ne peuvent pas répondre à ces
personnes qui se présentent
l'autre aspect de ma question c'est est
une égard à cette expérience qui devra
forcément avoir des effets et un impact
de la même manière sur le vaccin du coc
vite 19
il me paraît important de pouvoir
anticiper et de se projeter une
association qui sera compliqué merci la
parole est à notre collègue alain milon
pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
ministre la situation épidémique de
notre pays est inquiétante
l'augmentation de la circulation du
virus est désormais exponentielle et
nous sommes dans la deuxième vague et
nous nous apprêtons à vivre
malheureusement le remake de la
précédente
la première vague a été celle de
l'improvisation ni masque ni j'aille
hydraulique ni blouse pénurie de
médicaments injonctions contradictoires
à répétition du gouvernement d' inutile
le port du masque est devenu obligatoire
sous peine de sanctions les faux pas et
le pilotage à vue des pouvoirs publics
se sont succédé au discours
contradictoires du gouvernement et de
l'exécutif se sont malheureusement mail
et ceux tout aussi contradictoires des
scientifiques ébloui pour certains par
les feux de la rampe
la seconde vague et celle de la
préparation
elle avait pourtant été annoncé dès le
mois de juillet par le conseil
scientifique et le professeur jean
françois delfraissy l'avait dit et
répété il le dit lui même il n'a pas été
écouté par ailleurs nous apprenons
monsieur le ministre par la presse que
le général lee jurés missionné par le
premier ministre en avril dernier a
proposé 21 une solution pour mieux gérer
la crise sanitaire le minimum aurait été
d'en informer le parlement ou au moins
la commission denquête ce qui n'a pas
été le cas
le répit laissé par le virus cet été
aurait dû être mis à profit pour mieux
nous préparer
il n'en a rien été on a laissé les
français se faire traiter en masse pour
faire du chiffre
sans stratégie ce qui a embelli c'est le
système avec des résultats pour les
patients qui parfois mettait plus d'une
semaine à arriver si l'on a beaucoup
parlé des brigades sanitaire peu les ont
vus pourquoi ne pas avoir mis à profit
ce mois d'été monsieur ministres pour
préparer l'ouverture de lits de
réanimation supplémentaires vous en avez
annoncé 12000 le 27 août dernier il n'y
en a que 5 milles 7 dont 5000
opérationnel pourquoi ne pas avoir cet
été formé des jumeaux des aides
soignants des infirmiers
des internes pour venir en renfort au
service de réanimation en tant que de
besoin
ma question monsieur le ministre est
simple espérez vous un jour sortir la
france de cette crise pour vous répondre
aux parents les communistes des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
président millions j'ai d'abord vous
répondre sur l'état de préparation ou 7
à cet été monsieur center millions il ya
plusieurs milliers de soignants qui ont
été formés par le gouvernement ni par
vous d'ailleurs mais par les hôpitaux
par les facultés par les régions
déterminante déterminante qui ont
augmenté les capacités de formation
express de plusieurs milliers de
soignants pour qu'ils puissent venir
participer aux soins dans les services
de réanimation cet été 15 % de lits de
réanimation supplémentaires sont restés
armée équipée ouvert de façon pérenne
dans notre pays 15% pouvait considérer
que c'est peu en trois mois pour les
hôpitaux qu'on fait cet effort je peux
vous garantir que c'est beaucoup c'est
le sénateur millions vos chiffres datent
5700 lit c'était avant-hier
hier nous étions assis 1400 lits et
bientôt nous allons monter à 7500 lits
pourquoi nous manteau progressivement
monsieur le sénateur parce que si nous
des programmes ils ont tous les soins
d'un coup évidemment montré tout de
suite a diminué en 2010 mais un celi ne
serait pas aujourd'hui utilisé par des
malades qu vide et 2 on retardera des
soins utiles pour les français et vous
me poseriez a raison cette fois ci la
question de savoir pourquoi est ce qu'on
ne souhaite pas les français avec des
lits vides donc cette montée en gamme se
fait de façon progressive monsieur le
sénateur on n'a pas testé à vide un
million neuf cent mille tests sont
réalisés par semaine dans notre pays
avec un taux de positivité des tests de
plus de 17%
croyez-moi on teste pas à vide et je me
souviens de débat ici on me demandait
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne testez pas aux
populations asymptomatiques tous azimuts
par ailleurs 100 mille appels sont
passés par jour par les ars et
l'assurance maladie auprès des personnes
qui sont mises à l'abri en raison du coc
vide et après monsieur le sénateur
cantal à savoir qui avait raison qu'ils
avaient tort sur la deuxième vague
je laisse les français qui regardent
public sénat
cherchez la dernière fois que j'étais en
train de répondre à ce micro dans cet
hémicycle c'était il ya quelques jours
je crois que l'une des dernières
interventions j'avais fait monsieur le
rapporteur bas s'en souvient parce qu'il
était d'accord avec moi c'était pour
demander aux sénateurs de droite et de
gauche d'avoir la responsabilité de ne
pas voter un amendement déposé par tous
les groupes de sénateurs visant à
empêcher le gouvernement de fermer des
établissements recevant du public
et autorisant donc de fait c'était il ya
quelques jours la réouverture des
discothèques à marseille des restaurants
à lyon des bars à saint-etienne à telle
enseigne qu une deuxième délibération a
été demandée dans l'urgence par les
sénateurs voyant l'erreur qui a été
commise donc s'il vous plaît pas de son
la parole est à madame nathalie goulet
pour le groupe de l'union centriste avez
la parole
oui monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur ce
musée l'intérieur je voudrais d'abord et
à travers vous tous le gouvernement vous
féliciter pour les mesures qui ont été
prises il ya quelques jours
d'abord la dissolution du collectif
cheikh yacine
et ce matin la dissolution de baraka
city nous l'attendions depuis longtemps
c'est fait mais depuis quelques jours
des attaques d'une violence inacceptable
contre le président de la république et
contre la france se propage via des
médias des pays arabes et des médias
turcs qui sont autant de vecteurs de
haine pouvant inciter à la violence
physique tour eiffel ensanglanté
discours de l discours gravement
antisémite appel à la violence
la chaîne qatarienne al jazeera en arabe
multiplient les attaques comme la chaîne
turque trt on sait que le qatar et la
turquie soutiennent la mouvance des
frères musulmans dont j'ai demandé à de
multiples reprises l'interdiction en
france
leur leader youssouf qaradawi interdit
de séjour dans de nombreux pays
européens multiplient les appels à la
haine un des derniers en date était un
hommage appuyé au travail d'hitler
précisant même qu'en chaise roulante il
irait à battre des juifs nous avons
monsieur le ministre les outils
juridiques lactique que deux caps de la
directive européenne services médias
audiovisuels nous avons également qui a
été retranscrite dans la loi du 30
septembre 86 les services télévisuels
sont soumis au contrôle du csa
particulièrement vigilants pour réprimer
l'incitation à la haine à la violence et
à d'autres manquements il y a dix ans le
csa avait interdit la chaîne dur hamas
al aqsa et même la chaîne al manar or la
situation en 2010 était bien moins grave
que celle que nous traversons
aujourd'hui
alors ma question est simple monsieur le
ministre allez vous engager des
procédures pour interdire la chaîne al
jezira et la chaîne trt des réseaux
français merci
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur gérald darmanin monsieur le
président messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice
permettez moi effectivement de vous
remercier pour les propos
d'encouragement pour le gouvernement de
la république dans les décisions
difficiles qu'il prend le groupement de
fait chaque hassine effectivement quand
a été dissout la semaine dernière en
conseil des ministres un groupement créé
en 2004 et baraka city qui ce matin à la
demande du président à vue qui a été
dissous l'association qui a été créée en
2010 et d'autre à la demande du
président de la république nous pensons
d'ailleurs au ccf sera présenté à la
demande du premier ministre dans les
semaines qui viennent
vous évoquez la question des réactions
internationales
je pourrais remarqué devant vous que le
discours du président de la république
était juste celui qui consistait à
vouloir couper des influences étrangères
des affaires intérieures françaises
parce que nous en france nous
considérons que les français de
confession musulmane n'appartiennent à
aucune puissance étrangère et nous
considérons qu'il s'agit d'affaires
française respectant la souveraineté
française et d'une des gnons toute
responsabilité à quelques dirigeants
d'un pays aussi grand soit-il que le
peuple turc par exemple et de ses
dirigeants pour se mêler des affaires
françaises troisièmement vous avez
évoqué la question des chaînes
télévisées
je voudrais apporter de réponse sous
l'autorité du premier ministre
le csa a des dispositions c'est une
autorité administrative indépendante
je sais que le premier ministre a un nom
du président de la république avec la
ministre en charge de la communication
et la culture aura l'occasion d'évoquer
cela avec le président du csa pour
qu'une éventuelle mesure soit prise et
l'autorité ni strativa dépendance il
répondra auprès du premier ministre mais
surtout nous avons une négociation très
importante celle de la directive que met
en place la commission européenne et
premier ministre est allé la semaine
dernière avec clément bonne discuté avec
la présidente de la commission avec le
commissaire thierry breton pour que la
directive deee dsk qui permet de lutter
contre la haine en ligne et contre
effectivement un certain nombre de
vecteurs de qom
éducation qui pourrait être encadré pour
ne pas dire interdit et transposer la
loi française soit fait dans la loi dite
séparatisme que j'aurai l'honneur de
porter dans votre parlement je suis sûr
qu'à ce moment là vous aiderez la france
avoir les moyens de lutter contre ses
ennemis de l'extérieur
madame ou les cinq minutes je suis je
suis un peu déçu j'ai pas attendre la
loi des séparatismes et et monsieur le
ministre nous on nous avons des attaques
tous les jours les attaques qui sont
insupportables et qui ont été lancés
contre le président de la république
française ne doivent pas ne doit pas
continuer le csa a les moyens avec la
directive de prendre des mesures de
suspension provisoire
je pense que c'est extrêmement important
qu'on n'attende pas une directive
européenne et un texte à venir pour
prendre des décisions vous savez très
bien et je croque conclut samuel patil a
payé que ces vecteurs de haine peuvent
entraîner de la violence physique sur
nos concitoyens il faut agir
la parole est au président pierre
laurent pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen que les avaient la
parole monsieur le président madame la
ministre le premier ministre a reçu
lundi avec la ministre du travail les
cinq centrales syndicales elles vous ont
adressé une demande claire unanime le
retrait définitif de votre réforme de
l'assurance chômage
cette réforme n'a qu'un but économiser
sur l'indemnisation du chômage
c'était déjà terriblement injuste mais
devant le drame économique qui se joue
c'est indigne
c'est inhumain et c'est contraire à
l'avenir des forces du travail qu'il
faut préserver
c'est tellement vrai que vous n'osez pas
appliquer cette réforme vous l'avait
reportée de trois mois une première fois
puis maintenant de trois 3 mois une
seconde fois mais vous persistez à
vouloir l'appliquer plus tard
pourquoi cet entêtement des centaines de
milliers d'emplois vont être détruits
menace est fragilisé par la crise on
annonce près d'un million deux cent
mille chômeurs supplémentaires l'année
prochaine
appliquer cette réforme aujourd'hui
serait un scandale parce que celle
inverse de ce qu il faut plus de
protection sociale et pas moi
le plan de relance donne beaucoup
d'argent aux entreprises
mais le medef continue de demander de
l'économie sur le chômage
c'est inacceptable ma question est
simple madame la ministre
pourquoi refusez-vous d'entendre
l'évidence qu'attendez vous pour atteint
abandonner cette réforme on vous
répondre la parole et à la milice
délégué en charge de l'insertion madame
klinkert avait la parole merci monsieur
le président monsieur le sénateur pierre
laurent la réforme de l'assurance
chômage a en effet a été abordée lundi
en conférence de dialogue social
organisé par le premier ministre avec
les partenaires sociaux
compte tenu de la situation sanitaire il
existe aujourd'hui un consensus pour
reporter l'application de cette réforme
le gouvernement fait pleinement
confiance au dialogue social et aux
partenaires sociaux pour trouver de
nouveaux équilibres et le gouvernement
est prêt est prêt à adapter des
paramètres à la nouvelle situation de
l'emploi pour autant permettez moi de
vous dire
cette réforme est une bonne réforme elle
repose elle repose sur deux piliers
encourager les entreprises à avoir des
emplois de meilleure qualité et
s'assurer et s'assurer que quand on
reprend une activité on est mieux
rémunéré que quand on est demandeur
d'emploi et ses principes restent
pertinents aujourd'hui évidemment il
faut tenir compte du nouveau contexte
c'est pourquoi c'est pourquoi nous avons
annoncé un report de trois mois
supplémentaires de cette réforme
quel est l'objectif de ce report
l'objectif c'est de prendre le temps
prendre le temps de discuter des
paramètres avec les partenaires sociaux
car le gouvernement mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs le gouvernement est
attentif aux difficultés que peuvent
avoir certains demandeurs d'emploi et
notamment les plus précaires
je tiens d'ailleurs à rappeler que nous
agissons depuis le début de la crise
pour protéger tous les salariés et les
compétences nous avons mis en place un
dispositif d'activité partielle d'une
ampleur inédite qui a permis de près
hervé l'emploi de près de neuf millions
9 millions de françaises et de français
en avril dernier monsieur le sénateur la
situation l'exigent
dans le moment singulier que nous
traversons nous devons savoir nous
rassembler je vous remercie monsieur le
président laurent madame la ministre
votre réponse n'est pas sérieuse soit la
réforme est bonne comme vous le dites
alors il faut l'appliquer
soit elle est mauvaise il faut la
retirer alors moi je vais vous donner
les chiffres
moi je vais vous donner les chiffres qui
ont été données lors de la réunion qui
sont les projections officielles qui
sont faites si la réforme est appliquée
au 1er janvier 2021
elle impacterait à la baisse les
indemnités d'un million deux cent mille
chômeurs elle permettrait d'économiser
un milliard et demi en 2021 et 2
milliards 6 en 2022
donc on donne 100 milliards au plan de
relance et on n'a qu'une obsession c'est
économiser 2 milliards et des milliards
2022 sur le dos des chômeurs alors
ajouté de l'injustice à l'injustice
c'est toujours une faute mais dans la
situation à concurrence est une faute
politique
impardonnable d'un fare alais au
président christian cambon pour le
groupe l'est républicain monsieur le
président
c'est le président ma question s'adresse
au ministre des affaires étrangères
depuis des mois la turquie de monsieur r
2 one multiplie les provocations à
l'égard de ses alliés occidentaux
chantage aux flux migratoires achats
d'armes russes pour fragiliser le temps
forages gaziers illégaux dans les eaux
grec et chypriote offensive contre nos
alliés kurde en syrie ingérence en libye
pis encore de manière irresponsable
au lieu d'agir en faveur de la paix la
turquie attise le terrible conflit du
haut karabagh en envoyant des avions des
drones suicide et des mercenaires pour
soutenir l'offensive de l'azerbaïdjan
contre l'arménie
ceci n'est pas encore suffisant alors
que la france vient de traverser un
drame épouvantable
le président turc offense par ses propos
le président de la république insultant
par là même notre pays tout entier
comble de l'inacceptable
cet amalgame inadmissible avec la
situation des juifs dans les années 30
qui donne la nausée
alors monsieur le ministre va-t-on
encore une fois de plus c'est sans
réagir
supporter longtemps d'être le bouc
émissaire de la crise économique et
politique qui secoue la turquie
si la turquie nous trouve aussi
infréquentable va-t-on par exemple
continuer à prêter chaque année 300
millions d'euros 3 milliards depuis dix
ans à ce pays et cette année l'afd qui
s'apprête à monter à porter ce montant à
400 millions connaissez vous monsieur le
ministre un banquier qui vous prêtent de
l'argent pour se faire copieusement
insulté alors me dit-on oui la france a
aussi des intérêts comme ses voisins des
intérêts économiques en turquie
je ne le mets connais pas mais l'appel
au boycott des produits français déjà
une réponse et devrait nous inciter à
beaucoup plus de lucidité pour l'avenir
de nos entreprises dans ce pays alors ma
question est bien simple
quelles mesures allez vous prendre
ici en france et aussi au conseil
européen de décembre où nos amis sont un
petit peu nous on va dire sur leur
soutien pour sanctionner les dirigeants
nationalistes qui veut jouer à
l'empereur ottoman alors qu'il fait
offense à son peuple et aussi à
l'histoire même de la turquie merci la
parole et autres secrétaires d'état
chargé des affaires européennes
monsieur clément bonne monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président quand
bon permettez moi tout d'abord de vous
prier de bien vouloir excuser l'absence
de jean yves le drian de miss de
l'europe des affaires étrangères qui est
retenu par un deuil familial
je rejoins en tout point ce que vous
dites sur la turquie le dernier épisode
qui repousse chaque jour les frontières
de l'inacceptable du président erdogan
qui a insulté le prendre la république
merci pour cette unité dans le soutien
est révélateur non pas d'un moment de
tension passagers mais d'une stratégie
d'ensemble que vous avez décrite ce qui
est celle de la turquie de multiplier
les provocations tous azimuts
c'est toujours le même objectif exercer
une pression maximale sur ses voisins et
singulièrement bien sûr sur l'union
européenne
nous avons trop longtemps été naïf et je
crois que puisque vous rappeler les
propos qui ont été tenus à l'égard dû
prendre la république c'est l'honneur de
la france et c'est l'honneur du grand de
la république d'avoir tout au long des
derniers mois en particulier essayer de
dessiner l'europe l'union européenne sur
ce qu'est la réalité du régime turc
actuel ce qu'est la réalité de la
politique étrangère turque car c'est la
même stratégie du haut karabakh à la
libye en passant par la méditerranée
orientale et les insultes dont vous
faisiez et 1 je crois que nous avons
était le fer de lance de cette prise de
conscience européenne qui vous avez
raison n'est pas encore suffisante mais
les mots de solidarité qui ont été
exprimées ces derniers jours par
l'ensemble des dirigeants européens sans
ambiguïté sont aussi un fait nouveau qui
marque le que le consensus évolué vers
une position de fermeté qui a défendu la
france
nous allons aller plus loin et vous avez
raison nous continuerons cette stratégie
de réactions françaises et européennes
cela peut passer par de nouvelles
sanctions je rappelle que la france en
avait été à l'initiative
l'an dernier après des forages déjà dans
les eaux chypriotes nous avons un rendez
vous
sai européen de décembre et nous
pousserons évidemment en faveur de
mesures européennes de réaction forte
dont l'outil possible des sanctions faut
être précis aussi ça ne va pas être le
résumé de notre politique étrangère y
compris à l'égard de la turquie et le
prix dans la république n'a pas hésité
non plus à avoir des mesures de réaction
par une présence militaire renforcée par
exemple en méditerranée orientale
cet été un point précis sur la question
que vous soulevez des financements
français et européens l'agencé française
de développement est active depuis 2004
en turquie elle doit elle est en train
de le faire revoir sa politique
d'intervention d'évidence en turquie je
tiens à signaler pour qu'il n'y ait
aucune ambiguïté que d'ores et déjà il
n'y a pas de subvention versée la
turquie il ya semble de prêt qui ne
transite pas par l'état turc et qui
soutiennent un certain nombre d'actions
de la société civile mais nous reverrons
aussi cette politique européenne et
française de prêt à la turquie parmi
d'autres instruments de réponse dans la
prochain dans les prochains mois merci
en tout cas de votre soutien surprise la
parole et un autre collègue étienne
poumirol pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste qui régule qu'il y avait la
parole merci le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre nous avons depuis plusieurs
mois la crise sanitaire qui est abattue
sur notre pays est aussi une crise
économique et sociale
la deuxième vague et les mesures qui
vont être prises dans les prochaines
heures vont encore prolongé les
terribles effets de ces restrictions
pour beaucoup de français un million de
français de plus sous le seuil de
pauvreté ont rejoint les plus de 9
millions qui étaient déjà chiffre en
augmentation depuis 2018
cette situation est dramatique et il
aurait fallu réagir plus en amont plus
rapidement et plus efficacement vous
annonce de samedi dernier ne répondent
pas à ces trois impératifs
vous pratiquez un saupoudrage qu'il
prend pas en compte l'ampleur de ce qui
est déjà là et encore moins de ce qui
nous attend dans notre pays
votre plan est centré sur l'insertion
par l'activité
cela est certes nécessaire mais
insuffisant en particulier quand les
perspectives de création d'emplois sont
celles d'aujourd'hui
les jeunes les plus précaires les
nouveaux précaires sortie de votre radar
à cela vous proposer des aides
exceptionnelles et ponctuelles
quand la deuxième vague nous confirme
qu'un grand nombre de français risque de
s'installer dans une précarité sur un
temps long il faut ouvrir donc le revenu
minimum aux jeunes présentent péché de
sombrer revenir sur votre réforme des
apl revaloriser les minima sociaux
augmenter la part du plan de relance
pour soutenir les plus précaires et
notamment en ce qui concerne l'aide
alimentaire les associations caritatives
nous ont dit que cette demande explose
depuis six mois
parfois multiplié par deux voire par
trois et ne répondait pas qu'il ne faut
pas prolonger les populations dans les
minima sociaux
la question n'est plus là la seule qui
doit se poser est la suivante
allez vous enfin adapter votre politique
de lutte contra pour d'autres et à la
situation actuelle
on vous répondra par le cannabis délégué
chargé de l'insertion le ministre merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice
poumirol vous m'interrogez sur les
conséquences de la crise sur l'emploi et
l'insertion
le premier ministre vous l'avez rappelé
le premier ministre a annoncé samedi
plusieurs mesures pour lutter contre la
pauvreté et contre la précarité mesure
qui s'ajoute aux mesures déjà prises
précédemment
nous nous battons et nous nous battrons
pour ne laisser personne sur le bord de
la route
c'est pourquoi nous augmentons de
nouveau le nombre de places en insertion
par l'activité économique aux cent mille
places prévues s'ajouteront 30 mille
places supplémentaires comme l'a annoncé
le premier ministre
le budget 2021 prévoyait déjà 1,2
milliard d'euros pour l'iae soit 204
millions de plus qu'en 2020 samedi le
premier ministre a annoncé 150 millions
d'euros supplémentaires pour l'iae
c'est inédit est essentiel l'insertion
par l'activité économique sera l'une des
clés pour lutter contre le chômage et
donc pour lutter contre la précarité
madame la sénatrice nous entendons
l'urgence sociale et économique
c'est pourquoi ai je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure nous avons reporté la réforme de
l'assurance chômage de 3 mois cette
réforme je le rappelle est une bonne
réforme mais elle
être adapté à la situation le
gouvernement s'est donc donné trois mois
supplémentaires pour dialoguer avec les
partenaires sociaux
certains par certains paramètres vont
être adaptés plus précisément le
contexte salutaire et économique a mis
en lumière aussi les difficultés pour
les personnes en contrat court un
certain nombre il ya un nombre important
de salariés précaires qui parvenait
avant la crise a effectué suffisamment
de contrats courts pour maintenir un
certain niveau de revenus ne le peuvent
plus vous le savez ce sont les
saisonniers les extras de l'hôtellerie
de la restauration ou de l'événementiel
mais pas seulement
nous sommes très attentifs à leur
situation et cherchons actuellement des
solutions
madame la sénatrice vous le comprenez
nous ne laisserons personne sur le bord
du chemin
bonhomme ou birol quelques secondes
madame la ministre votre réponse est
pour le moins une très évasive et je
dirais que l'urgence sociale qui fait
jour aujourd'hui
vous niez pas très sensible dans dans
votre réponse moi j'aurais aimé avoir
une réponse à la fois précise et
concrète pour tous ces gens qui viennent
frapper à la porte de nos crs ou des
associations et qui voire même n'aurait
même plus entrer dans l'eau cs ou dans
les associations parce qu'ils en sont en
état de détresse absolue et cela je
pense qu'on voulait aussi concernés
la parole est au président françois noël
buffet pour le groupe les république à
monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur le 18 octobre
dernier le conseil de défense a annoncé
que deux cent trente et une personnes
étrangères en situation irrégulière est
soupçonné de radicalisation serait
reconduite dans leur pays d'origine
au delà du cas particulier se pose la
question de l'efficacité de notre
système en matière de retour dans les
pays d'origine des personnes en civil
étrangères en situation irrégulière sur
notre territoire en 2019 plus de 122 me
l'obligation de quitter le territoire
national ont été prononcées moins de
15000 ont été exécutés en 2018
dans cet hémicycle le sénat a voté une
disposition assez simple qui
consisterait pour obtenir des laissez
passer consulaires des pays sources de
conditionner les villes obtention de
visas au fait que les pays acceptent de
recevoir leurs ressortissants étrangers
sur leur territoire dès lors qu'ils sont
en france en situation irrégulière quand
tu des circonstances mais au delà de
celle ci même monsieur le ministre
pourriez-vous reprendre à votre charge
cette proposition du sénat qui
malheureusement avait fait l'objet d'un
refus du gouvernement à l'époque et d'un
désaccord de l'assemblée nationale à
l'époque dont vous répondre la parole et
au ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
darmana vous avez la parole
ce président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur vous avez
raison les étrangers en situation
irrégulière qui sont définitivement
après des décisions de justice dans ce
qu'ils ont fait recours parce que nous
sommes un état de droit et qu'ils ont
eue docu tf une obligation de quitter le
territoire national de retourner dans
leur pays
c'est une évidence et nous devons
appliquer le droit
si je ressors de la période du coc vide
puisque assemble le problème notamment
le fait qu'il n'y ait pas pendant
plusieurs mois des espaces aériens
ouverts notamment avec les pays de ce
qui arrivait je voulais que c'est quand
même un sujet sur lequel
l'administration veut peut être en
difficulté
il ya la question des laissez passer
consulaires la reconnaissance que ces
citoyens sont bien des citoyens des pays
qui viennent sur le territoire national
je suis prêt à étudier toutes les
dispositions qui conformément au droit
permettent le retour dans des bonnes
conditions de ces étrangers en situation
irrégulière j'aimerais cependant pas que
votre démonstration démontrent que ce
gouvernement serait laxiste et que
lorsque des responsabilités vous étiez
très courageux puisque dans la moyenne
des cinq entre 2007 et 2012
vous étiez à 12 millions par an
reconduite à la frontière et que le
gouvernement du président de la
république propriétaires locaux vides et
en est à 18 milles vous aurez constaté
2002 différence il devrait pas qu'ils
aient de liens non plus entre étrangers
et personnes radicaliser ce qu'il
faudrait monsieur le président c'est
être fermes sont nos principes sur la
liberté d'expression
quand j'entends de prison votre groupe
ce matin sur rtl dire je cite monsieur
retailleau qui donne des leçons de
fermeté à tout bout de champ oui à la
caricature mais avec une forme de
respect et ben non monsieur le président
retailleau la liberté d'expression elle
est totale même quand ça gêne elle
concerne toutes les religions et c'est
avec ce genre de format monsieur ciotti
vous a d'ailleurs corrigé
monsieur abad vous à corriger et oui
vous devriez retirer vos propos parce
que je crois monsieur prison retailleau
que ce avec des propos comme ceux ci qu
on encourage pas le président de la
république et leur nom être ferme comme
nous le sommes depuis ce matin
monsieur le monsieur le président buffet
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre je n'ignore pas que la période
de 2020 compte tenu de la situation
sanitaire peut poser des difficultés
je ne conteste pas d'ailleurs les
chiffres que je vous donnais son site de
2019 en revanche au delà de la situation
particulière je trouve qu'il serait
utile
naturellement une fois les voies de
droit épuisé et que la situation
irrégulière de l'étranger soit
définitive que l'on puisse travailler à
ce sujet car si naughton n'optant pas
obtenu si nous n'obtenons pas pardon
excusez moi de laisser passer consulaire
dans de bonnes conditions et de la part
des pays sources
nous n'y arriverons jamais et
malheureusement le conditionnement en
tous les cas le fait de dire que nous ne
donnerons pas de visa si nous n'avons
pas cessé passer consulaires peut-être
un moyen discussions vraiment le sénat
s'y était engagé je souhaite que nous
puissions continuer là-dessus très bien
la parole est à notre collègue philippe
folliot pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
madame la ministre de la défense depuis
quelques mois la multiplication de
comportements inamicaux voire agressif
de la turquie envers ses alliés de
l'otan en général et de la france en
particulier pose un grave problème
l'incident avec la frégate courbet au
mépris des règles de l'alliance
les explorations sauvage en méditerranée
orientale au mépris du droit de la mer
la livraison d'armes à la libye
au mépris de l'embargo décidé par l'onu
l'intervention haut karabagh au mépris
des équilibres régionaux et pour finir
les insultes contre le président
maquereau au mépris des usages
diplomatiques les plus élémentaires
tout cela fait beaucoup tout cela fait
trop le peuple turc ne serait être
assimilés aux outrances d'un président
confronté à une contestation populaire
majeur avec des récentes lourde défaite
électorale qui avec l'énergie du
désespoir agite un islamisme
conservateur et agressif un des symboles
en est le sabordage de l'héritage du
moderniste et visionnaire mustafa kemal
dit atatürk notamment au travers de la
transformation de sainte-sophie de musée
en mosquée nous avons régulièrement
abordé ces questions et c'est différent
au sein de l'assemblée parlementaire de
l'otan en relevant notamment que le
président tueur ne se comporte pas comme
un allié respectueux de nombre de
principes démocratiques et en ignorant
les articles fondateur 4 et 5 du traité
de l'alliance quelle réponse apporter
vous au décalage entre les actes du
président populiste
erdogan et les obligations qui lui
incombent en tant qu'alliée de la france
au sein de l'otan
madame la ministre selon vous la turquie
peut-elle et doit-elle rester dans
l'otan
pour vous répondre la parole et cabinet
le ministre désormais à des influences
carli merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur la turquie a adhéré
à l'otan en 1952 et elle lui a apporté
pendant de nombreuses années sa
contribution à la sécurité euro
atlantique alors comme avec d'autres
alliés nous avons pu avoir des
différends mais jusqu'à présent c'est
vrai que c'est différent n'avait jamais
porté atteinte à la cohésion de
l'alliance et on peut même dire que le
fait que la grèce et la turquie
appartiennent à la même alliance a pu
contribuer à apaiser certaines tensions
entre ces deux pays
mais depuis quelques mois nous assistons
à une situation tout à fait inédite où
la turquie pratiquer la politique du
fait accompli ou elle adopte une
attitude décomplexée et ceci vous
l'avais dit au mépris de bon nombre des
intérêts de sécurité de ses alliés et au
risque de l'escaladé
je ne reprends pas tous les exemples en
méditerranée orientale et plus récemment
avec l'envoi de mercenaires dans le haut
karabakh
alors cette attitude se doublent par
ailleurs des outrances verbales de ses
dirigeants qui sont parfaitement
inadmissible et qui ont conduit le
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères a rappelé l'ambassadeur de
france en turquie pour consultations
alors ce constat que je dresse c'est en
fait celui d'un allié qui ne se comporte
pas en alliés et face à cette situation
il n'y a qu'une seule attitude possible
c'est celle de rappeler à la turquie les
obligations qui s'imposent taele en tant
qu'allié alors c'est ce que j'ai fait en
juin lors des incidents avec l'un autre
frégate courbet c'est ce que j'ai refait
la semaine dernière devant mes collègues
de l'otan puisque nous avions une
réunion me des ministres de la défense
en rappelant que la france serait
intraitable face à toute violation du
droit international comme elle le serait
face à la remise en cause a cédé l'été
européenne et vous monsieur clément
bonne la relever bon nombre de pays
européens mais pas seulement aussi les
etats-unis ont condamné de façon
publique les agissements nature qui
alors pour terminer je dirai qu'au delà
de ces dénonciations du comportement
tueur il faut agir et c'est ce que nous
faisons notamment dans le cadre de
l'opération
irini où nous faisons preuve d'une
posture à la fois vigilante et de
fermeté la parole est maintenant de leur
collègue françoise dumont pour le groupe
l'est républicain vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance la fermeture
partielle ou totale des cafés débits de
boissons des restaurants ou encore des
hôtels par manque de clients est une
mesure qui concerne de plus en plus de
territoire aujourd'hui l'explosion du
nombre de contaminations de ces derniers
jours nous permet de douter de
l'efficacité de ces mesures
et en dépit des protocoles sanitaires la
question dure confinement refait surface
lors de la première vague le
gouvernement s'est montré assez réactif
sur la prise des mesures compensatoires
à l'arrêt d'activité des établissements
recevant du public tels que nos hôtels
ou encore les bars et restaurants
néanmoins le 2 le défi aujourd'hui est
tout autre alors que nous entrons dans
une seconde vague sans doute plus
violente et plus longue
les professionnels du tourisme peuvent
se satisfaire de 2002 mesures
compensatoires et doivent se voir
proposer un vrai horizons le
gouvernement a présenté un plan france
relance qui prétend faire la france de
demain faire la france de demain c'est
s'appuyer sur ses forces et notamment
sur ces territoires
le tourisme en fait partie les
professionnels de ce secteur offrent des
emplois durables non délocalisables ce
sont également des savoir-faire que le
monde entier nous envie
il faut penser à demain un jour nous
vaincrons le virus et en attendant nous
devons préserver la filière du tourisme
et de l'hôtellerie restauration aussi et
avant les nouvelles annonces de ce soir
pourriez vous nous préciser ce que le
gouvernement prévoit pour permettre à
ces métiers qui met en valeur nos terry
ouah de s'adapter concrètement aux
mesures imposées par la situation sin
finances sanitaire pardon également
comme vous le savez déjà et avant la
crise sanitaire
la filière hôtellerie-restauration
peinait à recruter pour connor pourquoi
ne pas faire de cette période troublée
une opportunité pour favoriser la
formation de nos jeunes à ces nombreux
métiers par des dispositifs innovants de
formation à distance ou en présentiel
dans les établissements hôteliers et de
restauration désormais fermée au public
nous nous devons monsieur le ministre
d'anticiper l'avenir pour préserver
cette filière particulièrement touchée
au complot la parole est aux secrétaires
d'état chargés de transition libérer des
communications électroniques monsieur
cédric haut pour vous répondre
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice du monde
voudrait effectivement excusé l'absence
de monsieur bruno le maire qui est
retenue par les dernières consultations
préalables aux annonces de 7 ce soir du
président de la république précisément
avec les secteurs je crois que vous
évoquez ou non le maire à ce titre a eu
l'occasion de le rappeler
lundi dernier à l'assemblée nationale ce
que nous cherchons à faire notre
objectif c'est bien de conjuguer la
lutte contre l'épidémie
avec le maintien de l'activité et la
protection économique
dans une situation sanitaire olivier
ferrand et le premier ministre ont
rappelé tout à l'heure qui est
extrêmement inquiétante et notre
première responsabilité est de freiner
le plus efficacement possible la
propagation du virus tout en permettant
à notre économie de près de produire
c'est pourquoi l'ensemble du ministère
de l'économie des finances et de la
relance est mobilisé pour soutenir les
secteurs les plus fragilisées à savoir
notamment ce secteur des cafés hôtels
restaurants et ceux qui en dépendent
rappelez peut-être ce qui a été fait
jusqu'ici
d'abord que le fonds de solidarité a été
simplifié renforcée et élargie pour
toutes les entreprises sans exception
toutes les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés installés dans les zones de
couvre-feu et subissant une perte de 50
% de leur chiffre d'affaires peuvent
avoir accès à une aide mensuelle allant
jusqu'à 1500 euros
j'ajoute par ailleurs que les
entreprises d'au moins 50 salariés de ce
secteur des chr
peuvent désormais bénéficier de l'aide
de 10000 euros si elles ont perdu 50%
sans condition de plafonnement de
chiffre d'affaires je rappelle que les
exonérations de charges ont été
massivement renforcé et que le chômage
partiel indemnisé à 100% pour ces
secteurs a été prolongé jusqu'à la fin
de l'année
je vous assure et madame la sénatrice
mais plus largement la chambre août que
les mesures d'urgence seront adaptés aux
dispositifs annoncés ce soir par le
président de la république à cet effet
monsieur le premier ministre détaillera
devant la chambre haute demain à 14h30
les mesures prises pour lutter contre la
propagation de la côte de la copie de 19
je crois que dans cette période nous
devons collectivement prendre nos
responsabilités nous devons protéger
sanitairement et économiquement et je
veux à ce titre vous réitérer notre
engagement nous ne laisserons aucune
entreprise sur le bord de la route vers
la reprise
je vous remercie merci la parole et
vatan à madame la présidente laurence
rossignol
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicaine avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vers ans depuis le 27 février
nous vous êtes vous nous vous
interrogeons sur l'adéquation des moyens
de santé publique à la maîtrise et la
prise en charge de l'épidémie
depuis le 27 février qu'il s'agisse des
questions au gouvernement de la
commission des affaires sociales de la
commission denquête vous nous répondez
nous sommes prêts
le 14 juillet le président de la
république disait nous sommes prêts pour
la deuxième vague permettrait
aujourd'hui en attendant ces annonces de
ce soir et la précipitation
la mise en scène qui est la dramaturgie
qui est fait depuis 48 heures dans la
presse de douté de cette affirmation du
14 juillet monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui les français sont très
inquiets leur inquiétude tient
l'épidémie mais il tient aussi à la
manière dont le gouvernement leur parle
parce que vous êtes habile monsieur vers
ans vous maîtrisez le verbe vous nous
parlez avec énergie et on a même souvent
un peu de d'empathie pour vous vous
faites un job qui est pas un job facile
mais cette habileté
elle est aussi fait beaucoup de semi
vérités semi vérités sur les tests semi
vérités sur la stratégie d'isolement
semi vérités sur les lits de réanimation
vous en annonces et 14000
je pense qu'il y en aura environ 7500
semi vérités sur les vaccins anti-grippe
vous avez répondu tout à l'heure un
collègue mais là encore on n'a pas bien
vu qu'elle était votre stratégie
alors monsieur le ministre les français
sont un peuple éclairé responsable et
mature
quand allez vous sortir de la posture
politique voire même politicienne pour
leur part les uns à hauteur de ce qu'ils
sont madame la sénatrice rossignol c'est
vous qui avez parlé de politique
politicienne
j'ai donc me permettre pour une fois de
vous répondre en politique politicienne
madame la sénatrice
mais c'est la triste qu'est ce que
j'aurais aimé que de votre questions
surgissent une idée une proposition
allait une orientation générale à
laquelle ni la france ni l'europe ni les
états unis n'aurait songé pour lutter
contre la pandémie la plus meurtrière de
notre histoire contemporaine
madame la sénatrice qu'est ce que
j'aurais aimé un mot pour les français
solidaires fort fort contre vents et
marées et qui attendent de leur classe
politique non pas qu'il fasse de cette
lutte contre l'épidémie je ne sais quel
marchepied vers je ne sais qu'à
l'élection à venir mais bien un grand
moment de capacité à faire preuve d'un
minimum d'unité nationale madame la
sénatrice qu'est ce que j'aurais aimé
que vous ayez l'honnêteté de rappeler
que semaine après semaine j'étais ici
dans cet hémicycle pour rappeler à la
représentation nationale que l'épidémie
n'était pas finie que nous avions pas
terrassé le virus et que nous devions
rester armée tout au long de l'année au
pouvoir lutter contre l'épidémie mais
non vous vous livrez par votre question
une nouvelle attaque en piqué une
nouvelle attaque en piqué madame la
sénatrice
on ne sauve pas des vies avec des
attaques politiques on ne soutient pas
les soignants avec des attaques
politiques
on n'encourage pas les français à tenir
bon dans cette période difficile avec
des attaques politiques avec une attaque
politique avec des attaques politiques
comme celles que vous faites avec la
polémique permanente que certains
essayent d'instaurer un moment où nous
avons besoin de solidarité et d'unité
nationale
je ne crois pas madame la sénatrice que
vous ayez participer et aider votre pays
dans la lutte contre l'épidémie en
soutien des français
madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre le sénat mon groupe
le groupe socialiste mais d'autres
groupes aussi vous ferons des
propositions nous on nous en avons déjà
fait nombreuses mais la manière dont
vous traitez nos propositions qu'il
s'agisse de l'examen des projets de loi
qu'il s'agisse de nos discussions plus
techniques de mise en oeuvre de la
politique sanitaire ne nous ne nous fera
pas renoncer à vous faire des
propositions mais permettez nous aussi
dire aux français que vous voyagez seul
vous pilotez sol et vous n'écoutez
jamais ni le parlement ni la société
civile dans la parole et notre collègue
sam hendricks l'air pour le groupe l'est
républicain la parole merci monsieur le
président alors ma question s'adresse au
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
monsieur le ministre le président du
conseil scientifique jean françois
delfraissy tiers depuis lundi la
sonnette d'alarmé
l'épidémie de lakovic 19 est incontrôlée
et la situation de nos hôpitaux devient
très périlleuse certains services de
réanimation sont d'ores et déjà saturé
l'épidémie flambent et des français
meurent votre devoir monsieur le
ministre est non seulement de protéger à
tout prix les français
mais c'est aussi et avant tout
d'anticiper le conseil scientifique
avait prévu dès juillet qu'il y aurait
une deuxième vague
aujourd'hui cette vague déferle
incontrôlée et les français ont le
sentiment que rien n'a été anticipé
depuis la fin du confinement
les français notamment ont le sentiment
que rien n'a changé à l'hôpital par
rapport au printemps
il est vrai que l'organisation
hospitalière aurait mérité que soit
élaboré un plan d'anticipation pendant
l'été afin de pouvoir augmenter
rapidement le nombre de soignants et
permettre l'ouverture d'un plus grand
nombre de lits de réanimation
alors monsieur le ministre plutôt que de
dévaloriser certaines professions
paramédicales en donnant des
autorisations temporaires d'exercice à
des personnes qui n'ont pas d'expérience
pourquoi ne pas s'autoriser à surclasser
via un temps de formation et pour
quelques tâches limiter les aides
soignants et les infirmiers comme l'a
suggéré le professeur philippe juvin
chef du service des urgences de
l'hôpital georges pompidou à paris pour
vous répondre la parole et communes de
solidarité pour le coup madame la
sénatrice dreclerc vous avez
parfaitement raison il faut anticiper
être capable de former davantage de
personnel soignant est d'ailleurs dans
votre question vous n'avez pas suggérer
comme j'ai pu l'entendre ça et là que
nous aurions pu former davantage
d'anesthésistes pendant l'été f puisque
chacun sait qu'il faut disant néanmoins
madame la sénatrice
quand j vous avez raison c'est que non
seulement je considère que vous avez
raison mais je considère que c'est ce
que nous avons fait et nous c'est pas le
gouvernement essaie pas vous les
sénateurs c'est l'ensemble c'est les
régions ce sont les hôpitaux ce sont les
facultés qui se sont organisés je vais
vous donner quelques exemples
d'abord nous avons supprimé le concours
d'entrée dans les études
d'aide-soignante dans notre pays nous
l'avions fait avant la crise sanitaire
aucun regret de l'avoir fait les régions
augmenter le nombre de places de
formation plus de 1000 places cette
année de formation pour les infirmières
plus de 1000 augmentation de place pour
les aides soignants alors ça prend du
temps pour former des aides-soignants et
des infirmières vous l'avez dit
vous-même dans votre question mais nous
sommes dans l'anticipation en prévoyant
que nous aurons peut-être besoin dans un
an ou deux de milliers de soignants plus
sur certains territoires oui madame la
sénatrice nous recrutons des faisant
fonction des soignants des agents de
soins qui ont des missions qui sont
moins qualifiés
c'est pas déshonorant je les fais je les
fais pendant près de trois ans quand
j'étais jeune étudiant et j'ai été aide
soignant jusque je suis monté jusqu'au
niveau d'être soignants en ehpad
j'ai effectué des missions alors j'en
avais pas la qualification et je crois
avoir fait mon travail avec soin et
conviction et attention pour les
personnes dont je m'occupais par
ailleurs madame la sénatrice nous
voulons faire revenir à l'hôpital des
personnes qui ont quitté l'hôpital ou
revenir en ehpad
vous serez amené à voter la semaine
prochaine le plfss lui milliards d'euros
d'augmentation pour les soignants
non-médicaux plus de 200 euros
d'augmentation nets par mois pour les
aides soignants ça c'est un outil
d'attractivité madame la sénatrice je
pense que vous en convient
avec moi nous augmentons toutes les
capacités de formation de tous les
instituts de formation de france et nous
mobilisons partout nous pouvons deux
exemples rapidement en nouvelles
aquitaine pôle emploi reçoit
actuellement en entretien trois cents
personnes qui sont inscrites à pôle
emploi qui sont aide soignante pour les
inciter à rester un peu davantage dans
leurs branches professionnelles
un autre exemple dans le finistère un
dispositif de recrutement dead à
domicile pour des personnes licenciées
du secteur de l'agroalimentaire a été
mis en place
etc etc des initiatives comme celle là
elle nous permet de renforcer les rangs
des soignants de plusieurs milliers de
plusieurs milliers de blouses blanches
dont nous avons besoin et je voulais à
travers votre question il ma réponse les
remercier pour leur engagement très
clair vous avez quelques secondes non je
devais apparent la collègue stéphane
sautarel pour le groupe l'est
républicain avait la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture et
l'alimentation
monsieur le ministre je vais aborder un
sujet qui aurait été au coeur de
l'actualité si les crises sanitaires
sécuritaires économiques et sociales
n'occupaient pas et à juste titre tous
les esprits avec un budget de 380 7
milliards d'euros sur sept ans la pac 21
27 et je m'en réjouis le premier budget
européen même s'il est en recul
le 21 octobre au matin un accord a été
trouvé après deux ans de négociations
entre états membres de l'union
européenne
quels en sont les enjeux d'abord l'enjeu
du maintien voire du renforcement d'un
tissu d'agriculteurs mayer notre pays
vivent de leur production assurant le
socle de notre réalité est en fait de
notre pays
ensuite l'enjeu de la souveraineté
alimentaire de la france et d'une
alimentation saine
enfin l'enjeu de notre réponse aux
évolutions climatiques et
environnementales à la préservation du
vivant
l'accompagnement des mutations à opérer
pour s'engager dans une agriculture plus
durable plus raisonnée est essentielle
il ne doit ni pénaliser ceux qui sont
déjà engagés sur ce chemin bien au
contraire
ni ce qu'ils amorcent cette
transformation qu'il faut encourager et
protéger sans jamais oublier bien sûr
l'objectif premier de l'indépendance
alimentaire
je pense en particulier aux zones de
montagne où les efforts déjà accomplis
seront je l'espère vous connu
avec cette nouvelle pac et les 62
milliards d'euros que la france touchera
nous engageons dans un véritable
changement de paradigme avec
l'obligation de pratiques agronomiques
exigeantes comme socle du futur régime
dead et l'ajout déco régimes nationaux
pour ceux qui iront au delà des minima
logo légaux exigible il apparaît donc
essentiel de poursuivre la recherche
d'un double équilibre celui de la
cohérence européenne et celui de la
reconnaissance de la diversité et de la
richesse agricole de la france au titre
du psn monsieur le ministre
quelle garantie avons nous de ne pas
aboutir à 27 politiques agricoles
nationales divergentes mais au contraire
d'aller vers un encours avoir une
convergence des normes
cette différenciation territoriale telle
différenciation territoriale intégrera
le futur plan stratégique national et
enfin quid du cofinancement de l'état
au-delà des aides superficiaires au
titre des politiques régionales
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est obligée de l'agriculture
d'alimentation aux ministres si beaucoup
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur sautarel vous évoquez
effectivement un sujet ô combien
important pour tous nos territoires
vous le savez j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer à plusieurs reprises dessus
moi j'ai un et un seul objectif pour
notre agriculture c'est la question de
la souveraineté
nous devons regagner en souveraineté
agroalimentaire dans notre pays et là où
je suis satisfait de l'accord de la
politique agricole commune obtenue il ya
quelques jours c'est que cette politique
elle va nous permettre de regagner en
souveraineté et ça n'était pas une mince
affaire
la première question et vous l'avez
évoqué c'est que contrairement à ce que
certains pourraient imaginer
il n'est pas possible de faire de
l'agriculture sans agriculteurs dans le
beau territoire du cantal qui est le
vôtre il n'est pas possible de faire de
l'élevage sans les éleveurs et pour cela
il ya la question du revenu et vous
l'avez dit monsieur le sénateur grâce à
l'implication en particulier du
président de la république
le budget de la politique agricole
commune a été préservé et de combien
nous avons atterri à 386 milliards
d'euros là où la proposition de la
commission initial
était de 365 milliards d'euros 20
milliards d'euros de moins et puis le
deuxième défi monsieur le sénateur vous
l'avez aussi ce qu'il sait c'est la
question oui il faut une pac ambitieuse
dans les mesures environnementales
mais cette ambition environnementale
elle n'est possible que si elle est
obligatoire pour tous les états membres
parce qu'on ne peut pas accepter d'avoir
sur nos étals un concombre français est
un con compte d'un autre pays européen
qui ne répondent pas aux mêmes normes
environnementales et pour la première
fois cette politique agricole commune a
permis au titre de ces éco schéma 20 à
30% du paiement direct soit
conditionnelle des mesures
environnementales
mais le soin le soin de manière
obligatoire à tous les états membres
et ça nous l'avons obtenu et ça c'est
une très grande avancée pour nos
agriculteurs
enfin je terminerai en posant juste une
question qui quels secteurs d'activité
aujourd'hui dans notre pays en sept ans
verra 20 à 30% de son activité
conditionnelle des mesures
environnementales et ben c'est
l'agriculteur l'agriculture
soyons en fiers dit le disons cela
montrons cela et portant haut les
couleurs de cet agriculteur qui forgent
nos territoires et que vous représentez
tous les jours toujours merci merci
monsieur le ministre
ouais saluer nos collègues présents
qu'ils accusent d'être présent dans les
tribunes qui démontre que malgré les
restrictions l'engagement et le suivi
par nos collègues et est important tout
au long de ces questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres merci de votre
présence
nos prochaines questions d'actualité
auront lieu le mercredi 4 novembre à 15
heures la séance est suspendue elle sera
reprise à 16h30 pour l'examen du projet
de loi de programmation de la recherche
pour les années 2000 21 à 2003
la séance est donc suspendu
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement au sénat que
vous avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur notre antenne avec une
douzaine de questions consacré
directement ou indirectement à la crise
du comité 19 on retiendra plusieurs
passes d'armes comme entre les miss de
la santé et bernard jomier ou laurence
rossignol ou encore entre le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin avec le
président du groupe a l'air au sénat est
d'ailleurs alex poussard est bien le
président du groupe et les airs au sénat
il est à notre micro en ce moment même
bruno retailleau
effectivement je suis avec bruno
retailleau le président du groupe l'est
républicain voilà qui arrive à mon micro
bruno retailleau durant cette séance de
questions d'actualité le ministre de
l'intérieur vous a interpellé en vous
demandant de retirer vos propos d'hier
soir sur le droit de caricaturer je vais
préciser le contexte hier soir chez nos
confrères d'rtl une question est porté
sur le droit de caricaturer vous avez
dit oui au droit de caricaturer mais
avec je cite une certaine forme de
respect il faut être aussi prudent et
faire attention à la généralisation est
ce que vous allez retirer vos propos
vous propos comme la demande et gérald
darmanin
non mais il n'en n'est absolument pas
question hier soir et il ya eu un tweet
qui raccourcit mes propos mais quand on
écoute la séquence
les choses sont absolument claires et je
veux dire aux français qu'il y en a
marre que monsieur darmanin dès lors qu'
il se sent mise en question puisque là
il était gêné aux entournures sur la
réponse à une question
attac l'opposition ce que je veux dire
c'est que hier monsieur darmana nous
attaquer pour islamophobie est
aujourd'hui m'attaquerai mois pour un
peu trop de complaisance vis-à-vis de
l'islamisme c'est lui monsieur darmanin
qui il ya quelques années avait proposé
un concordat avec l'islam c'est à dire
c'est à dire un coup de canif un sérieux
coup de canif à la loi de séparation de
1905 c'est lui c'est par son inaction
qu'il tente de cacher finalement qu' il
en vient à attaquer ses adversaires
politiques c'est indigne
il a même proféré un mensonge je viens
d'avoir damien abad
qui est le président du groupe à
l'assemblée nationale monsieur bart
maddens a dit devant les sénateurs que
monsieur à batum avait taclé c'est
absolument faux c'est un mensonge
il faut que les français sachent qui est
monsieur darmanin je tiens à le dire et
c'est moi qui ai proposé l'interdiction
du voile pendant les sorties scolaires
des listes communautariste c'est nous
avec l'élite bas qui ont proposé la
modification de la constitution pour que
la laïcité soit reconnue dès l'article 2
de notre norme suprême
donc ça suffit assez de mensonges ce que
les français demandent ça n'est pas de
mettre en cause d'opposition ce que les
français demandent ce sont des actes et
nous jugerons le gouvernement et
monsieur darmanin aux actes et non pas à
ces déclarations qui sont mensongères
parfois alors votre réponse est claire
voudrait qu'on évoque une autre
actualité
l'allocution du président de la
république ce soir qui pourrait annoncer
un nouveau confinement est ce que cela
signifie à l'échec de la stratégie
sanitaire du gouvernement
écoutez il ya eu au moment du
confinement un échec pourquoi parce
qu'on a mis la france où cloche et on
n'a pas cassé les reins de l'épidémie on
n'a pas suffisamment d'abord courrier
aux masses qui en avait pas mais le
dépistage on est oubliés on n'a pas fait
le traçage l'isolément des personnes
ensuite on a des confiné il ya eu le
problème du dépistage puisque les
résultats des tests venait des jours
après ça ne servait à rien de tester en
nombre et puis un couvre-feu qui est
venu trop tard le problème est ce que je
demande au président de république c'est
bien sûr sans doute des mesures mais
surtout une stratégie
la seule stratégie doit consister 1 en
augmentant le nombre de lits de
réanimation nous avons fait des
propositions notamment en mettant dans
le coup les cliniques privées mais aussi
en forme en plus vite le personnel et de
la casser la chaîne de contamination en
dépistant les tests antigénique
notamment avec les ehpad en traçant
beaucoup plus voilà et puis en isolant
les personnes qui sont contaminées et
qu'ils n'ont pas chez eux de surface
suffisamment grande pour s'isoler du
reste de leurs proches
est ce que demain après midi le groupe
l'est républicain du sénat votera la
confiance après le discours du premier
ministre jean castex était pour
l'instant en tout cas les français ne
leur font pas confiance bien mais je
réunirai mon groupe demain matin pour en
discuter
merci beaucoup pour votre réaction bruno
retailleau
merci beaucoup alexandre et une autre
réaction à votre micro vous être
rejoints à l'instant par un autre
président de groupe le président du
groupe socialiste au sénat il s'agit de
patrick kanner c'est avoue alexandre oui
avec patrick kanner le président des
sénateurs socialistes on est entendu
olivier véran durant cette séance de
questions d'actualité qui est dénoncée à
les leçons données par certains
sénateurs est la polémique permanente
également dans l'hémicycle du sénat
notamment en visant laurence rossignol
qu'est ce que vous répondez aux mises de
la santé très simplement qu'il faut
garder son sang froid
aujourd'hui le déconfinement est
malheureusement un échec il faut le
constater
et encore une fois sans polémique il
faut essayer de chercher les raisons de
cet échec qui va impacter 67 millions de
français dès demain soir probablement
donc dans ce cadre là ce que je dis est
monsieur vers ans et que bien sûr il
n'est pas le seul responsable ou non
n'est pas le seul responsable c'est un
échec collectif mais néanmoins il est
membre du gouvernement et le
gouvernement doit gouverner et donc doit
assumer ses décisions et des décisions
n'ont pas été prises au bon moment et je
pense que notamment depuis le 11 mai
beaucoup de mesures auraient pu être
prises y compris sur le plan social pour
accompagner les français mais on a
l'impression que le miz de la santé
finalement refus cette responsabilité de
l'arrivée de la deuxième vague il dit
c'est un phénomène européen qui tish qui
touche tous les pays même les bonnes et
les bons élèves madame rossignol a eu
raison de rappeler que le 14 juillet
présent d'un public avait dit mais nous
serons prêts en cas de deuxième vague
manifestement on ne l'est pas et cette
comparaison avec les autres pays
européens
me schott pas mal je vais vous le dire
pourquoi parce que ceux d'hier mais
finalement quand on se regarde quand on
se compare on peut se consoler mais moi
ce que je demande c'est que mon pays
soit meilleur que les autres pays
européens et donc qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
marché c'est nous qui amène à ce que
nous soyons obligés de nous re confiné
dès demain soir probablement est-ce que
vous allez voter la confiance après le
discours du premier ministre
jean castex demain après midi vous me
posez une question d'alchimiste parce
que finalement vous savez ce qu'ils
paient maintenant ce discours je ne le
sais pas on espérait qu'il nous
donnerait des éléments hier soir dans la
grande réunion avenue de ségur ça n'a
pas été le cas
nous sommes restés sur notre faim et mon
objectif c'est bien sûr d'abord
d'écouter ce soir le présent
public et curieusement d'avoir ce débat
50-1 après alors que ni moi n'avions eu
avant nous aurions pu avoir des
explications de la prod point ministre
donc on nous prend en otage et je ne
veux pas que le parlement sur la voiture
balai du gouvernement aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup patrick kanner d'avoir
répondu à mes questions elle et on
enchaîne encore les réactions salle des
conférences
alexandre puisque vous allez être
maintenant rejoint par marc fesneau
marc fesneau qui est donc le ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
et ça va être aussi bien l'occasion de
parler de cette actualité parlementaire
très riche pour demain où vous l'avez
dit il va y avoir et bien deux d'abord
une déclaration de jean castex puis le
projet de loi urgence qui va être
débattu alors qu' il y en a ri avec
cette deuxième vague mais oui on arrive
avec cette deuxième vague marc fesneau
est ce que le gouvernement a une part de
responsabilité dans l'arrivée de cette
deuxième vague coûté faut regarder ce
qui se passe au travers le monde et de
la question n'est pas de chercher des
responsabilités la question c'est de
chercher ça la responsabilité celle
étant d'après nous on vit une vague que
tous les pays d'europe vivent que tous
les pays du monde vide alors moi je veux
bien ceux qui commentent qui sont assis
au bord sur leurs fauteuils qui disent
voilà les responsables qui désigne déjà
à la vindicte
nous on est en situation de
responsabilité et paddy responsabilités
donc nous notre travail c'est de faire
face à cette deuxième vague qui n'est
pas un un élément propre à la france il
suffit de regarder les courbes de
l'ensemble de l'europe et de l'ensemble
du monde donc nous comme nous sommes des
responsables publics nous sommes là pour
répondre à la crise et faire face à ces
crises sanitaires qui remonte de façon
vertigineuse plus rapidement que la même
les experts les plus pessimistes avaient
annoncé et donc on est face à cette
difficulté là et donc le président de la
république s'exprimera ce soir mais je
trouve que dans le moment convient je
cherche je veux pas sauter sur le mon
fauteuil comme un cabri comme disait
général de vote pour dire unité unité
unité au moment où il traverse un moment
très difficile dans le monde en europe
et en france que cherche un peu certains
continuent à chercher des responsables
ou à jeter à la vindicte je pense que
c'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est de
faire face collectivement parce que je
pense qu'on a besoin des sénateurs on a
besoin des députés on a besoin des
collectivités locales on a besoin
évidemment des soignants et de ce site
sont
pourtant ils vont être mobilisés dans
les semaines qui viennent et on a besoin
de tous les français parce qu'au fond
pour s'en sortir on a besoin les uns les
autres d'être ensemble on peut être en
désaccord c'est pas la question d'unité
pour l'unité on a besoin d'être ensemble
parce que c'est ensemble qu'on s'en
sortira ou séparés qu'on ne s'en sortira
pas est ce que le gouvernement a besoin
du parlement pour piloter cette crise
notamment dans l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
ces prochains mois les sénateurs
craignent d'être encore une fois mis de
côté comme ça avait été le cas selon eux
pendant la crise du printemps dernier
oui enfin il me semble que le travail
qu'on a fait avec le sénat comme avec
l'assemblée nationale dans des
conditions sanitaires je me souviens
parce que j'avais été la navette du
premier tech sur l'état d'urgence
sanitaire aux bancs à l'assemblée au
sénat
il y avait très peu de sénateur il y
avait très peu de députés dans une dans
chacune des chambres et au fond on a
quand même fait le travail est au fond
la démocratie n'a jamais été mise entre
parenthèses évidemment ça crée des
contraintes y compris des contraintes
sanitaires et des contraintes de travail
évidemment on est obligé de travailler
dans l'urgence ce n'est pas satisfaisant
ni pour le parlement ni pour le
gouvernement mais l'urgence existe des
temps exige que nous travaillons dans ce
temps là et je reconnais volontiers que
c'est difficile pour les uns pour les
autres mais le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale ont toute leur place pour
contrôler et miruna de contrôle et nous
en parlions tout à l'heure en conférence
des présidents je trouve que le
président larcher avait raison pour
aussi proposé pour proposer au
gouvernement et je pense que dans un
esprit de construction on peut y arriver
à essayer de trouver des voies et
chemins parce qu'on voit bien que le
défi qui est devant nous est un défi
immense le défi épidémique
et puis le défi social et économique qui
vient et qui étaient déjà là et vous
écouterez les propositions des
parlementaires mettent en situation
alors on peut ne pas être d'accord
écoutez c'est pas tout prendre écoutez
c'est débattre écoutez c'est prendre
parfois tenir compte parfois et qui
parfois ne pas être d'accord mais
parfois aussi c'est prendre des
propositions donc en tout cas c'est la
disposition est la mienne et celle à
disposition du gouvernement
merci beaucoup marché nous d'avoir
répondu à mes questions merci beaucoup
alexandre pour cette nouvelle réaction
va commencer le débrief de cette
question d'actualité au gouvernement
notamment largement consacré à la copie
d'un seul à quelques heures avant les
annonces des manuels macron ce soir à
20h sur ce plateau jean pierre sueur
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateur
socialiste du loiret avec nous également
philippe dallier des jeunes sénateurs
les républicains de la seine saint denis
jean pierre sueur votre réaction tout
d'abord à ce que dit marc fesneau qui
dit non la démocratie n'a jamais été
mise entre parenthèses mais lui
jean se détend et bien nous oblige à
travailler comme nous le faisons
actuellement avec le parlement même si
c'est compliqué lui explique tout ça par
l'urgence écoutez je crois d'abord qu'il
faut faire preuve de responsabilité du
gouvernement on le voit au niveau
européen doit prendre des décisions
difficiles dans un contexte difficile
cela étant dit je suis quand même frappé
par l'indécision par les retours en
arrière par les imprécisions qui
émaillent les dernières semaines très
franchement on n'a pas l'impression que
le cap soit clair et très franchement
aussi j'ai été choqué d'apprendre qui
hier monsieur le premier ministre a
réuni les responsables de tous les
partis politiques de tous les groupes
parlementaires et ne leur a dit rien
vraiment rien donc il y a quand même
quelque chose qui ne va pas tout le
monde attend oui ce qui va arriver à 20h
ce soir mais je peux vous dire que pour
ce qui est du dialogue avec le parlement
et sénat
je crois qu'il ya une grande efficience
je vais vous faire réagir dans un
instant philippe dallier mais on va
aller à nouveau rejoindre une dernière
fois alexandre poussin salle des
conférences car vous êtes avec nadia est
ministre délégué chargé de la ville sept
avoue alexandre oui à nadia el président
de la république pourrait annoncer un
nouveau confinement ce soir en tout cas
un nouveau tour de vis sanitaire avec
des conséquences sociales notamment sur
les plus démunis sur les quartiers
populaires comment on protège cette
population dans une période
exceptionnelle
et bien tout d'abord je tiens à rappeler
que les décisions qui vont être prises
ce soir par président de la république
aujourd'hui elles sont inconnues encore
tout ce que nous savons aujourd'hui
c'est que la crise sanitaire s'aggrave
et que nous sommes dans un contexte qui
nécessite de prendre des mesures qui
soient beaucoup plus contraignante
maintenant la question c'est comment on
accompagne les habitants de nos
quartiers nous le faisons depuis déjà
plusieurs mois
et nous avons vu nous avons vécu un 1er
confinement au printemps nous avons tous
vu ces files d'attentes sur de l'aide
alimentaire nous avons vu aussi des
habitants qui vit qui ont vécu le
confinement mais de manière exemplaire
parce que contrairement à ce qui peut
être dit a pu être dit elles ont
respecté les mesures de confinement dans
l'ensemble donc aujourd'hui sans
présager évidemment des décisions qui
vont être prises ce soir par un
président de la république
ce que je veux dire c'est que les
habitants nous les accompagnons déjà
depuis plusieurs mois et j'ai décidé à
la fin de l'été de prendre une décision
d'aller aider les associations de
proximité qui font justement ce soutien
du dernier kilomètre pour éviter tout ce
que nous avons vécu pendant le
confinement c'est à dire une fracture
numérique pour des enfants qui étaient
éloignés de la continuité éducative sur
cette aide alimentaire qui n'a pu être
acheminés faute de tissu associatif
associatif organisé et bien j'ai pris
des décisions en anticipation de ce qui
pouvait se produire par la suite et donc
ce quartier solidaire ces quartiers
solidaire abondent et donc de 20
millions d'euros qui est un fonds
d'urgence en soutien aux associations de
proximité pour qu'elles puissent faire
ce travail de du dernier kilomètre
soutenir les associations soutenir
également les entreprises dans ces
quartiers comment on fait pour les
accompagner dans cette période difficile
et bien le gouvernement a pris des
décisions déjà il ya plusieurs mois pour
venir en soutien de l'activité
économique et de l'accompagnement de nos
entreprises à travers le fond de
solidarité à travers le prêt garanti par
l'état à travers la nationalisation des
salaires le chômage partiel n'est ni
plus ni moins qu'une nationalisation des
salaires est bien pour les habitants des
quartiers particulièrement pour les
entrepreneuses et les entrepreneurs qui
vivent une situation fragile et
fragilisés par le contexte sanitaire
économique que nous connaissons
j'ai annoncé une prime de 1500 euros qui
touchera cinq mille d'entre eux qui
viendra abonder la trésorerie qui
viendra les accompagner dans cette
période de turbulences sanitaires et
économiques que ça c'est en plus du fond
solide de solidarité par exemple
auxquelles ils ont accès cette prime
vient s'ajouter à l'ensemble des
décisions que nous avons prises pour
accompagner l'activité économique et la
préservation de nos emplois dernière
question nadia est ce que vous pensez
qu'un éventuel nouveau confinement va
être accepté dans les quartiers
populaires encore une fois je ne veux
pas anticiper sur les décisions qui vont
être prises ce soir par présidente de la
république tout ce que je veux dire
aujourd'hui à nos concitoyens c'est que
le gouvernement agit le gouvernement
prend des décisions en fonction du
contexte sanitaire que nous connaissons
et nous serons là à leurs côtés pour
assumer toute la responsabilité qui est
la nôtre aujourd'hui donc qu'ils soient
rassurés nous agissons sur le domaine
économique évidemment et on vient d'en
parler sur le domaine social nous
continuerons à les accompagner comme
nous l'avons toujours fait et sur le
contexte sanitaire là aussi les mesures
qui vont s'imposer à nous le sont mais
sur l'ensemble du territoire européen et
mondial parce que cette crise que nous
connaissons ne touchent pas
malheureusement que la france elle
touche tous les pays du monde et nous
agissons en conséquence
merci beaucoup navigué pour votre
réaction après cette séance de questions
d'actualité
merci à beaucoup alexandre philippe
dallier votre réaction à ce que vient de
dire nadia est un qui défend et bien la
politique qui a été menée dans les
quartiers je rappelle que vous l'êtes et
inat heures de la seine saint denis que
vous jugez que la politique du
gouvernement a été à la hauteur lors de
cette pandémie pour apporter l'aide
nécessaire et bien dans ces quartiers
difficiles en mai enfin dans ces
quartiers difficiles que dans ces
quartiers il ya une concentration de
populations en difficulté effectivement
ça c'est un simple constat
ceci étant dit des gens en difficulté
des gens dans la précarité il y en a
dans bien d'autres quartiers en france
et il ne s'agit pas de demander aux
gouvernements font ça que j'ai trouvé
que le propos de la ministre était un
peu peu ambigu banc les ministres de la
ville donc elle parle des quartiers mais
la politique qui doit être mise en
oeuvre
elle doit s'adresser à tous ceux qui
effectivement souffrent de cette crise
évidemment donc n'ayons pas l'air de
laisser croire comme c'était un peu le
cas qu'il y avait une politique
spécifique pour les publics en
difficulté dans ces quartiers maintenant
il ya une concentration des difficultés
mais les mesures que le gouvernement a
pris elle s'adresse
heureusement à tout ceci dans le plein
et c'est la même chose pour les
entreprises voilà ne faisons pas d'un
cas particulier de ces quartiers en
l'occurrence et sont allés à la hauteur
pour vous ces mesures rapport à
l'urgence sociale à laquelle on assiste
aujourd'hui plus un million de pauvres
avec la pandémie on a entendu dans lors
de ces questions d'actualité certains
réclament est effectivement d'autres
mesures beaucoup plus importants de
certains vont même très très loin il ya
aussi un élément qu'il faut avoir en
tête
et moi je vais quelque part le courage
de le poser sur la table aujourd'hui
c'est ce que coûte cette crise au pays
et ce qu'elle coûtera parce
qu'aujourd'hui
quoiqu'il en aujourd'hui nous n'en
sommes que malheureusement à la seconde
vague et on ne sait pas combien la
seconde vague d'écouté mais la première
elle a déjà coûté 300 milliards d'euros
à la france jusqu'au est-ce que nous
pouvons aller ça c'est une question que
les responsables politiques doivent se
poser même si ça n'est pas la première
le premier sujet qui vient à l'esprit
des français
mais il faut se rendre compte que lutter
contre cette crise et en nationalisant
les serres là je reprends l'expression
on a effectivement mis des sommes
considérables sur la table et de l'autre
côté pour soutenir les entreprises parce
que cette crise elle va s'aggraver de
manière dramatique si jamais on avait
effectivement un nombre de dépôts de
bilan astronomiques dans six mois dans
un an
donc il faut à la fois aider les plus en
difficulté et soutenir les entreprises
pour préserver à terme les emplois et le
potentiel de croissance de ce pays
alors on peut toujours dire qu'on n'en
fait jamais assez moi je dis qu'on a
déjà dépensé 300 milliards d'euros et
que nous ne sommes qu'au début de cette
crise
donc il ya un moment où les choses ne
tiendront plus ça il faut aussi d'avoir
entre les choses ne tient de remplacer
philippe dallier jean pierre sueur
urgence sociale
patrick kanner le présente votre groupe
a dit aussi que c'était une dimension
sur laquelle il attendait vraiment et
bien des annonces du gouvernement lors
de la déclaration de jean castex
je suis sensible à ce que des filets
parce que j'ai parfois l'impression que
nous dormons au dessus d'un volcan c'est
à dire que je parle avec des gens qui me
disent oh bah oui mais est-ce qu'on va
vraiment rembourser ses dettes mais
écoutez il n'y a pas de doute on va les
rembourser il va falloir les rembourser
mais je dirais raison de plus pour
mettre en oeuvre la justice voyez vous
depuis le début de cette crise
on nous dit voilà il ne faut pas de
prélèvement complémentaire jamais
règlement oui je dirais impôts et taxes
moi je dirais que quand on est dans une
situation où le nombre de bénéficiaires
de l'aide alimentaire a augmenté de 30%
il y à 1 millions de nouveaux pauvres
aujourd'hui il faut faire appel à la
solidarité nationale
et ça ne me choquerait pas bien voir une
augmentation d'impôt pour vous mais pour
les personnes utilisant les plus aisés
les mieux fortunés voyez l'histoire de
l'impôt sur la fortune
d'autres histoires de ce genre je crois
que dans une période aussi difficile il
ne faut pas hésiter à faire preuve de
solidarité nationale et c'est pourquoi
notre groupe a regretté que dans la loi
d'urgence sanitaire qui sera présenté ça
doit être la cinquième
eh bien il n'y ait que des mesures
sanitaires certes nécessaire mais aucune
mesure sociale
or l'urgence elle et elle va être
toujours davantage sanitaires et
sociales on en revient donc et bien un
petit peu au calendrier parlementaire un
qui est donc très bousculée avec la
pandémie bleus main philippe dallier il
va y avoir à la fois la déclaration de
jean castex suivie d'un débat et d'un
vote du sénat
et puis cette loi d'urgence sanitaire à
laquelle jean pierre sueur fait
référence à ce projet doit de
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
est ce que vous vous avez déjà une idée
de ce que vous allez
de ce que vous allez voter cette boutade
où nous allons a fait la même chose
attendre d'entendre le président de la
république ce soir à 20 heures puisque
tout est suspendu à la déclaration du
président de la république nous
entendrons le premier ministre demain et
nous prendrons notre décision dans la
foulée je vais pas vous dire a priori ce
que nous ferons sans avoir entendu et le
président de la république et le premier
ministre ensuite voilà maintenant il est
clair que si on parle de l'état d'esprit
dans lequel nous sommes bien évidemment
que le pays dans une situation
extrêmement difficile et il faut faire
preuve d'unité mais pour autant et c'est
bien le rôle des parlementaires et de
tous les parlementaires
on peut effectivement porter un certain
nombre de critiques sur les politiques
qui sont menées et force nous force nous
est de constater aujourd'hui que cette
pandémie s'est emballé
et pourtant dès le mois de septembre le
professeur delfraissy avait tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé et donc pourquoi
est-ce qu'on doit réduire et d'autres
médecins bien plus bien plus tôt encore
donc pourquoi est ce qu'on les a pas
écoutés fret ou alors je ne dis pas que
décidé il facile en cette période c'est
clair mais lorsque l'on est aux
commandes
comme nous l'a dit le président de la
république on doit effectivement écouter
être conseillés ensuite on décide
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas écouté le
professeur delfraissy au mois de
septembre ça c'est une vraie question
et aujourd'hui on vient nous annoncer
alors que le président a plus qu'à
parler il ya une dizaine de jours
là il va nous annoncer des mesures
beaucoup plus contraignante parce que la
machine s'est emballée est allé plus
sous contrôle
je veux parler de votre vote parce que
les positions du sénat des
parlementaires allemands d'être scrutés
et je voudrais qu'on aurait écoute tout
à l'heure et bien olivier veyrat olivier
ferrand qui lors des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement via lors
d'une de ses réponses a rappelé le fait
que le sénat avait voté la réouverture
des bars des restaurants
c'est un c'est un sujet qu'à être qui
est scruté propose d'écouter tout de
suite là l'intervention est bien du
ministre de la santé puis vous fait
ravir jusqu'après crois que l'une des
dernières interventions j'avais fait
monsieur le rapporteur bas s'en souvient
qu'il était d'accord avec moi c'était
pour demander aux sénateurs de droite et
de gauche d'avoir la responsabilité de
ne pas voter un amendement déposé par
tous les groupes de sénateurs visant à
empêcher le gouvernement de fermer des
établissements recevant du public et
autorisant donc de fait c'était il ya
quelques jours
la réouverture des discothèques à
marseille des restaurants à lyon des
bars à saint-etienne à telle enseigne qu
une deuxième délibération a été demandée
dans l'urgence par les sénateurs voyant
l'erreur qui a été commise donc s'il
vous plaît pas de ce taux rappelons
qu'il ya une deuxième délibération
s'annonce alors qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
exploite un incident de séance comme
evian nuit hier soir il ya un groupe qui
s'est trompé de vote
voilà sa réunion nicotine ça arrive
assez souvent mais ce qui est important
pour moi voyez vous eux c'est l'attitude
que nous allons avoir alors je vais
partager
l'attitude du groupe de mon collègue
philippe dallier
pour ce qui est du vote
suite à la déclaration de monsieur
castex nous avons une réunion de notre
groupe demain à midi où nous allons
établir notre position mais ce serait
quand même un peu irresponsable de
décider d'une position avant d'avoir
entendu le président et le premier
ministre
en revanche oui sur la loi d'urgence est
mise à travailler
nous avons travaillé nous la connaissons
très franchement nous ne pouvons pas
l'adopter en l'état je le dis dès
maintenant pourquoi parce que
premièrement on nous met l'urgence
sanitaire pour six mois
ça veut dire ça veut dire que l'on ne
propose pas nous ce serait raisonnable
de l'instaurer pour deux mois puis qu'il
y ait un nouveau rendez vous avec le
parlement le parlement est niée dans
cette affaire on prévoit déjà dans
quatre mois
une loi de réduction d'urgence sanitaire
enfin qu'est ce qu'on en sait et enfin
je ne veux pas être trop long outre le
fait qu'il n'y a pas de mesures sociales
il y a un nombre d' ordonnance
vous savez qu'on arrive je sais pas on
doit en être à cinq cas probables
ordonnance alors à ce qu'il y ait des
cas et tous les gouvernements eurent
recours à des ordonnances dans des cas
d'extrême urgence d'urgence lorsque
c'est nécessaire mais il y a des
quantités d'eau redonnant ce qui ne sont
pas utiles et qui peuvent donner
tout simplement une décision
parlementaire allait tout de suite on va
rejoindre jean mas siège en masse et
notre streamer politique jean tu as
suivi avec ta communauté sur twitter et
bien toute la discussion convient
d'avoir à l'instant et les questions
d'actualité qu'est ce qui ressort qu est
ce qui interpelle ta communauté après
cette séance est bien écoute tam ce qui
interpelle ce sont les questions et les
réponses d'olivier ferrand le chat
voulait faire les internautes voulait
que les questions soient posées elles
ont été posées merci aux sénatrice et
aux sénateurs pour ça la question les
réponses de l'île et vers ont été jugés
assez peu clair par les internautes
beaucoup d'internautes m'ont fait
remarquer que olivier ferrand avait du
mal à cacher le manque de stratégie du
gouvernement dans la lutte contre l'
qu'ovide olivier verrons qui donc s'est
caché derrière une attitude qu'ils ont
été nombreuses et nombreux à trouver un
peu agressive envers les sénateurs et
sénatrices beaucoup trouvent colligées
verront utilise des mots un peu trop
fort lorsqu'il devint répond aux élus
ceci étant il y en a quand même
plusieurs qui ont fait remarquer qu'il
plaignent olivier ferrand en dix ans
olivier ferrand il est en train de s'en
prendre plein la gueule de la part des
sénateurs et sénatrices alors que lui il
fait partie des premiers qui depuis
plusieurs mois tirent la sonnette
d'alarmé en disant qu'il faut y aller
mollo et c est d'ailleurs l'idée vers en
a plutôt marqué des points au moment où
il a répondu au sénateur alain milon
alain milon qu' il ya encore quinze
jours les sénateurs étaient en train de
faire passer des amendements de proposer
au gouvernement de réouvrir les bars et
les restos à marseille et que donc il y
avait un petit peu d'hypocrisie de la
part de certains sénateurs qui
aujourd'hui reproche au gouvernement de
ne pas en avoir fait assez à ce moment
là là sur ce coup-là faut reconnaître
que l'idée ferrand a marqué des points
libération une deuxième délibération
donc un autre vote qui a fait que
finalement les sénateurs n'ont pas voté
pour la réouverture des bars nom n'est
pas irresponsable
vous n'êtes pas irresponsable c'est la
bonne mais bon vous savez non voilà que
le match aussi olivier ferrand le sénat
c'est ce qui vraiment interpelle dans
dans cette séquence
philippe dallier alors on a un peu la
forme et puis on a le fond c'est à dire
l'esprit de responsabilité dans cette
séquence vous vous demandiez tout à
l'heure est ce que la démocratie
fonctionne en cette période
oui elle fonctionne dans des conditions
particulières mais elle fonctionne
si vous regardez ce qui s'est passé
depuis le manoir ce le sénat a toujours
été au rendez
où nous avons adopté en les modifiant
souvent des textes dans des délais
extrêmement courts nous avons nous avons
trouvé rechercher et trouver des accords
avec l'assemblée nationale donc que
monsieur véran ou le gouvernement mais
on va laisser monsieur errant sur le
sujet viennent nous chercher des poux
dans la tête sur cette question
franchement c'est très mal venue et
surtout en utilisant un argument qui
n'en est pas un franchement mettre en
cause le sénat comme il peut
oui c'est petit c'est bas et je pense
qu'il aurait mieux fait de s'abstenir ça
ne grandit pas c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire un mois jean pierre sueur
sur le fait qu'on voit beaucoup de
personnes qui sont inquiètes face à
cette nouvelle restriction des libertés
qui s'annonce alors restriction de
liberté nécessaire et justifiée par les
la sécurité sanitaire mais on a vu des
tribunes de jean marie burguburu de
dominique rousseau de claire hédon qui
s'inquiètent face à ces restrictions
est ce que c'est votre cas aussi est-ce
qu'on restera trop nos libertés dans
cette séquence est entièrement juste il
sait pourquoi on a besoin du parlement
vous savez le sénat il a des qualités il
a peut-être des défauts mais il a une
grande qualité c'est qu'il défend
toujours les libertés publiques
pour nous c'est extraordinairement
important et alors là nous sommes en
phase de textes qui restreignent qui
donne le pouvoir de restreindre les
libertés publiques
nous devons être très attentifs parce
que il ne faut pas aller au-delà de ce
qui est nécessaire
il faut bien sûr faire ce qui est
nécessaire
le confinement c'est une atteinte aux
libertés publiques c'est clair il faut
le faire s'il n'y a pas d'autres moyens
si un impératif de santé publique
s'impose à nous mais en même temps
voyez-vous lorsqu'on demande une carte
blanche pour six mois
nous disons non parce que nous voulons
préserver ce qui fait la république
française ce pourquoi elle est aimée à
savoir liberté égalité fraternité
voyez vous c'est très simple un alarmant
sur ce sujet philippe dont je partage
absolument la vie d'agent perçu heures
et c'est bien pour cela effectivement
que non le texte qui vient le
ordonnance qui étaient 70 sera ramenée
par le sénat nous verrons bien mais
probablement à une trentaine seulement
mais 30 c'est déjà beaucoup mais de
soixante dix à trente donc c'est ce
travail là que nous faisons pour
préserver les libertés publiques et
rassembler les deux mois je ne vous ai
pas répondu totalement sur la question
du vote sur le texte sur l'urgence
sanitaire
oui car il était percé modifié et bien
sûr il est tout à fait possible que
toutes les modifications qui seront
faites par le sénat fasse que nous
puissions voté le texte du sénat mais
nous ne pouvons pas voter en l'état le
texte du gouvernement
c'est impossible s'est dit allez on
prend à nouveau la direction de la salle
des conférences pour rejoindre alexandre
poussard vous êtes avec la sénatrice
centriste française gatel pour revenir
et bien sûr toute cette séquence bien
sûr marqué par la pandémie
et oui françoise gatel comment vous
allez faire pour défendre les libertés
des français dans le débat qui aura lieu
demain sur le projet de loi prorogeant
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
et je crois que tout à l'heure le
ministre vers ans a dit que le sénat
donné beaucoup de conseils autre leçon
nation ou de leçons moi je pense que le
sait l'un veut dire son mot qui est le
mot que lui confie la constitution
c'est-à-dire dans une crise sanitaire
c'est un peu comme dans une course il
peut y avoir un pilote qui est
l'exécutif mais il ya un copilote qui
guide qui contrôle et qui encadre et si
tout le rôle du parlement et je crois
que le sénat à coeur de donner au
gouvernement les moyens de gérer cette
crise
mais en même temps d'une manière très
affirmée et très responsable
le sénat rappelle qu'on ne peut pas
faire un chèque en blanc un gouvernement
quel qu'il soit mais que ce gouvernement
doit rendre compte et on doit encadrer
les possibilités pour ce gouvernement de
prendre des mesures nécessaires en
matière de réactivité
parce que cet état d'urgence dure très
longtemps et qu'on ne doit pas
s'installer dans une gestion des
affaires qui serait aux seules mains de
l'exécutif
quand le bateau subi un gros temps et
aujourd'hui c'est ce que subit notre
pays
il faut garder le pied calme et droit il
faut rappeler que nous vivons dans une
démocratie que la démocratie
elle est supérieure à tous et que dans
nos institutions il y à un exécutif qui
a sa légitimité sa responsabilité mais
il ya aussi un parlement qui doit
pouvoir au nom des français intervenir
proposer des choses et encadré alors
justement durant cette période
exceptionnelle le gouvernement demande
aux parlementaires de faire des
propositions mais est-ce que vous avez
l'impression d'être écoutés dans vos
propositions
je pense et on le verra dans la loi
d'urgence sanitaire le sénat fait
beaucoup de propositions
il a aussi entendu des choses
nécessaires je comprends qu'il y ait une
certaine un sentiment un peu d'urgence
mme il ya un emballement qui je trouve
n'est pas sain encore une fois quand le
temps est gros dit on dans ma bretagne
de ma faim il faut savoir garder son
calme
je pense que le gouvernement doit aussi
entendre des demandes et des
propositions qui sont formulées par on a
besoin d'avoir des éléments
d'information sur l'impact économique
sur l'impact social qu'il est
l'évaluation comment va-t-on travaillé
et aujourd'hui je crois que le parlement
mais les responsables politiques l'ont
affirmé nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui les
informations qui seraient nécessaires
pour qu'on puise une manière positif et
constructif faire notre travail
alors avec vous françoise gatel faudrait
qu'on vienne sur un des petits incidents
de cette séance de questions d'actualité
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin qui a interpellé directement
bruno retailleau pour lui demander de
retirer ses propos d'hier soir sur le
droit à caricaturer bruno retailleau qui
demande quand même une forme de respect
de prudence dans nos caricatures
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec lui
alors d'abord je rappellerai que le che
darmanin qui est brillant un peu dévié
sur la réponse à la question qui était
celle du président de la commission des
lois et qui parlait de de la façon dont
on gère les personnes qui devrait plus
rester sur notre territoire
ah bon et monsieur d'arman
c'est en quelque sorte soudainement
détendue par un trait ou d'une
escarmouche qui portait sur la phrase
qui dit monsieur retailleau et monsieur
darmanin disait que monsieur retailleau
émettait des réserves sur le droit de
caricaturer puisqu'il faisait le
caricaturer servent avec respect moi je
pense je sais pas ce qu'a dit monsieur
retailleau et je ne porte pas du tout de
même si je dis et je crois que tous les
les républicains dans ce pays quand je
dis république je parle pas des seuls
membres du parti des républicains mais
disent que caricaturer dessinée critiqué
faire de l'humour fait partie des
libertés essentielles de notre
démocratie il faut qu'on puisse
continuer à le faire et caricaturés
n'est pas forcément provoquer parce que
je pense que ceux qui sont caricaturés
doivent aussi être et veiller à ce que
veut dire cette caricature qui est un
trait d'humour parfois qui est aussi un
élément pédagogique pour attirer
l'attention sur des excès donc il faut
le prendre comme ça parce qu'il faut du
respect dans la caricature
c'est un peu con trats non non non moi
je veux dire le jeu je ne suis pas dit
où l'interprète de monsieur retailleau
la caricature c'est la caricature
si vous donnez à quelqu'un le droit de
s'exprimer ou 3 ou ou de caricaturer il
s'exprime il dessine comme il veut
trouver un endroit de caricaturer total
merci beaucoup françoise gatel d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
merci à alexandre est justement pour
comprendre exactement de quoi on parle
une herbe à réécouter ce moment où
gérald darmanin a attaqué à bruno
retailleau tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle sur la question des
caricatures quand j'entends de prison
votre groupe ce matin sur rtl
dire je cite monsieur retailleau qui
donne des leçons de fermeté à tout bout
de champ oui à la caricature mais avec
une forme de respect et ben non monsieur
le président retailleau
la liberté d'expression est totale même
quand ça gêne elle concerne toutes les
religions et c'est avec ce genre de
format monsieur ciotti vous a d'ailleurs
corrigé
monsieur abad vous à corriger et oui
vous devriez retirer vos propos parce
que je crois monsieur prison retailleau
que ce avec des propos comme ceux ci qu
on n'encourage pas le président de la
république et leur nom être ferme comme
nous le sommes depuis ce matin
philippe dallier que pensez vous de
cette attaque de gérald darmanin à
l'égard du président de votre groupe
on va rappeler que vous ne retailleau a
plaidé hier pour une forme de respect
dans les caricatures ces propos ont fait
polémique
je précise aussi qu'il a tenté
d'éteindre l'incendié par un tweet dans
lequel il dit qu'on ne me fasse pas dire
ce que je n'ai pas dit le droit à la
caricature est un droit que rien ni
personne n'a le droit de remettre en
cause
écoutez je pense que gérald darmanin la
question qui lui était posée n'était pas
une question facile c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire puisque sur l'immigration
wii et sur les reconduites à la
frontière de ce qui effectivement ont
été sommés par la justice du pays de
quitter le territoire
voilà donc il a botté en touche et il a
un bon petit tactique politique il a
effectivement changé de sujet et en plus
à mon sens déformé les propos du
président de notre groupe je le connais
bien je connais bien bruno retailleau et
laissé entendre qu'il pourra être
complaisant vis-à-vis de ceux qui
aujourd'hui s'en prennent à la france
est bon même jusqu à décapiter un
enseignant il y a quelques jours enfin
franchement c'est pas c'est pas digne
quoi voilà donc gérald darmanin aurait
mieux fait de répondre à la question qui
lui a été posée
plutôt que de créer de petites
polémiques je note que bruno retailleau
a dit ce qu'il fallait on dire point
barre la caricature c'est la caricature
et sur le fond jean pierre sfeir surtout
le débat qu'on voit naître autour des
caricatures c'est un débat au niveau
international bien sûr avec ce boycott
qui vise aujourd'hui la france les
échanges entre air doan et emmanuel
macron et même au niveau interne on voit
le président du cfcm qui dit attention
les caricatures il faut quand même une
forme de modération sur les cars et
camions
soyons très clairs et soyons solidaires
la liberté d'expression c'est la liberté
d'expression le droit à la caricature
c'est le droit à la caricature et de la
caricature
qu'est ce que vous voulez vous lisez des
canards paraissant le mercredi où
d'autres jours la caricature n'est pas
respectueuse si elle est respectueuse
c'est plus une caricature voyez ce que
je veux dire
alors moi je suis pour une position très
claire
il y à la liberté de la caricature il y
à la liberté d'expression
la seule chose qui est interdite
c'est lorsque on viole la loi exemple
vos publié dans un journal quelque chose
qui est raciste
le racisme n'est pas une opinion c'est
un délit dont vous pouvez être poursuivi
devant les tribunaux
est ce que j'aimerais c'est qu'on arrive
à ce que des messages qui sont sur
internet et qui sont non pas les
caricatures mais qui sont contraires à
la loi
racisme antisémitisme diffamation
injures qu'il soit poursuivi
comme c'est le cas si cela arrive à
public c'est là où dans n'importe quel
journal de ce pays il ya la loi via le
gouvernement avait identifié ce problème
au moins mais oui mais on a tous dit on
était nombreux à dire y compris au sénat
à propos de la loi avia l'idée
l'intention est bonne simplement le
conseil constitutionnel a bien remarqué
et nous l'avions dit ici que telle
qu'elle est écrite elle portait atteinte
à la liberté d'expression dont nous nous
disons 1
la liberté d'expression doit être
garanti protéger ok 2
il y a dans la loi un certain nombre de
délits qui sont écrits et je vous dis
qu'il s'applique à tous les journaux qui
s'applique à toutes les télévisions
par exemple les propos racistes et bien
ce que je voudrais c'est que l'on arrive
à un système tourné si un message sur
internet même s'il est anonyme
il ya bien quelqu'un qui est responsable
de sa publication
et je voudrais je sais ce n'est pas
facile qu'on arrive à pouvoir mettre en
cause quelqu'un qui diffuse un message
qui est contraire à la loi
ce qui est tout à fait différent de la
liberté d'expression qui doit être
totale
philippe dallier là dessus puisque l'on
sait bien sûr que dans l'assassinât de
sa mère pattie les réseaux sociaux ont
joué un rôle important
à la fois lorsque et bien le terroriste
qui a tué sa mère pattie et bien ses
ventes et de cet assassinat et puis même
auparavant dans la chaîne qui a pu
entraîner à ce drame enfin je remarque
d'abord que même lorsque les auteurs de
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux
sont anonymes il ya parfois les moyens
j'allais dire d'aller les chercher
pour cela on a besoin de la coopération
effectivement des grands fournissent
avait même été et parfois c'est
effectivement signé aki hamas est signée
donc la loi peut s'appliquer dans ces
cas là mais la question était posée par
la loi la vie a été plus compliqué que
ça il fallait mettre en responsabilité
facebook twitter etc
les positionner en censeur et est donc
c'est les dispositions qui étaient dans
le texte qui nous paraissait
effectivement allé beaucoup trop loin
donc le sujet tout le monde est d'accord
il existe il est extrêmement complexe et
on ne je ne pense pas qu'on trouvera
j'allais dire quand on trouvera une
formulation qui permettra ne laissons
pas croire cela que disparaîtront sur
les réseaux sociaux
tout ce tout toutes ses formes
effectivement de dérive
voilà par contre on peut essayer
d'améliorer les choses mais la loi avia
je pense que la député en question s'il
est très mal pris
tout le monde avait dit que conseil
constitutionnel à les censurer il a
censuré mais écoutez il faut remettre
tout cela sur le tapis et essayer de
trouver une meilleure articulation ça
sera sûrement le cas avec la nouvelle
loi sur les séparatismes merci beaucoup
à tous les deux d'avoir participé à ce
débrief des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
dans un instant sur ce plateau la
sénatrice us et nathalie goulet et la
sénatrice rdp un ce nouveau groupe de la
majorité présidentielle nadège avait on
va continuer à débriefer l'actualité
mais d'abord on rejoint quentin qu'elle
met dans l'hémicycle quentin vous allez
revenir pour nous et bien sûr les temps
forts de cette séance
qu'est ce que vous retenez et bien tam
il ya eu plusieurs passes dame passe
d'armes aujourd'hui entre sénateurs et
le gouvernement autant des sénateurs de
gauche que de droite
tout d'abord sur le sujet de la
responsabilité du gouvernement dans
cette deuxième vague que nous sommes en
train de vie
bernard jomier par exemple il a parlé de
nouvelles mesures restrictives annoncé
ce soir qui devrait être devraient être
annoncées ce soir par emmanuel macron
comme des mesures qui seront je cite les
marqueurs de l'échec de votre politique
de santé publique
un autre moment la tension est montée
entre olivier ferrand et cette fois ci à
la sénatrice laurence rossignol
le ministre n'a pas apprécié que cette
sénatrice évoque les semi vérités dans
le discours biomnis de la santé écoutez
les changes
la sénatrice on ne sauve pas des vies
avec des attaques politiques on ne
soutient pas les soignants avec des
attaques politiques
on n'encourage pas les français à tenir
bon dans cette période difficile avec
des attaques politiques avec une attaque
politique avec des attaques politiques
comme celles que vous faites avec la
polémique permanente que certains
essayent d'instaurer un moment où nous
avons besoin de solidarité et d'unité
nationale
je ne crois pas madame la sénatrice que
vous ayez participer et aider votre pays
dans la lutte contre l'épidémie en
soutien des français à manière dont vous
traitez nos propositions qu'il s'agisse
de l'examen des projets de loi qu'il
s'agisse de nos discussions de plus
techniques de mise en oeuvre de la
politique sanitaire ne nous ne nous fera
pas renoncer à vous faire des
propositions mais permettez nous aussi
dire aux français que vous voyagez sol
vous pilotez sol et vous n'écoutez
jamais ni le parlement ni la société
civile il ya eu un autre sujet très
important aujourd'hui à lors de cette
séance des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
c'est la question à des tensions avec la
turquie recep tayyip erdogan qui a
insulté le président français bien la
droite sénatoriale a soutenu emmanuel
macron elle a appelé à hausser le ton
face à la turquie écoutez le président
de la commission de la défense et des
affaires étrangères ici au sénat
christian cambon
si la turquie nous trouve aussi
infréquentable va-t-on par exemple
continuer à prêter chaque année 300
millions d'euros 3 milliards depuis dix
ans à ce pays et cette année l'afd qui
s'apprête à monter à porter ce montant à
400 millions alors me dit-on oui la
france a aussi des intérêts comme ses
voisins des intérêts économiques en
turquie je ne le mets connais pas mais
l'appel au boycott des produits français
déjà une réponse et devrait nous inciter
à beaucoup plus de lui
édité pour l'avenir de nos entreprises
dans ce pays est maintenant écouter la
réponse de florence parler la ministre
des armées
un peu plus tard cette séance
lorsqu'elle a évoqué l'attitude de la
turquie pourtant membre de l'otan
écoutez la bon nombre de pays européens
mais pas seulement aussi les etats-unis
ont condamné de façon publique les
agissements nature qui alors pour
terminer je dirai qu'au delà de ces
dénonciations du comportement tueur il
faut agir et c'est ce que nous faisons
notamment dans le cadre de l'opération
irini où nous faisons preuve d'une
posture à la fois vigilante et de
fermeté
la ministre qui vient d'évoquer
l'opération irigny inquiets l'opération
de l'union européenne qui est déployé en
méditerranée depuis avril 2020 et donc
on le vend à la tension est forte dans
ce dossier et âme
merci beaucoup quentin pour toutes ces
explications et ses temps forts que vous
avez retenu de cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
on poursuit le débrief avec nathalie
goulet bonjour vous êtes sénatrice us et
de l'ordre vice présidente de la
commission des lois est également avec
nous nadège avait bonjourbonjour
sénatrice terres des pays du finistère
vous êtes membre de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable je voudrais
d'abord qu'on revienne sur cette
question des caricatures qui est bien et
sont à l'origine aussi des tensions
récentes qui lie à entre la turquie et
la france
dernier épisode en date aujourd'hui avec
la clique caricature d'air d'eau anin
dans charlie hebdo que vous voyez à
l'écran qui provoque la colère d'ankara
on y voit ce dessin qui montre le
président turc en tee shirt et en sous
vêtements en train de boire une bière de
soulever la jupe d'une femme voilée
la turquie annonce qu'elle va prendre
des mesures judiciaires et diplomatiques
un mot d'abord est bien là dessus
nathalie goulet un mot sur cette image
c'est là c'est aussi la réponse de
charlie hebdo avec l'outrance qu'on leur
connaît et leurs droits de caricaturer
ar doan parce que le président turc
appelle lui-même au boycott des produits
français
et cela parce que la semaine dernière et
bien emmanuel macron a défendu le droit
de caricaturer lors de l'homme
hajj hassan elle pâtit c'est charlie wi
on est charlie on est charlie voilà il
faut vous êtes charlie et charlie est
intéressant dans le contexte actuel non
mais je dis à la liberté se divise pas
bon que des gens soient choqués on peut
le comprendre
ces traces que l'objectif d'une
caricature aussi justement encours de
crédit reste donc si vous voulez mais
moi je vais sûrement faire beaucoup de
mécontents et pourtant des gens vont
probablement me reprocher ce que je vais
dire mais il ya des moments où on a
besoin d'apaisement et des moments on
n'a pas besoin d'accroître la tension je
trouve que la tension entre la france et
la turquie est déjà bien forte
donc je comprends moi à titre personnel
ça me fait pas rire bon mais je
comprends que ça puisse en faire rire
bon ceci est en moi en ce moment
j'essaie plutôt de chercher des moments
d'apaisement face à metz 2 8 sur le feu
baotou les captations en tous les cas ça
ça mais pas de beurre dans les épinards
oui ça met de l'huile sur le feu mais
c'est aussi l'objectif de charlie dans
tout ce débat et cette escalade de temps
bien mais c'est son droit ils l'exercent
le mien et dire que je que vous trouvez
que ça n'est pas constructif a forcé non
c'est pas constructible nadège avait
après on connaît charlie hebdo ils sont
sûrs sur la liberté d'expression la
liberté de conscience donc effectivement
là il preneur libre et d'expression en
affichant une caricature qui peut être
drôle ou pas d'ailleurs
maintenant il existe aussi des
caricatures dans certains pays des
manuels macron qui ont été diffusées
notamment en iran sur
ou qu'il représente en tant que diable
nous on est on ne va pas aller on ne va
pas dire qu'on va prendre des mesures il
peut mettre mon cas mais voilà on est
beaucoup
face à la liberté d'expression n'est pas
divisible on va on va également écoutez
bien ce qu'on a dit jean castex tout à
l'heure dans l'hémicycle puisque il a
consacré sa première réponse dans
l'hémicycle lors des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement au
terrorisme mais il a aussi parlé des
caricatures que ce soit dit ici que se
soit répétée ici comme ailleurs partout
dans le monde
en france on peut publier des
caricatures librement on connaît aussi
vous l'avez dit leur levier leur mode
opératoire des lieux de culte des
tournées des associations paravents des
réseaux sociaux proactif comme les
lâches ils agissent dans l'ombre et bien
qu'ils sachent qu'ils trouveront
toujours la république en travers de
leur chemin
voilà pour la réaction de jean castex
tout à l'heure et tout de suite on va
rejoindre alexandre poussard salades des
conférences alexandre vous êtes avec le
sénateur socialiste jean yves le conte
bien pour parler de ces tensions avec la
turquie
et bien sûr avec cette question ces
caricatures qui sont aussi au coeur de
ces tensions récentes
oui oui avec jean yves le conte on va
parler de cette montée des tensions
entre la france et la turquie de cette
surenchère verbale surenchère d'insultés
du gouvernement turc envers le président
de la république jean yves le conte est
ce que vous trouvez que la réponse de la
diplomatie française est assez forte
face au gouvernement turc
on n'est pas obligé de calquer la
réponse sur les méthodes du président
turc donc de ce qu'on avait là
l'important c'est d'être ferme sur le
fond est correct dans la forme
alors comment on est ferme sur ce point
de vue là
c'est c'est correct il faut pas
participer à cette évolution vers l'un
ni rationnel absolu
bon voilà il ya les choses pour moi sont
claires il ya des il ya des choses qui
ne se disent pas entre chef de l'état
quand ils sont responsables on est
responsable voilà le niveau d' insulte
auquel s'est livré le président erdogan
on sait pas septembre du tout et c'est
logique une réponse mais il s'agit pas
non plus qu'une escalade absolue on a
suffisamment de désaccord pour essayer
de les traiter point par point de
manière rationnelle
je rappelle quand même que sur un
certain nombre de désaccords en
particulier sur ce qui se passe
actuellement en azerbaïdjan on a besoin
de faire en sorte de trouver un point
pour sauver des vies d'accord mais par
exemple quand le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères du
sénat christian cambon propose des
mesures financières notamment sur des
prêts de l'agencé française pour le
développement des prêts qu'on fait
actuellement la turquie est ce qu'il
faut des mesures des sanctions
économiques des sanctions financières
quand on fait des prêts sans subvention
on vend de l'argent donc on gagne de
l'argent
voilà donc il faut pas faire de cesser
ces mêmes sujets qu avec la chine c'est
le même sujet qu'avec un certain nombre
à kankan laquelle agence française de
développement fed est prêt elle agit
comme une banque une banque elle vend de
l'argent elles gagnent de l'argent en
vendant de l'argent voilà
est ce que on sait pas des cadeaux donc
faut être pragmatique voilà deux points
de vue là c'est il faut être
c'est ce que je crois que c'est ces deux
choses deux choses différentes
ce qui est problématique dans cette
affaire c'est que pour nous profondément
ancré dans notre manière de voir les
choses
la religion est une opinion c'est une ça
peut être une conviction profonde mais
c'est une opinion on je n'ai pas une
part de votre identité
la difficulté c'est que dans un certain
nombre de pays du monde votre religion
est une part de votre identité et qu'à
partir de là effectivement voilà il ya
des incompréhensions mais ce qu'il faut
aussi voir c'est que il ya un certain
nombre de pays au moyen orient le liban
depuis un an et demi dont on voit qu'une
population qui veut se sortir de ce
carcan parce que finalement en fait
quand ça fait partie de votre identité
vous en êtes prisonniers et la laïcité
c'est une émancipation
il faut pouvoir promouvoir la laïcité
est notre manière de voir les choses
comme une émancipation avec en n'étant
pas dans une démarche d'affrontement
dans une démarche de conviction vous
parlez de pragmatisme et ce qu'il faut
par exemple continuer à faire des
affaires avec le qatar alors que le
cousin de l'émir du qatar a mené s'est
publiquement emmanuel macron sur les
réseaux sociaux
côté quand il ya des menaces si elle
mérite d'être judiciariser vaut le faire
si le qatar veut inviter veut proposer
de boycotter la france qu'ils boycottent
le psg enfin je veux dire il faut rester
rationnel très bien rester pragmatique
et rationnel merci beaucoup jean yves le
conte d'avoir répondu à mes questions
beaucoup l accent votre réaction
justement à ce sujet qui évoquait à
l'instant alexandre poussard nathalie
goulet est ce que eh bien la france se
doit aussi et bien boycotter faire des
sanctions économiques à l'égard des pays
qui menacent par exemple et bien
emmanuel macron dans ce contexte de
tension qu'il ya un ensemble
si on parle des pays qui menace les
manuels macron c'est une chose mais il
ya aussi tout le contexte de terrorisme
dont a parlé depuis des semaines et des
mois et des années
c'est pas bon donc moi j'écoute ce que
dit
j'arrive le compte et je pense qu'en ce
qui concerne la riposte proportionnée
c'est une réponse de juristes et la
diplomatie est fait pour ça c'est pour
ça que tout à l'heure je vous disais est
ce que c'est bien le moment d'en
rajouter
bon après la liberté de la presse elle
est une indivisible et sacré bon je suis
tout à fait d'accord donc des mesures de
rétorsion je pense qu'on aura d'autres
sujets pour des mesures de rétorsion
mais pour ce qui concerne le qatar ont
fait face comme un débat du boycott ont
fait face mais le boycott c'est bien et
c'est une arme assez traditionnel on l'a
eu au moment où la france a refusé
d'entrer en irak
on s'était plus des french fries c'était
des liberty fries et c'est bon il y aura
des conséquences
mais je crois qu'il faut les supporter
puisque puisque finalement c'est la
position de la france qui compte
il faut les supporter nadège avait mais
pas forcément en faire plus pas
forcément nous même appelé à un fait on
est un pays où on passe par la voie
diplomatique
avant tout il est on peut pas
à mon avis appelé au boycott autres de
différents produits comme dit nathalie
en fait le boycott
il est utilisé un peu partout voilà deux
manières c'est une sorte de sanction
maintenant notre voie c'est à dire
rappelant que c'est enfin il y a le
boycott keller douanes a appelé mais il
ya aussi beaucoup plus tôt beaucoup
d'associations qui ont appelé au boycott
n'était pas forcément la part seulement
des dpi oui tout à fait mais on est un
pays où on passe par la voie
diplomatique et je pense que c'est la
voie à défendre en priorité sur
l'ensemble de ces questions je crois
qu'il faut qu'on ait une position où je
suis resté très longtemps la commission
aux affaires étrangères choix que la
france doit parler d'une seule voix le
pire qui puisse arriver c'est des voix
dissonantes jeudi si le gouvernement
prend une position il faut que la france
parle d'une seule voix je suis un peu de
la vieille école mais je pense que c'est
mieux pour défendre notre pays que nous
parlions d'une seule voix surtout dans
des périodes aussi difficile on va
revenir également bien aux sujets que
vous abordiez dans l'hémicycle tout à
l'heure la question de l'incitation à la
haine sur les médias du moyen-orient qui
sont accessibles en france vous avez
parlé d' al jazeera de tft qu'elle ait
problème exactement que vous visez
aujourd'hui vous savez on est en train
de chasser la laine en ligne bon alors
le texte ma vie a été un votable en
l'état
et oui pas fauté et entièrement censurés
par le conseil compte c'est tout à fait
essentielle
c'était tout à fait légitime parce que
supprimer des contenus sans juge
la commission de la culture ici le sénat
a estimé qu' avec le conseil
constitutionnel que c'était une que
c'est une sanction bien mérité qu'on
aurait mieux fait d'écouter le scénar
bon ceci étant la haine en ligne c'est
une vraie difficulté mais il ya plus que
là elle en ligne il ya aussi les
télévisions qui sont accessibles
il ya une dizaine d'années le csa a
obtenu la suppression de al aqsa les
chaînes du ramasse et puis une autre
télé dont j'ai oublié le nom mais dans
la même année en 2015 et une suppression
d'une d'une chaîne égyptienne qui
diffusait des messages de haine
donc on a les satellites on a la
compétence le csa sait faire on
débranche ça fait déjà des réseaux ce
que vous allez user message récent
particulièrement al jazeera al jazeera
en arabe
oui la chaîne en français agit plus
extra espèce de couverture convenable
lgbt tout le monde il est beau tout le
monde il est gentil donc à une
couverture mais de temps en temps il
passe quand même des messages
la chaîne en arabe est très violente oui
on a déjà vais là dessus votre aviez
alors peut-être pas forcément sur ce jeu
de très spécifique mais sur le fait que
et bien cette haine en ligne soit au
coeur des attentions notamment bien sûr
après l'attentât tj bleus je pense que
tout le monde en a pris conscience le
gouvernement en fait fait également ce
qu'il faut et j'ai toute confiance dans
le dans le ministre
de monsieur darmanin il cherche bien
combattre en fait l'idéologie religieuse
donc et les non pas les musulmans mais
en fait les islamistes tel qu'on le
connaît de manière terroriste et donc
les français musulmans donc sont aussi
que le premier visé par part saisi cela
même à la question c'est de savoir
comment parce que on l'a dit il y avait
eu un texte qui a posé vraiment problème
là la loi via qui a été censuré par le
conseil constitutionnel qu'est ce qu'il
faut prévoir aujourd'hui est bien face à
ces incitations à la haine en ligne ou à
la télévision
le gouvernement a déjà pris des mesures
sur des choses comme dissoudre
l'association ce matin donc le bayrak à
city il travaille également sur la
dissolution du ccf je pense que tout ce
qui va se mettre en place petit à petit
et en travaillant dans l'unité va aussi
permettre d'effacer les réseaux petit à
petit nathalie goulet
écoutez c'est ce qui s'est passé ce
matin j'ai d'ailleurs salué et félicité
le ministère maintenant tout à l'heure
en séance parce que barack et city ça
fait longtemps
cette association est dans le
collimateur des services et il faut
quand même du courage pour dissoudre est
d'ailleurs le dirigeant de barack et
city a rien trouvé de mieux
immédiatement après dans l'herbe dans la
matinée dans les heures qui viennent de
s'écouler de demander l'asile politique
qu'est la turquie oui surtout qu'ils y
aillent
et on va pas on va pas le garder on va
il n'a pas nous manquer un bon donc ça
veut bien dire qu'ils avaient des liens
extérieurs ont simplement entre les
réseaux qu'on a beaucoup de mal à
freiner les télévisions c'est un peu
autre chose parce que la télévision
quand vous débranchez qu'en plus ils
sont sur eutelsat et que on a une
compétence parce que la france a une
compétence et ça ne s'est pas du tout
les mêmes difficultés que pour nos
solutions c'est beaucoup plus facile on
s'est tous très facile c'est beaucoup
plus facile parce que parce que les
chaînes ont apprécié des primes
technique et comme un peu tu écris pour
débrancher un satellite bon film pardon
mais y ait les compétences e juridique
et en plus c'est ça c'est faire donc on
a la compétence
on a les sujets puisque que ce soit drt
où que ce soit à algésiras doivent
répondre à des critères en matière de
respect
du droit qui est en france et surtout
l'appel à la violence d'antisémitisme
parce que c'est aussi ça
vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé avec
avec samuel pâtit ont tous ses appels à
la haine finissent par provoquer les
actes violents sur les personnes donc il
faut trouver le plus vite possible tous
les outils nécessaires pour faire cesser
ces messages internet c'est un autre
problème la télévision c'est quand même
beaucoup plus simple allez on va bien
avec un autre sujet bien sûr qui est
très marquant aujourd'hui dans
l'actualité la pandémie de l'aco vide
alors que l'on attend les annonces des
manuels macron ce soir à 20 heures avec
de nouvelles restrictions et on va
écouter tout à l'heure et bien bernard
jomier le sénateur socialiste est
également co rapporteur de la commission
d' enquête sur la cause vide et il a
tout à l'heure interpellé le
gouvernement l'écoutant il n'est pas
digne de renvoyer aux français la
responsabilité de cette seconde vague
elle est en premier la responsabilité de
ceux qui n'ont pas su analyser et agir à
temps la stratégie tester tracé isolé
est en échec et les français n'y sont
pour rien alors monsieur le ministre
nous attendons ce soir l' annonce de
nouvelles mesures restrictives
elles seront le marqueur de l'échec de
notre politique de santé publique
ayons le courage de le reconnaître voilà
pour l'interpellation tout à l'heure de
bernard je me et un co rapporteur de la
commission denquête qu'ovide on l'entend
dire eh bien il ne faut pas culpabiliser
les français comme le gouvernement peut
le faire parfois aujourd'hui ils
renvoient aussi le gouvernement à ses
responsabilités
qu'est ce que vous répondez nadège avait
quand on dit d'un cat ont fait entre le
mois de mars est aujourd'hui entre la
première et la deuxième vague
je pense que le virus il reste
il reste il évolue on a aussi un
gouvernement qui a qui a pris des
mesures
aujourd'hui la situation elle expose
partout dans le monde
46 % des nouveaux cas en fait sont en
europe
l'union européenne et les différents
pays travaillent ensemble pour trouver
des solutions mais des solutions
visiblement tout le monde prend les
mêmes
quand on voit qu'en espagne il
reconfirme également en irlande
ils ont aussi confirmé au moment on est
sûr effectivement des solutions qui
évolue et mais on n'a pas encore de
système où effectivement on peut soigner
ce virus quelle erreur pour vous ont été
commises dans la gestion vous le dit ce
sont certainement des heurts qui ont été
aussi commises à l'étranger puisque on
en arrive à duras confinement dans
d'autres pays mais qu'est-ce qui a raté
est-ce que c'est aussi l'échec est bien
dû déconfinement que l'on voit
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut faire
face comme pour le terrorisme à l'unité
nationale
on gère d'abord la crise et ensuite on
va effectivement travaillé sur comment
elle a été gérée et qu'est-ce qui peut
être qu est ce qui aurait pu être
amélioré ou pas entre je pense que le
virus aujourd'hui il réagi il est là
beaucoup plus tôt que prévu et même les
scientifiques aujourd'hui ben font
évoluer leur diagnostic au fur et à
mesure mais nathalie goulet en même
temps on se rappelle qu'il y avait aussi
eu des alertes qui avait donné par
certains scientifiques à partir du mois
de juillet
c'est vrai que c'est difficile à on ne
peut pas personne ne voudrait être à la
place du gouvernement aujourd'hui
néanmoins est-ce qu'on est dans un
moment où on peut constater qu'il ya des
choses qui n'ont pas fonctionné
écoutez c'est une situation qui est
totalement inédite est extrêmement
compliqué à gérer je dire on sait pas ce
qu'on ferait à la place du gouvernement
moi je en tant que citoyen je voudrais
quand même vous dire et partager avec
vous le désarroi absolu de la population
qui ne comprend absolument rien à ce qui
se passe ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est l'élu trop de
messages contradictoires trop de
messages contradictoires les
l'airé télévision en chaîne continue qui
sont tellement anxieux gènes qui font de
la surenchère qui va qui va annoncer les
choses les plus épouvantables etc aucun
espèce de respect pour les gens qui chez
eux reçoivent ces messages et qui
commence à être vraiment tout à fait
inquiets encore plus que qu'il l'était
jusque là et puis l'économie qui est
complètement à plat parce que jusqu'à
maintenant coûte que coûte ça va mais on
dira qu'il aura quoi qu'il en coûte quoi
vivre on va les payer de toute façon
mais là le plan de relance va tomber en
plein deuxième vague
c'est à dire qu'il va tomber à plat ça
met de l'argent qui ne pourra pas
produire de d2 résultat pour sauver des
entreprises donc celle qui était pas
encore morte vont être moribonde il va
on pourra pas faire un deuxième plan de
relance on en aura pas les moyens et
donc tout ça crée confusion incertitudes
et et et angoisse pour les populations
au d'abord les fragiles mais les autres
et puis de la casse sociale et puis de
la casse économique et donc quand quand
vous faites le total de cette situation
vous voyez bien que la france est très
fragilisée aujourd'hui est qu'il s'agit
pas à ce soir que le président n'est pas
un discours clair et précis parce que
nous on est tout à fait d'accord pour
suivre le président de la république
affair faire corps faire société
mais il faut aussi voir que le parlement
est pas tellement bien traîner en ce
moment non plus en ce qui concerne
l'information et le suivi donc on
navigue un peu à vue malgré tout on
navigue à vue a dit nathalie goulet
on a entendu un notamment l'opposition
très critiques très sévères
après bien la séance de consultation
hier en présence des partis politiques
certains ont dit on nous a conviés à une
réunion mais nous n'avons rien appris
l'inde et j'avais oui alors visiblement
la réunion a aussi beaucoup porté sur le
report des élections est assez peu aussi
sur le coup vite
nous la vraie problématique aussi
lorsqu'on est sur le point d'apprendre
de nouvelles mesures de restriction il
est aussi importante pour les français
tout à fait après je pense que le sujet
des élections peut être remis à plus
tard sur je parle des régionales et des
cantonales évidemment aujourd'hui il
faut que donc ce soir le président de la
république parlera demain jans cappel
jean castex nous expliquera
effectivement comment le gouvernement va
mettre en oeuvre les mesures que
monsieur le président présentera et il
faudra effectivement qu'on puisse avoir
de la lisibilité sur les choses et puis
qu'on puisse travailler tout ce qu'on se
remet vous trouvez pas quand même que
c'est un rythme qui est très bousculés
pour le parlement aujourd'hui on a vu
deux fois et bien les interruptions sur
l'examen du projet de loi de prorogation
de l'état d'urgence une première fois là
et puis là cette fois ci encore une fois
il a été retiré de l'ordre du jour c'est
très compliqué aussi pour ceux nés à
travailler dans ces conditions tout à
fait je serais chef de file sur le texte
demain sur la progression du budget de
l'état d'urgence il faut aussi s'adapter
à la situation et on voit que la
situation progresse vite dans le mauvais
sens malheureusement sur la crise
sanitaire et donc on doit aussi être
réactif pour pouvoir effectivement
essayer de prendre le maximum de bonnes
mesures possibles le mois de la fin
nathalie que j'ai lâché le mot de la fin
avant tout les cas j'espère qu'on pourra
travailler dans des conditions à peu
près normale pour le projet de loi de
finances de sécurité sociale et pour le
projet de loi de finances tout court
parce que ce sont des textes absolument
fondamentaux et il faut que le parlement
puisse travailler dans de bonnes
conditions
vous devrez c'est compliqué aussi sur le
projet de loi de finances quand on voit
la l'annoncé d'un prochain
confinement ont fouillé deux médailles
celle là si le budget va pouvoir le
budget transfert d'une façon ou d'une
autre un beau jeans le budget doit être
votée à la fin du mois de décembre et
moi j'appelle tout à fait de façon tout
à fait sérieuse et est tout à fait
lourde enfin en tous les cas j'appelle
vraiment à ce qu'on puisse travailler
dans des conditions normales le plfss
lpfc les actes fondateurs pour
travailler normalement j'espère qu'on
pourra travailler dans de bonnes
conditions c'est vraiment un appel au
gouvernement pour qu'on puisse au moins
travailler même en nombre réduit et va
falloir revoir nos méthodes de travail
aussi à nos méthodes de vote parce que
le vote budget c'est un vote pour
l'ensemble du parlement et des
parlementaires donc il faut qu'on ait
notre c'est un droit parlementaire
majeur l'acquiescement au budget voilà
il ya encore du pain sur la planche pour
le parlement qui s'apprête à légiférer
dans des conditions on imagine compliqué
alors qu'on attend et bien les nouvelles
restrictions annoncées par le président
de la république ça sera ce soir à 20h
merci beaucoup à tout les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débrief des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement à 18h vous
retrouvez rebecca fitoussi pour un
nouveau numéro d' allons plus loin
encore très largement consacré à la
gestion de la qos vide en attendant
voyez les temps forts de la séance de
questions d'actualité sélectionnés par
alice par d'autres bonne soirée sur
public sénat nous faisons face à la
seconde vague
et comme au printemps avec beaucoup
d'autres pays de l'hémisphère nord
notamment
et comme au printemps la qualité de
notre réponse déterminera le nombre de
vies que nous sauverons ou de vie que
nous perdrons la première vague a révélé
des forces et des faiblesses de notre
pays
les constats qui ont été effectués
montrent de sérieux problèmes
d'organisation celle de certains parlent
même d'une crise organisationnel et de
nombre non moins sérieuses failles dans
nos processus de décision jusqu'à
l'expert mentionné par le chef de l'état
qui fait ces constats alors monsieur le
ministre
quelles sont les décisions que vous avez
prises quels sont les actes que vous
avez posé
suite à ces concertos pour mieux nous
préparer à cette seconde vague
je vous remercie monsieur le sénateur
joe mais vous avez raison la science la
seconde vague frappe l'europe
elle frappe d'ailleurs indistinctement
l'ensemble des pays qui nous entourent
y compris les pays qui ont eu 1 re
démarrage plus tardif que la france
l'italie a multiplié le nombre de
nouveaux diagnostics par dix en moins de
trois semaines
en moins de trois semaines l'allemagne
augmentent de 100 % le nombre de malades
chaque semaine la suisse dont on vantait
à juste titre l'investissement
incroyable des troupes lors d'un pays la
taille de la suisse sur le contact
racing et la capacité de tests a vu
toutes ses capacités de contact racing
débordé et ses capacités de test saturé
avec des délais qui sont analogues à
ceux qu'on avait pu connaître il ya
quelques semaines dans notre pays
face à cela on pourrait penser mais ce
n'est pas votre cas est vous êtes
forcément sénateurs mais médecin on
pourrait penser qu'il faudrait chercher
là un dysfonctionnement d'un appareil
d'état où on peut se demander utilement
comment freiner collectivement par
l'action de tous et en solidarité
la diffusion du virus avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard monsieur le sénateur il
ya trois paramètres dans un virus comme
le coronavirus deux qu'on ne maîtrise
pas la contagiosité
c'est à dire les risques de transmettre
le virus quand on l'a le nombre de jours
pendant lequel on est contagieux ces
deux paramètres là on ne maîtrise pas il
ya en somme un bar à mettre et c'est
vieux comme le monde
on peut maîtriser c'est le nombre de
personnes avec qui on est en contact et
qui pourraient être contaminés c'est
pour cela que nous prenons les gestes
barrières que nous prenons le lavage des
mains que nous prônons la distanciation
sociales et des mesures de restriction
sont prises partout où c'est nécessaire
sur l'ensemble du territoire et nous
continuerons monsieur le ministre je
suis tout de même un peu inquiet de vous
entendre dire qu'il n'ya pas
dysfonctionnement de l'état
tous les rapports tous les travaux
effectués montrent qu'il ya un problème
d'organisation et qu'il ya un problème
dans les processus de décision
cette myriade d'agents sanitaires mal
coordonnées entre elles la création par
le chef de l'état d'instance nouvelle
alors que la crise est en cours témoigne
témoigne de ces difficultés
tout le monde est responsable certes
mais certains ont plus de
responsabilités que d'autres et n'est
pas digne de renvoyer aux français la
responsabilité de cette seconde vague
elle est en premier la responsabilité de
ceux qui n'ont pas su analyser et agir à
temps la stratégie tester tracé isolé
est en échec et les français n'y sont
pour rien alors monsieur le ministre
nous attendons ce soir l' annonce de
nouvelles mesures restrictives
elles seront le marqueur de l'échec de
notre politique de santé publique
ayons le courage de le reconnaître
chaque année la grippe saisonnière
touche des millions de français en
traîne des milliers d'admission en
urgence le vaccin contre la grippe
sauvent des vies et limite les
complications les mesures appliquées
contre la queue vide 19 devrait ralentir
la propagation de l'épidémie grippale de
façon plus certaine il s'agit de limiter
l'engorgement des hôpitaux et les
erreurs de diagnostic liées à des
symptômes similaires entre les deux
virus
de plus les risques de double infection
semble réel
dans ce contexte les français sont
invités très largement à se vacciner
contre la grippe
d'où une demande globale en forte
augmentation cette année plus de 15
millions de personnes sont destinataires
de prescription de vaccins des commandes
de votre ministère aurait été passé en
mars dernier sur la base du chiffre de
l'année dernière avec une augmentation
de 30 %
malgré cet effort au-delà de la campagne
de vaccination ciblant les personnes les
plus vulnérables
allons-nous réellement pouvoir couvrir
l'ensemble des demandes de cette année
enfin la lumière de cette expérience
comment allez vous anticipez le bon
approvisionnement en france des vaccins
contre lacko vite 19 lorsqu'ils seront
disponibles sur le marché mondial ce
n'est pas le gouvernement qui fait des
commandes de vaccin antigrippal ce sont
les pharmacies d'officine qui s'équipent
il se trouve que cette année les
pharmaciens sont autorisés à vacciner
contre la grippe de manière plus
importante que les années précédentes et
les commandes ne le passent pas en mars
mais mois de décembre dernier avant même
l'épidémie une chance dans notre malheur
si je puis dire c'est que les
pharmaciens considérant qu'ils avaient
vacciner davantage on commande un peu
plus de vaccins que les années
précédentes et par ailleurs
au printemps lorsque l'épidémie a
commencé nous avons fait le choix pour
la première fois de nous doter d'un
stock d'état complémentaire de vaccins à
mettre à disposition des officiers des
défis et des hôpitaux
si jamais la situation devait l'exiger
quelle est la situation précise nous
avons consommé en cinq jours
l'équivalent d'un mois de doses de
vaccin antigrippal une ruée véritable
ruée sur les pharmacies 82% des
personnes qui ont acheté des vaccins en
pharmacie sont âgées de 65 ans et plus
ils sont donc parfaitement dans la cible
et sur les 18 % qui restent un certain
nombre d'entre eux correspondent à des
soignants des prestataires du domicile
ils ont donc dans la cible est à des
gens qui sont porteurs de comorbidité de
pathologies qui rend la vaccination
antigrippale nécessaire pour eux
l'aoc encore on est dans la cible un
certain nombre de pharmaciens pour face
à des ruptures de stock pour la plupart
temporaire je vous rassure cette semaine
un million trois cent mille doses
supplémentaires sont livrés pour ré
achalandé les pharmacies 3 millions de
doses vont suivre à destination des
pharmaciens seller commandes habituelles
et au cours du mois de novembre et même
jusqu'à début décembre l'état se
pourvoir en vaccins pour pouvoir réagir
et achalandé ces pharmacies monsieur le
sénateur il n'y a pas d'urgence puisque
la grippe ne démarre pas avant noël dans
l'hémisphère sud elle a même été retardé
et qu'une vaccination doit être fait au
bon moment et mon appel monsieur le
sénateur mon appel ma crainte n'est pas
que nous manquions vaccin ma crainte est
que nous ne soyons pas assez nombreux
parmi les publics vulnérables à avoir
une vaccination antigrippale faute
d'aller décidé se faire vacciner l'année
dernière 48 % du public cible s'est fait
vacciner leurs maîtres commandes
d'atteindre 75%
je souhaite ardemment que les publics
vulnérables et fragiles des médecins les
soignants les acteurs du domicile se
fassent vacciner
il en va de la protection des français
c'est là notre objectif et les dom et
les et l'accès au vaccin
suivra vous pouvez compter sur le réseau
des pharmaciens pour cela monsieur le
ministre j'ai bien entendu votre réponse
et je vous en remercie
la difficulté que nous ayons c'est de
pouvoir y voir clair dans les chiffres
j'étais allé chercher j'ai cherché les
chiffres à peu près partout et j'ai
trouvé des des commandes est un acronyme
aider vraiment des choses que je
n'arrivais pas à expliquer donc je
n'arrive pas à fixer le chiffre il
semblerait que c'est de l'ordre de 13
millions de vaccins qui ont été
commandés peut-être avec + 30 % 17
millions maximum elle mais tant qu'il ya
eu 17 millions de commandes et on sait
qu'aujourd'hui la population française
les plus de 65 ans
elle porte sur 13 millions d'individus
les entre 60 et 65 ans vous rajouter 4
millions donc j'avais vo 17 millions à
plus de
sur la base des plus de 60 ans donc on
voit bien que on est sur un nombre de
vaccins disponibles qui risque d'être en
dessous d'une demande si effectivement
comme on le voit aujourd'hui il ya une
vraie tension qui fait que les
pharmacies ne peuvent pas répondre à ces
personnes qui se présentent
l'autre aspect de ma question c'est est
une gare à cette expérience qui devra
forcément avoir des effets et un impact
de la même manière sur le vaccin du coc
vide 19
il me paraît important de pouvoir
anticiper et de se projeter une
situation qui sera compliqué ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur ce musée l'intérieur je
voudrais d'abord et à travers vous tous
le gouvernement vous féliciter pour les
mesures qui ont été prises il ya
quelques jours
d'abord la dissolution du collectif
cheikh yacine et ce matin la dissolution
de baraka city nous l'attendions depuis
longtemps c'est fait mais depuis
quelques jours des attaques d'une
violence inacceptable contre le
président de la république et contre la
france se propage via des médias des
pays arabes et des médias turcs qui sont
autant de vecteurs de haine pouvant
inciter à la violence physique tour
eiffel ensanglanté discours de l disco
gravement antisémite appel à la violence
la chaîne qatarienne al jazeera en arabe
multiplient les attaques comme la chaîne
turque trt on sait que le qatar et la
turquie soutiennent la mouvance des
frères musulmans dont j'ai demandé à de
multiples reprises l'interdiction en
france
leur leader youssouf qaradawi interdit
de séjour dans de nombreux pays
européens multiplient les appels à la
haine un des derniers en date était un
hommage appuyé au travail d'hitler
précisant même qu'en chaise roulante il
irait à battre des juifs nous avons
monsieur le ministre les outils
juridiques lactique que deux caps de la
directive européenne services médias
audiovisuels nous avons également qui a
été retranscrite dans la loi du 30
septembre 86 les services télévisuels
sont soumis au contrôle du csa
particulièrement vigilants pour réprimer
l'incitation à la haine
la violence et à d'autres manquements il
y a dix ans le csa avait interdit la
chaîne du hamas al-aqsa et même la
chaîne al manar or la situation en 2010
était bien moins grave que celle que
nous traversons aujourd'hui
alors ma question est simple monsieur le
ministre allez vous engager des
procédures pour interdire la chaîne al
jazeera et la chaîne trt des réseaux
français merci
le regroupement il le fait chaque
hassine effectivement quand a été
dissout la semaine dernière en conseil
des ministres un groupement créé en 2004
et baraka city qui ce matin à la demande
du président de la revue qui a été
dissous une association qui a été créée
en 2010 et d'autre à la demande du
président de la république nous pensons
d'ailleurs au ccf sera présenté à la
demande du premier ministre dans les
semaines qui viennent vous évoquez la
question des réactions internationales
je vous ferai remarquer devant vous que
le discours du président de la
république était juste celui qui
consistait à vouloir couper des
influences étrangères des affaires
intérieures françaises
parce que nous en france nous
considérons que les français de
confession musulmane n'appartiennent à
aucune puissance étrangère et nous
considérons qu'il s'agit d'affaires
française respectant la souveraineté
française et d'une des gnons toute
responsabilité à quelques dirigeants
d'un pays aussi grand soit-il que le
peuple turc par exemple et de ses
dirigeants pour se mêler des affaires
françaises troisièmement vous avez
évoqué la question des chaînes
télévisées
je voudrais apporter de réponse sous
l'autorité du premier ministre
le csa a des dispositions c'est une
autorité administrative indépendante
je sais que le premier ministre a un nom
du président de la république avec la
ministre en charge de la communication
et la culture aura l'occasion d'évoquer
cela avec le président du csa pour
qu'une éventuelle mesure soit prise et
l'autorité ni strativa dépendantes
répondra auprès du premier ministre mais
surtout nous avons une négociation très
importante celle de la directive que met
en place la commission européenne et
premier ministre est allé la semaine
dernière avec clément bonne discuté avec
la présidente de la commission avec le
commissaire thierry breton pour que la
directive dite dsk qui permet de lutter
contre la haine en ligne
effectivement un certain nombre de
vecteurs de communication qui pourrait
être encadré pour ne pas dire interdit
et transposé en loi française soit fait
dans la loi dite séparatisme que j'aurai
l'honneur de porter devant le parlement
je suis sûr qu'à ce moment là vous
aiderez la france avoir les moyens de
lutter contre ses ennemis de l'extérieur
suis je suis un peu déçu je vais pas
attendre la loi des séparatismes et
monsieur le ministre nous on nous avons
des attaques tous les jours les attaques
qui sont insupportables et qui ont été
lancés contre le président de la
république française ne doivent pas ne
doit pas continuer le csa a les moyens
avec la directive de prendre des mesures
de suspension provisoire
je pense que c'est extrêmement important
qu'on attende pas une directive
européenne et un texte à venir pour
prendre des décisions vous savez très
bien et je crois conclut samuel patil a
payé que ces vecteurs de haine peuvent
entraîner de la violence physique sur
nos concitoyens il faut agir
c'est le président ma question s'adresse
au ministre des affaires étrangères
depuis des mois la turquie de monsieur r
2 one multiplie les provocations à
l'égard de ses alliés occidentaux
chantage aux flux migratoires achats
d'armes russes pour fragiliser le temps
forages gaziers illégaux dans les eaux
grec et chypriote offensive contre nos
alliés kurde en syrie ingérence en libye
pis encore de manière irresponsable
au lieu d'agir en faveur de la paix la
turquie attise le terrible conflit du
haut karabagh en envoyant des avions des
drones suicide et des mercenaires pour
soutenir l'offensive de l'azerbaïdjan
contre l'arménie
ceci n'est pas encore suffisant alors
que la france vient de traverser un
drame épouvantable
le président turc offense par ses propos
le président de la république insultant
par là même notre pays tout entier
comble de l'inacceptable c'est un
amalgame inadmissible avec la situation
des juifs dans les années 30 qui donne
la nausée
alors monsieur le ministre va-t-on
encore une fois de plus c'est sans
réagir
supporter longtemps d'être le bouc
émissaire
de la crise économique et politique qui
secoue la turquie si la turquie nous
trouve aussi infréquentable
va-t-on par exemple continuer à prêter
chaque année 300 millions d'euros 3
milliards depuis dix ans à ce pays et
cette année l'afd qui s'apprête à monter
à porter ce montant à 400 millions
connaissez vous monsieur le ministre un
banquier qui vous prêtent de l'argent
pour se faire copieusement insulté alors
me dit-on oui la france a aussi des
intérêts comme ses voisins des intérêts
économiques en turquie je ne le mets
connais pas mais l'appel au boycott des
produits français déjà une réponse et
devrait nous inciter à beaucoup plus de
lucidité pour l'avenir de nos
entreprises dans ce pays alors ma
question est bien simple
quelles mesures allez vous prendre ici
en france et aussi au conseil européen
de décembre où nos amis sont un petit
peu mou on va dire sur leur soutien pour
sanctionner le dirigeant nationaliste
qui veut jouer à l'empereur ottoman
alors qu'il fait offense à son peuple et
aussi à l'histoire même de la turquie je
rejoins en tout point ce que vous dites
sur la turquie
le dernier épisode qui repousse chaque
jour les frontières de l'inacceptable du
président erdogan qui a insulté le prêt
de la république
merci pour cette unité dans le soutien
est révélateur non pas d'un moment de
tension passagers mais d'une stratégie
d'ensemble que vous avez décrite qui est
celle de la turquie ne multiplié les
provocations tous azimuts
c'est toujours le même objectif exercer
une pression maximale sur ses voisins et
singulièrement bien sûr sur l'union
européenne
nous avons trop longtemps été naïf et je
crois que puisque vous rappeler les
propos qui ont été tenus à l'égard dû
prendre la république c'est l'honneur de
la france et c'est l'honneur dû prendre
la république d'avoir tout au long des
derniers mois en particulier
essayez de dessiller l'europe ni
européenne sur ce qu'est la réalité du
régime turc actuel ce qu'est la réalité
de la politique étrangère turque car
c'est la même stratégie du haut karabakh
à la libye en passant par la
méditerranée orientale et les insultes
dont vous faisiez est temps je crois que
nous avons était le fer de lance de
cette prise de conscience européenne qui
vous avez raison
n'est pas encore suffisante mais les
mots de solidarité qui ont été exprimées
ces derniers jours par l'ensemble des
dirigeants européens sans ambiguïté sont
aussi un fait nouveau qui marque le que
le consensus évolué vers une position de
fermeté qui a défendu la france
nous allons aller plus loin et vous avez
raison nous continuerons cette stratégie
de réactions françaises et européennes
cela peut passer par de nouvelles
sanctions je rappelle que la france en
avait été à l'initiative
l'an dernier après des forages déjà dans
les eaux chypriotes nous avons un
rendez-vous au conseil européen de
décembre et nous pousserons évidemment
en faveur de mesures européennes de
réaction forte dont l'outil possible des
sanctions faut être précis aussi ça ne
doit pas être le résumé de notre
politique étrangère y compris à l'égard
de la turquie et le prix dans la
république n'a pas hésité non plus à
avoir des mesures de réaction par une
présence militaire renforcée par exemple
en méditerranée orientale
cet été un point précis sur la question
que vous soulevez des financements
français et européens l' agence
française de développement est active
depuis 2004 en turquie elle doit elle
est en train de le faire revoir sa
politique d'intervention d'évidence en
turquie je tiens à signaler pour qu'il
n'y ait aucune ambiguïté que d'ores et
déjà il n'y a pas de subvention versée
la turquie il ya semble de prêt qui ne
transite pas par l'état turc et qui
soutiennent un certain nombre d'actions
de la société civile mais nous reverrons
aussi cette politique européenne et
française de prêt à la turquie parmi
d'autres instruments de réponse dans la
prochain dans les prochains mois
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur le 18 octobre
dernier le conseil de défense a annoncé
que deux cent trente et une personnes
étrangères en situation irrégulière est
soupçonné de radicalisation serait
reconduite dans leur pays d'origine
au delà du cas particulier se pose la
question de l'efficacité de notre
système en matière de retour dans les
pays d'origine des personnes en six
étrangères en situation irrégulière sur
notre territoire en 2019 plus de 122 me
l'obligation de quitter le territoire
national ont été prononcées moins de
15000 ont été exécutés en 2018
dans cet hémicycle le sénat a voté une
disposition assez simple qui
consisterait pour obtenir des laissez
passer consulaires des pays sources de
conditionner
vie l'obtention de visas au fait que les
pays acceptent de recevoir leurs
ressortissants étrangers sur leur
territoire dès lors qu'ils sont en
france en situation irrégulière compte
tenu des circonstances mais au delà de
celle ci même mais c'est le ministre
pourriez-vous reprendre à votre charge
cette proposition du sénat qui
malheureusement avait fait l'objet d'un
refus du gouvernement à l'époque et d'un
désaccord de l'assemblée nationale à
l'époque
vous avez raison les étrangers en
situation irrégulière qui sont
définitivement après des décisions de
justice dans ce qu'ils ont fait recours
parce que nous sommes un état de droit
et qu'ils ont eue docu tf une obligation
de quitter le territoire national doit
retourner dans leur pays
c'est une évidence et nous devons
appliquer le droit
si je ressors de la période du coc vide
puisque assemble le problème notamment
le fait qu'il n'y ait pas pendant
plusieurs mois des espaces aériens
ouverts notamment avec les pays de ce
qui arrive et vous et que c'est quand
même un sujet sur lequel
l'administration veut peut être en
difficulté
il ya la question des laissez passer
consulaires la reconnaissance que ces
citoyens sont bien des citoyens des pays
qui viennent sur le territoire national
je suis prêt à étudier toutes les
dispositions qui conformément au droit
permettent le retour dans les bonnes
positions de ces étrangers en situation
irrégulière j'aimerais cependant pas que
votre démonstration des mondes que ce
gouvernement serait laxiste et que
lorsque c'est une responsabilité le
détestiez courageux puisque dans la
moyenne des cinq entre 2007 et 2012
vous étiez à 12000 parents reconduite à
la frontière et que le gouvernement du
président de la république ont compris
être idiot vide et en est à 18 milles
vous aurez constaté 2002 différence ne
devrait pas qu'ils aient de liens non
plus entre étrangers et personnes
radicaliser ce qu'il faudrait monsieur
le président c'est être fermes sont nos
principes sur la liberté d'expression
quand j'entends le président votre
groupe ce matin sur rtl dire je cite
monsieur retailleau qui donne des leçons
de fermeté à tout bout de champ oui à la
caricature mais avec une forme de
respect et ben non monsieur le présent
recueil où la liberté d'expression est
totale
même quand ça gêne elle concerne toutes
les religions et c'est avec ce genre de
format monsieur ciotti vous adhériez
corrigés monsieur abad vous à corriger
et oui vous devriez retirer vos propos
parce que je crois monsieur prison
retailleau que ça avec des propos comme
ceux ci on n'encourage pas le président
de la république et le gouvernement à
être fermes comme nous le sommes depuis
ce matin et la période de 2020 compte
tenu de la situation sanitaire peut
poser des difficultés
je ne conteste pas d'ailleurs les
chiffres que je vous donnais sont sus de
en revanche au delà de la situation
particulière je trouve qu'il serait
utile
naturellement une fois les voies de
droit épuisé et que la situation
irrégulière de l'étranger soit
définitive que l'on puisse travailler à
ce sujet car si naughton n'obtenant pas
n'obtenons si nous n'obtenons pas pardon
excusez moi de laisser passer consulaire
dans de bonnes conditions et de la part
des pays sources nous n'y arriverons
jamais et malheureusement le
conditionnement en tous les cas le fait
de dire que nous ne donnerons pas de
visa si nous n'avons pas cessé passer
consulaires peut-être un moyen de
discussion vraiment le sénat s'y était
engagé je souhaite que nous puissions
continuer là-dessus mais c'est une
ministre verte depuis le 27 février
nous vous êtes vous nous vous
interrogeons sur l'adéquation des moyens
de santé publique à la maîtrise et la
prise en charge de l'épidémie
depuis le 27 février qu'il s'agisse des
questions gouvernement de la commission
des affaires sociales de la commission
denquête vous nous répondez nous sommes
prêts le 14 juillet le président
république disait nous sommes prêts pour
la deuxième vague permettrait
aujourd'hui en attendant ces annonces de
ce soir et la précipitation
la mise en scène qui est la dramaturgie
qui est fait depuis 48 heures dans la
presse de douté de cette affirmation du
14 juillet monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui les français sont très
inquiets leur inquiétude tient
l'épidémie mais le tient aussi à la
manière dont le gouvernement leur parle
parce que vous êtes habile monsieur
verrons vous maîtrisez le verbe vous
nous parlez avec énergie et on a même
souvent un peu de d'empathie pour vous
vous faites un job qui est pas un job
facile mais cette habileté
elle est aussi fait beaucoup de semi
vérités semi vérités sur les tests semi
vérités sur la stratégie d'isolement
semi vérités sur les lits de réanimation
vous en annonces et 14000 je pense qu'il
y en aura environ 7500
semi vérités sur les vaccins anti-grippe
vous avez répondu tout à l'heure un
collègue mais là encore on n'a pas bien
vu qu'elle était votre stratégie
alors monsieur le ministre les français
sont un peuple éclairé responsable et
mature
quand allez vous sortir de la posture
politique voire même politicienne pour
leur parler à hauteur de ce qu'ils sont
madame la sénatrice rossignol c'est vous
qui avez parlé de politique politicienne
je vais donc vous me permettre pour une
fois de vous répondre en politique
politicienne madame la sénatrice
c'est la triste qu'est ce que j'aurais
aimé que de votre questions surgissent
une idée une proposition allait une
orientation générale à laquelle ni la
france ni l'europe ni les états unis
n'aurait songé pour lutter contre la
pandémie la plus meurtrière de notre
histoire contemporaine
madame la sénatrice qu'est ce que
j'aurais aimé un mot pour les français
solidaires fort fort contre vents et
marées et qui attendent de leur classe
politique non pas qu'il fasse de cette
lutte contre l'épidémie je ne sais quel
marchepied vers je ne sais quelles
élections à venir mais bien un grand
moment de capacité à faire preuve d'un
minimum d'unité nationale madame la
sénatrice qu'est ce que j'aurais aimé
que vous ayez l'honnêteté de rappeler
que semaine après semaine j'étais ici
dans cet hémicycle pour rappeler à la
représentation nationale que l'épidémie
n'était pas finie que nous avions pas
terrassé de virus et que nous devions
rester armée tout au long de l'année au
pouvoir lutter contre l'épidémie mais
non vous vous livrez par votre question
une nouvelle attaque en piqué une
nouvelle attaque en piqué madame la
sénatrice
on ne sauve pas des vies avec des
attaques politiques on ne soutient pas
les soignants avec des attaques
politiques
on n'encourage pas les français à tenir
bon dans cette période difficile avec
des attaques politiques avec des
attaques politiques avec des attaques
politiques comme celles que vous faites
avec la polémique permanente que
certains essayent d'instaurer un moment
où nous avons besoin de solidarité et
d'unité nationale
je ne crois pas madame la sénatrice que
vous ayez participer et aider votre pays
dans la lutte contre l'épidémie en
soutien des français
monsieur le ministre le sénat
mon groupe le groupe socialiste mais
d'autres groupes aussi vous ferons des
propositions nous on nous en avons déjà
fait nombreuses mais la manière dont
vous traitez nos propositions qu'il
s'agisse de l'examen des projets de loi
qu'il s'agisse de nos discussions plus
techniques de mise en oeuvre de la
politique sanitaire ne nous ne nous fera
pas renoncer à vous faire des
propositions mais permettez nous aussi
dire aux français que vous voyagez seul
vous pilotez sol et vous n'écoutez
jamais ni le parlement ni la société
civile
[Musique]